senators again that's the schedule 12 45
the senators
will be back in the chamber and at one
o'clock the chief justice will be sworn
in by senator strom thurman and then the
senators the numbers will continue to be
on your screen we'll get to calls in
just a couple of minutes but first we're
going to show you the scene earlier
today
just before 10 o'clock when congressman
henry hyde chairman of the house
judiciary committee and 12 of his
colleagues walked to the senate and
informally told the u.s senate the
articles of impeachment that the house
passed and there were two articles they
presented to the u.s senate this was the
scene an hour and a half ago
man behind the grace
who are all these other people
out of the way jesus
it's me
stations
foreign
oh
all right
it's sad
oh
let's go
yes
[Music]
okay any quorum is present
the sighted arms will present the
managers
on the part of the house of
representatives
senator bianora
either take your seats or go to the
cloakrooms
um
[Music]
my
mr president
and members of the senate
i announced the presence of the managers
on the part of the house of
representatives to conduct proceedings
on behalf of the house
concerning the impeachment of william
jefferson clinton
president of the united states
the managers on the part of the house
will be received and escorted to the
well of the senate
decided arms will make the proclamation
hear ye hear ye hear ye
all persons are commanded to keep silent
on pain of imprisonment while the house
of representatives is exhibiting to the
senate of the united states
articles of impeachment against william
jefferson clinton
president of the united states
the managers on the part of the house
will proceed
mr president the managers on the part of
the house of representatives are here
and present and ready to present the
articles of impeachment which have been
preferred by the house of
representatives against william
jefferson clinton president of the
united states the house adopted the
following resolution which with the
permission of the senate i will read
house resolution 10
resolve that in continuance of the
authority conferred in house resolution
614 of the 105th congress
adopted by the house of representatives
and delivered to the senate on december
19
1998 mr hyde of illinois mr
sensenbrenner of wisconsin mr mccullum
of florida mr gigas of pennsylvania mr
kennedy of florida mr boyer of indiana
mr bryant of tennessee mr shabbat of
ohio mr barr of georgia mr hutchinson of
arkansas mr cannon of utah mr rogan of
california and mr graham of south
carolina
are appointed managers to conduct the
impeachment trial
against william jefferson clinton
president of the united states
that a message be sent to the senate to
inform the senate of these appointments
and that the manager so appointed may in
connection with the preparation and the
conduct of the trial
exhibit the articles of impeachment to
the senate and take all other actions
necessary which may include the
following
one employing legal clerical and other
necessary assistance and incurring such
other expenses as may be necessary to be
paid from amounts available to the
committee on the judiciary under
applicable expense resolutions or
from the applicable accounts of the
house of representatives too
sending for persons and papers and
filing with the secretary of the senate
on the part of the house of
representatives any pleadings in
conjunction with or subsequent to the
exhibition of the articles of
impeachment that the managers considered
necessary
with the permission of the senate i will
now read the articles of impeachment
house resolution 611 resolved
that william jefferson clinton president
of the united states is impeached for
high crimes and misdemeanors and that
the following articles of impeachment be
exhibited to the united states senate
articles of impeachment exhibited by the
house of representatives of the united
states of america
in the name of itself and of the people
of the united states of america against
william jefferson clinton president of
the united states of america
in maintenance and support of its
impeachment against him
for high crimes and misdemeanors article
one
in his conduct while president of the
united states william jefferson clinton
in violation
of his constitutional oath faithfully to
execute the office of president of the
united states and the best of his
ability preserve protect
and defend the constitution of the
united states and in violation of his
constitutional duty to take care
that the laws be faithfully executed has
willfully corrupted and manipulated the
judicial process of the united states
for his personal gain and exoneration
impeding the administration of justice
in that
on august 17 1998 william jefferson
clinton swore to tell the truth the
whole truth and nothing but the truth
before a federal grand jury of the
united states contrary to that oath
william jefferson clinton willfully
provided perjurious false and misleading
testimony to the grand jury concerning
one or more of the following one
the nature and details of his
relationship with a subordinate
government employee
two prior perjurious false and
misleading testimony he gave in a
federal civil rights action brought
against him
three
prior false and misleading statements he
allowed his attorney to make to a
federal judge in that civil rights
action and for
his corrupt efforts to influence the
testimony of witnesses and to impede the
discovery of evidence in that civil
rights action
in doing this william jefferson clinton
has undermined the integrity of his
office has brought disrepute on the
presidency has betrayed his trust
as president and has acted in a manner
subversive
of the rule of law and justice to the
manifest injury of the people of the
united states wherefore william
jefferson clinton by such conduct
warrants impeachment and trial
and removal from office and
disqualification to hold and enjoy any
office of honor trust or profit under
the united states article 2
in his conduct while president of the
united states
william jefferson clinton in violation
of his constitutional oath faithfully to
execute the office of president of the
united states and to the best of his
ability
preserve protect and defend the
constitution of the united states and in
violation of his constitutional duty to
take care
that the laws be faithfully executed has
prevented obstructed
and impeded the administration of
justice and has to that end engage
personally and through his subordinates
and agents in a course of conductor
scheme designed to delay impede cover up
and conceal the existence of evidence
and testimony related to a federal civil
rights action brought against him in a
duly instituted judicial proceeding the
means used to implement this course of
conduct or scheme
included one including
included one or more of the following
acts one
on or about december 17 1997
william jefferson clinton corruptly
encouraged a witness
in a federal civil rights action brought
against him to execute a sworn affidavit
in that proceeding that he knew to be
perjurious false and misleading
two on about december 17 1997
william jefferson clinton corruptly
encouraged a witness in a federal civil
rights action brought against him to
give perjurious false and misleading
testimony if and when called to testify
personally in that proceeding three
on or about december 28 1997 william
jefferson clinton corruptly engaged in
encouraged or supported a scheme to
conceal evidence that had been
subpoenaed in a federal civil rights
action brought against him
four beginning on or about december 7
1997 and continuing through and
including january 14 1998 william
jefferson clinton intensified and
succeeded in an effort to secure job
assistance to a witness
in a federal civil rights action brought
against him in order to corruptly
prevent
the truthful testimony of that witness
in that proceeding at a time
when the truthful testimony of that
witness would have been harmful to him
five
on january 17 1998 at his deposition in
a federal civil rights action
brought against him william jefferson
clinton corruptly allowed his attorney
to make false and misleading statements
to a federal judge characterizing an
affidavit in order to prevent
questioning deemed relevant by the judge
such false and misleading statements
were subsequently acknowledged by his
attorney in a communication to that
judge honor about january 18 and january
20
uh 21
1998
william jefferson clinton related a
false and misleading account of events
relevant to a federal civil rights
action brought against him to a
potential witness in that proceeding in
order to corruptly influence the
testimony of that witness
on or about january 21 23 and 26
1998 william jefferson clinton
made false and misleading statements to
potential witnesses in a federal grand
jury proceeding in order to corruptly
influence the testimony of those
witnesses
the false and misleading statements made
by william jefferson clinton were
repeated by the witnesses to the grand
jury causing the grand jury to receive
false and misleading information in all
this william jefferson clinton has
undermined the integrity of his office
has brought disrepute on the presidency
has betrayed his trust as president and
has acted in a manner subversive of the
rule of law
and justice to the manifest injury of
the people of the united states
wherefore william jefferson clinton by
such conduct
warrants impeachment and trial
and removal from office and
disqualification to hold and enjoy any
office of honor trust or profit
under the united states
past the house of representatives
december 19
1998 newt gingrich speaker of the house
of representatives attest robin h carl
clerk
mr president that completes the
exhibition
of the articles of impeachment against
william jefferson clinton president of
the united states the manager's request
that the senate take order for the trial
the managers now request leave to
withdraw
[Music]
thank you mr manager hyde the senate
will notify the house of representatives
when it is ready to proceed
later
mr president
and majority leaders recognized mr
president i modify my previous request
and unanimous consent that the presiding
officer be authorized to appoint a
committee of six senators three upon the
recommendation majority leader and three
upon the recommendation democratic
leader to escort the chief justice into
the senate chamber
without objection it is so ordered now
mr president i ask unanimous consent
that the senate stand in recess until
the hour of 12 45 today and before the
chair puts this request i would say as a
reminder to all senators that at 1 pm
today following a live quorum the chief
justice and all senators will be sworn
in i thank all senators objections
without objection so
engine recess
that was the preceding guidelines for
the trial one of those favoring
conviction in this case is easily south
carolina first of all i'd like to say i
love alone she's just wonderful but uh
i'm for conviction i'll tell you why i
get so tired here people can't say this
is just about sex and it's private well
if he were doing it in the in his white
house bedroom that had been one thing
but he was doing in the people's oval
office and i'd like to remind people he
was receiving oral sex while talking to
a center about our troops in bosnia now
if that's not putting the nation second
to his personal needs well people need
to re-examine thank you thanks south
carolina once again live gavel to gavel
coverage of the trial of the president
here on c-span 2 re-airing each day that
the trial is in session on our companion
network on c-span at 8 p.m eastern time
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's go
right
[Music]
hey uh
if y'all wouldn't let's take a seat
sit down
the senate will convene as a court of
impeachment
the chaplain will offer a prayer
almighty god
whose providential care has never varied
all through our nation's history
we ask you for a special measure of
wisdom
for the women and men of this senate
as they act as jurors in this
impeachment trial
you have been our nation's refuge and
strength in triumphs and troubles
prosperity and problems
now dear father
help us through this difficult time
as you guided the senators to unity and
matters of procedure
continue to make them one in their
search for the truth
and in their expression of justice
keep them focused
in a spirit of nonpartisan patriotism
today
and in the crucial days to come
bless the distinguished chief justice as
he presides over this trial
we commit to you all that is said and
done
[Music]
and ultimately
decided
in your holy name
amen amen
[Music]
the sergeant-at-arms will make the
proclamation
hear ye hear ye hear ye
all persons are commanded to keep silent
on pain of imprisonment while the senate
of the united states is sitting for the
trial of the articles of impeachment
exhibit exhibited by the house of
representatives against william
jefferson clinton president of the
united states
the presiding officer recognizes the
majority leader thank you mr chief
justice
i send a resolution to the desk
providing for appropriated equipment and
furniture in the senate chamber and ask
that it be agreed to and the most to
reconsider be laid on the table
the clerk will report the resolution by
title senate resolution 17 to authorize
the installation of appropriate
equipment and furniture in the senate
chamber for the impeachment trial
without objection the resolution is
considered and agreed to
mr chief justice i now ask unanimous
consent that the four privileges be
granted to the individuals listed on the
document are sent to the desk during the
closed impeachment proceedings of
william jefferson clinton president of
the united states
without objection it's so ordered
mr chief justice i ask unanimous consent
that the secretary of the senate be
authorized to print as a senate document
all documents filed by the parties
together with other materials for the
convenience of all senators
without objection it is so ordered
mr chief justice i'm about to submit a
series of unanimous consent agreements
and a resolution for the consideration
of the senate
in addition to these matters i would
like to state for the information all
senators that pursuant to senate
resolution 16 the evidentiary record on
which the party's presentations over the
next days will be based was filed by the
house managers yesterday and was
distributed to all senators through
their offices these materials are now
being printed at the government printing
office as senate documents the initial
documents of the record have been
printed and are now at each senator's
desk as the printing of the rest of the
volumes of the record is completed over
the next few days that will also be
placed on the senator's desk for their
convenience
without objection the journal the
proceedings of the trial are approved to
date
the presiding officer submits to the
senate for printing in the senate
journal the following documents
the precept issued on january 8 1999
the writ of summons issued on january 8
1999
and the receipt of summons dated january
8 1999
the presiding officer submits to the
senate for printing in the senate
journal the following documents which
were received by the secretary of the
senate pursuant to senate resolution 16
106 congress first session
the answer of william jefferson clinton
president of the united states to the
articles of impeachment exhibited by the
house of representatives against him on
january 8 1999
received by the secretary of the senate
on january 11 1999
the trial brief filed by the house of
representatives received by the
secretary of the senate on january 11
1999
the trial brief filed by the president
received by the secretary of the senate
on january thirteenth nineteen ninety
nine
the replication of the house of
representatives received by the
secretary of the senate on january
thirteenth nineteen ninety nine
the rebuttal brief filed by the house of
representatives received by the
secretary of the senate on january 14
1999
without objection the foregoing
documents will be printed in the
congressional record
i would like to inform members of the
senate and the parties in this case of
my need to stand on occasion to stretch
my back i have no intention that the
proceedings should be any way
interrupted when i do so
the presiding officer notes the presence
in the senate chamber of the managers on
the part of house of rev the house of
representatives and counsel for the
president of the united states
personal to the provisions of senate
resolution 16 the managers for the house
of representatives have 24 hours to make
presentation of their case
the senate will now hear you
the presiding officer recognizes mr
manager hyde to begin the presentation
of the case for the house of
representatives
distinguished counsel for the president
and
senators
we are brought together on this solemn
and historic occasion to perform
important duties assigned to us by the
constitution
we want you to know how much we respect
you and this institution and how
grateful we are for your guidance and
your cooperation
with your permission we the managers of
the house are here to set forth the
evidence
in support of two articles of
impeachment against president william
jefferson clinton
you are seated in this historic chamber
not to embark on some great legislative
debate which these
stately walls have so often witnessed
but to listen to the evidence as those
who must sit in judgment
to guide you in this grave duty you've
taken an oath of impartiality
with the simple words i do
you have pledged to put aside personal
bias and partisan interest and to do
impartial justice
your willingness to take up this calling
has once again reminded the world
of the unique brilliance of america's
constitutional system of government
we are here mister chief justice and
distinguished senators
as advocates for the rule of law
for equal justice under the law
and for the sanctity of the oath
the oath
in many ways the case you will consider
in the coming days is about those two
words i do
pronounced at two presidential
inaugurations by a person whose spoken
words have singular importance to our
nation
and to the great globe itself
more than 450 years ago sir thomas moore
former lord chancellor of england
was imprisoned in the tower of london
because he had in the name of conscience
defied the absolute power of the king
as the playwright robert bull tells it
more was visited by his family
who tried to persuade him to speak the
words of the oath that would save his
life even while in his mind and heart
he held firm to his conviction that the
king was in error
moore
refused as he told his daughter margaret
when a man takes an oath meg
he's holding his own self in his hands
like water and if he opens his fingers
then
he needn't hope to find himself again
sir thomas moore the most brilliant
lawyer of his generation a scholar with
an international reputation the center
of a warm and affectionate family life
which he cherished
went to his death rather than take an
oath in vain
members of the senate
what you do over the next few weeks will
forever
affect the meaning of those two words i
do
you are now stewards of the oath
its significance in public service and
our cherished system of justice will
never be the same after this
depending on what you decide it will
either be strengthened
in its power to achieve justice or it
will go the way
of so much of our moral infrastructure
and become a mere convention
full of sound and fury
signifying nothing
the house of representatives has named
myself and 12 other members as managers
of its case
i have the honor of introducing those
distinguished members and explaining
how we will make our initial
presentation
the gentleman from wisconsin
representative jim sensenbrenner will
begin the presentation with an overview
of the case
representative sensenbrenner is the
ranking republican member of the house
judiciary committee and has served for
20 years
in 1989 representative sensenbrenner was
a house manager in the impeachment trial
of judge walter l nixon
who was convicted on two articles of
impeachment for making false and
misleading statements before a federal
grand jury
following representative sensenbrenner
will be a team of managers who will make
a presentation
of the relevant facts of the case
from the very outset of this ordeal
there has been a great deal of
speculation
and misinformation about the facts
that has been unfortunate for everyone
involved we believe
a full presentation of the facts and the
law by house managers will be helpful
representative ed bryant from tennessee
was a united states attorney from the
western district of tennessee
as a captain in the army representative
bryant served in the judge advocate
general corps and taught at the united
states military academy at west point
representative bryant will explain the
background of events that led to the
illegal actions of the president
following representative bryant
representative aza hutchinson from
arkansas
will give a presentation of the factual
basis for article two
obstruction of justice
representative hutchinson is a former
united states attorney for the western
district of arkansas
next you will hear from representative
jim rogan of california
representative rogan is a former
california state judge
and los angeles county deputy district
attorney
representative rogan will give a
presentation of the factual basis for
article 1 grand jury perjury
this should conclude our presentation
for today
tomorrow representative bill mccullum of
florida
will tie all of the facts together and
give a factual summation
representative mccullum is chairman of
the subcommittee on crime
a former naval reserve commander and
member of the judge advocate general
corps
following the presentation of the facts
a team of managers will present the law
of perjury and the law of obstruction of
justice and how it applies to the
articles of impeachment before you today
while the senate has made it clear that
a crime is not essential to impeachment
and removal from office
these managers will explain how
egregious
and criminal the conduct alleged in the
articles of impeachment is
this team includes representative george
geekes of pennsylvania
representative steve shabbat of ohio
representative bob barr of georgia and
representative chris cannon of utah
representative geekes is the chairman of
the subcommittee on commercial and
administrative law
and in 1989 he served as a manager of
the impeachment trial of judge alcy
hastings
who the senate convicted on eight
articles
for making false and misleading
statements under oath
and one article of conspiracy to engage
in
bribery representative geekes is a
former assistant district attorney
representative shabbat serves on the
subcommittee on crime and has experience
as a criminal defense lawyer
representative barr is a former united
states attorney for the northern
district of georgia where he specialized
in public corruption he also has
experience as a criminal defense
attorney
representative cannon has had experience
as the deputy associate solicitor
general of the department of the
interior and as a practicing attorney
that should conclude our presentation
for friday
on saturday three managers will make a
presentation on constitutional law as it
relates to this case
there's been a great deal of argument
about whether the conduct alleged in
these articles rises to the level of
removable offenses
this team's analysis of the precedence
of the senate an application of the
facts of this case will make it clear
that the senate has established the
conduct alleged in the articles
to be removable offenses
in this presentation you will hear from
representative charles kennedy of
florida
representative steve boyer of indiana
and representative lindsey graham of
south carolina
representative kennedy is chairman of
the subcommittee on the constitution and
one of the leading voices on
constitutional law in the house
representative bowyer served in the
united states army as a member of the
judge advocate general corps
where he was assigned a special
assistant to the united states attorney
in virginia
he also served as a deputy to the
indiana attorney general
representative graham served in the air
force as a member of the judge advocate
general corps and as a south carolina
assistant attorney
following the presentation of the facts
the law of perjury and obstruction of
justice and constitutional law
mr rogan and myself will give you a
final summation
and closing to our initial presentation
mr sensenbrenner
mr chief justice
distinguished counsel to the president
and senators
and his third annual message to congress
on december 7 1903
president theodore roosevelt said
quote
no man is above the law and no man is
below it
nor do we ask any man's permission when
we require him to obey it
obedience to the law is demanded as a
right
not asked as a favor unquote
we are here today because president
william jefferson clinton decided to put
himself above the law
not once
not twice but repeatedly
he put himself above the law when he
engaged in a multi-faceted scheme to
obstruct justice during the federal
civil rights case of paula corbin jones
versus william jefferson clinton at all
he put himself above the law when he
made perjurious
false and misleading statements under
oath during his grand jury testimony on
august 17
1998.
in both instances he unlawfully
attempted to prevent the judicial branch
of government a co-equal branch from
performing its constitutional duty to
administer equal justice under law
the united states house of
representatives has determined that the
president's false and misleading
testimony to the grand jury and his
obstruction of justice in the jones
lawsuit
are high crimes and misdemeanors within
the meaning of the constitution
should the senate conduct a fair and
impartial trial which allows each side
to present its best case
then the american public can be
confident that justice has been served
regardless of the outcome
we hear much about how important the
rule of law is to our nation and our
system of government
some have commented this expression is
trite
but whether expressed by these three
words or others
the primacy of law over the rule of
individuals is what distinguishes the
united states from most other countries
and why our constitution is as alive
today
as it was 210 years ago
the framers of the constitution devised
an elaborate system of checks and
balances to ensure our liberties by
making sure that no person
institution or branch of government
became so powerful that a tyranny could
ever be established in the united states
of america
we are the trustees of that sacred
legacy
and whether the rule of law and faith in
our nation emerges stronger than ever
or are diminished irreparably depends
upon the collective decision of the
message each senator chooses to send
forth in the days ahead
the evidence you will hear relates
solely to the president's misconduct
which is contrary to his constitutional
public responsibility to ensure the laws
be faithfully executed
it is about it is not about the
president's affair with a subordinate
employee an affair that was both
inappropriate and immoral
mr clinton has recognized that this
relationship was wrong
i give him credit for that
but he has not owned up to the false
testimony
the stonewalling and legal hair
splitting and obstructing the courts
from finding the truth
in doing so he has turned his affair
into a public wrong
and for these actions he must be held
accountable to the only constitutional
means the country has available
the difficult and painful process of
impeachment
impeachment is one of the checks the
framers gave to congress to protect the
american people from a corrupt or
tyrannical executive or judicial branch
of government
because the procedure is cumbersome
and because a two-thirds vote in the
senate is required to remove an official
following an impeachment trial
safeguards are there to stop congress
from increasing its powers at the
expense of the other two branches
the process is long
it is difficult
it is unpleasant
but above all it is necessary to
maintain the public's trust and the
conduct of their elected officials
elected officials such as myself and
yourselves who through our oaths of
office have a duty to follow the law
fulfill our constitutional
responsibilities
and protect our republic from public
wrongdoing
the framers of the constitution
envisioned a separate and distinct
process in the house and in the senate
they did not expect the house and the
senate to conduct virtually identical
proceedings with the only difference
being that conviction in the senate
requires a two-thirds vote
that is why the constitution reserves
the sole power of impeachment to the
house of representatives and the sole
power to try all impeachments to the
senate
history demonstrates different processes
were adopted to reflect very different
roles
in the case of president andrew johnson
no hearings were held or witnesses
called by the house on the president's
decision to remove secretary of war
stanton from office
the house first approved a general
article of impeachment that simply
stated that president johnson was
impeached for high crimes and
misdemeanors
five days later a special house
committee drew up specific articles
eleven articles were passed by the house
all but two of which were based upon
president johnson's alleged violation of
the tenure of office act by his actions
in removing secretary of war stanton
the trial was then conducted with
witnesses in the senate
in the case of president nixon the house
judiciary committee passed three
articles of impeachment
based not upon their own investigation
but upon the evidence gathered by the
urban committee
the patman committee the joint tax
committee and material from the special
prosecutor in various court proceedings
nine witnesses were called at the end of
the impeachment inquiry
five of them at the request of the white
house and their testimony was not at the
center of the impeachment articles
in the judge walter nixon impeachment in
1989
a trial with live witnesses was held
even after the senate rejected by less
than a two-thirds vote a defense motion
to dismiss one article of impeachment on
the grounds that it did not commit
constitute an impeachable offense
the house managers submit witnesses are
essential to give heightened credence to
whatever judgment the senate chooses to
make on each of the articles of
impeachment against president clinton
the matter of how this proceeding will
be conducted remains somewhat unsettled
senate impeachment precedent has been to
hold a trial
and in every impeachment case the senate
has heard from live witnesses
should the president's council dispute
the facts as laid out by the house of
representatives the senate will need to
hear from live witnesses in order to
reach a proper and fair judgment as to
the truthful facts of this case
the house concluded the president made
progeria's false and misleading
statements before the grand jury
which the house believes constitutes a
high crime and misdemeanor
our entire legal system is based upon
the courts being able to find the truth
that's why witnesses must raise their
right hand
and swear to tell the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth
that's why there are criminal penalties
for perjury and making false statements
under oath
the need for obtaining truthful
testimony in court is so important that
the federal sentencing guidelines have
the same penalties for perjury as for
bribery
the constitution specifically names
bribery as an impeachable offense
perjury is the twin brother of bribery
by making the penalty for perjury the
same as that for bribery congress has
acknowledged that both crimes are
equally serious
it follows that perjury and making false
statements under oath which is a form of
perjury be considered among the high
crimes and misdemeanors the framers
intended to be grounds for impeachment
the three judicial impeachments of the
1980s were all about lies told by a
federal judge
judge claiborne was removed from office
for lying on his income tax returns
judge hastings was removed for lying
under oath during a trial
and judge nixon was removed from making
false statements under oath to a grand
jury
in each case the senate showed no
leniency to judges who lie
their misconduct was deemed impeachable
and more than two-thirds of the senate
voted to convict them
if the senate is convinced that
president clinton lied under oath and
does not remove him from office the
wrong message is given to our courts
those who have business before them
and to the country as a whole
that terrible message is that we as a
nation have set a lower standard for
lying under oath for presidents than for
judges
should not the leader of our country be
held to at least a as high a standard as
the judges he appoints should not the
president be obliged to tell the truth
when under oath just as every citizen
must
should not our laws be enforced equally
your decision in this proceeding will
answer these questions and set the
standard of conduct of public officials
in town halls and courtrooms everywhere
and the oval office for generations
justice is never served by the placing
of any public official above the law
the framers rejected the british law of
the king can do no wrong when they wrote
our basic law in 1787
any law is only as good as its
enforcement and the enforcement of the
law against the president was left to
congress through the impeachment process
a senate conviction of the president in
this matter will reaffirm the
irrefutable fact that even the president
of the united states has no license to
lie under oath
deceiving the courts is an offense
against the public
it prevents the courts from
administering justice and citizens from
receiving justice
every american has a right to go to
court for redress of wrongs as well as
the right to a jury trial
the jury finds the facts
the citizens on the jury cannot
correctly find the facts
absent truthful testimony
that's why it's vital that the senate
protect the sanctity of the oath to
obtain truthful testimony
not just during judicial proceedings but
also during legislative proceedings as
well
witnesses before the congress
whether presidential nominees seeking
senate confirmation to high post in the
executive or judicial branches
federal agency heads testifying during
investigative hearings or witnesses at
legislative hearings giving their
opinions on bills are sworn to tell the
truth
eroding the oath to tell the truth means
that congress loses some of its ability
to base its decisions upon truthful
testimony
lowering the standard of truthfulness of
sworn testimony will create a cancer
that will keep the legislative branch
from discharging its constitutional
functions as well
mister chief justice we are here today
because william jefferson clinton
decided to use all means possible both
legal and illegal to subvert the truth
about his conduct relevant to the
federal civil rights suit brought
against him by mrs paula jones
defendants in civil lawsuits cannot pick
and choose which laws and rules of
procedure they follow and which they
will not
that's for the trial judge to decide
whether the defendant be president or
pauper
in this case a citizen claimed her civil
rights were violated when she refused
then governor clinton's advances and was
subsequently harassed at work
denied merit pay raises and finally
forced to quit the court ruled she had
the right to obtain evidence showing
other women including miss lewinsky got
jobs promotions and raises after
submitting to mr clinton and whether
other women suffered job detriments
after refusing similar advances
when someone lies about an affair and
tries to hide the facts
they violate the trust their spouse and
their family put in them
but when they lie about it during legal
proceedings
and obstruct the parties from obtaining
evidence
they prevent the courts from
administering justice
that is an offense against the public
made even worse when a poor and
powerless person seeks the protection of
our civil rights laws from the rich
or powerful
when an american citizen claims his or
her civil rights have been violated we
must take those claims seriously
our civil rights laws have remade our
society for the better
the law gives the same protections that
the child denied entry to a school or
college based upon race
as to an employee claiming
discrimination at work
once the whole is punched in civil
rights protections for some
those protections are not worth as much
for all
many in this senate have spent their
lives advancing individual rights
their successful efforts have made
america a better place
in my opinion this is no time to abandon
that struggle no matter what the
political mood and no matter what the
political consequence
some have said that the false testimony
by the pres given by the president
relating to sex should be excused since
as the argument goes everyone lies about
sex
i would ask the senate to stop and think
about the consequences of adopting that
attitude
our sexual harassment laws would become
unenforceable
since every sexual harassment suit is
about sex
and much of the domestic violence
litigation in our country is at least
partly about sex
if defendants in these types of suits
are allowed to lie about sex
justice cannot be done
and many victims
mostly women will be denied justice
mister chief justice the house has
adopted two articles of impeachment
against president william jefferson
clinton
each meets the standard of high crimes
and misdemeanors and each is amply
supported by the evidence
article one impeaches the president for
perjurious faults and misleading
testimony during his august 17 1998
appearance before a grand jury of the
united states
in four areas
first the nature and details of his
relationship with a subordinate
government employee
second prior persuarious faults and
misleading testimony he gave in a
federal civil rights action brought
against him
third prior false and misleading
statements he allowed his attorney to
make to a federal judge in that federal
civil rights lawsuit
fourth his corrupt efforts to influence
the testimony of witnesses and to impede
the discovery of evidence in that
federal civil rights action
the evidence will clearly show that
president clinton's false testimony to
the grand jury was not a single or
isolated instance which could be excused
as a mistake
but rather a comprehensive and
calculated plan to prevent the grand
jury from getting the accurate testimony
in order to do its job
furthermore it is important to dispel
the notion that the president's false
testimony before the grand jury simply
relates to the details of the
relationship between president clinton
and miss lewinsky
these charges make up only a small part
of article one
the fact is the evidence will show that
president clinton made numerous
perjurious faults and misleading
statements regarding his efforts to
obstruct justice
before describing what the evidence and
support of article one shows
it is also important to clearly
demonstrate that the senate has already
decided that making false statements
under oath to a federal grand jury is an
impeachable offense
the last impeachment decided by the
senate that of united states district
judge walter l nixon jr of the united
states district court for the southern
district of mississippi
involved the judges making false
statements under oath to a federal grand
jury
precisely the same charges contained in
article one against president clinton
following a unanimous 417 to nothing
vote in the house the senate conducted a
full trial and removed judge nixon from
office on the two articles charging
false statements to a grand jury
by votes of 89 to 8 and 78 to 19.
the senate was clear that the specific
misconduct that is making false
statements to a grand jury which was the
basis for the judge's impeachment
warranted his removal from office and
the senate proceeded to do just that
these votes a little more than nine
years ago on november third 1989
set a clear standard that lying to a
grand jury is grounds for removal from
office
to set a different standard in this
trial is to say that the standard for
judicial truthfulness during grand jury
testimony is higher than that of
presidential truthfulness
that result would be absurd
the truth is the truth
and the lie is a lie
there cannot be different levels of
truth for judges than for presidents
the president's perjurious faults and
misleading statements regarding his
relationship with miss lewinsky began
early in his grand jury testimony
these statements included parts of the
prepared statement the president read at
the beginning of the testimony
he referred or reverted to this
statement at least 19 times during the
course of the testimony
further the evidence will show the
president made other false statements to
the grand jury regarding the nature and
details of his relationship with miss
lewinsky at times when he did not refer
to his prepared statement
second the evidence will show that the
president piled perjury upon perjury
when he provided prejudice false and
misleading statement testimony to the
grand jury concerning prior for jurious
faults and misleading testimony given in
mrs paula jones case
on two occasions the president testified
to the grand jury that his deposition
testimony was the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth and that he
was required to give a complete answer
to each question asked of him during the
deposition
that means he brought to the grand jury
is untruthful answers to questions at
the deposition
third the evidence will show the
president provided a prejudious false
and misleading testimony to a federal
grand jury regarding his attorney's use
of an affidavit he knew to be false
during the deposition and mrs paula
jones case before federal judge susan
weber wright
the president denied that he even paid
attention to mr bennett's use of the
affidavit
the evidence will show he made this
denial because his failure to stop his
attorney from utilizing a false
affidavit at a deposition would
constitute an obstruction of justice
the evidence will also show the
president did not admit that mr
bennett's statement was false because to
do so would be to admit that he had
perjured himself earlier that day during
the grand jury testimony as well as at
the deposition
fourth the evidence will show that the
president provided for jurious false and
misleading testimony to the grand jury
concerning his corrupt efforts to
influence the testimony of witnesses and
to impede the discovery of evidence in
mrs paula jones civil rights action
the evidence will show that these
statements related to at least four
areas
first is statements relating to gifts
exchanged between the president and miss
lewinsky
the subpoena served on miss lewinsky in
the jones case required her to produce
each and every gift she had received
from the president
these gifts were not turned over as
required by the subpoena
but ended up under miss betty curry's
bed in the sealed container
the president denied under oath that he
directed miss curry to get the gifts but
the evidence will show that miss curry
did call ms lewinsky about them and that
there was no reason for her doing so
unless directed by the president
second the president made prejudious
false and misleading statements to the
grand jury
regarding his knowledge that the
lewinsky affidavit submitted at the
deposition was untrue
the evidence will show that the
president testified falsely on this
issue on at least three
separate occasions during his grand jury
testimony
he also provided false testimony on
whether he encouraged miss lewinsky to
file a false affidavit
third
the president made false and misleading
statements to the grand jury by reciting
a false accounts of the facts regarding
his interactions with miss lewinsky and
miss curry who is a potential witness
against him in mrs jones case
the record reflects the president tried
to coach ms curry to recite inaccurate
answers to possible questions should she
be called as a witness
the evidence will show the president
testified to the grand jury that he was
trying to figure out what the facts were
but in reality the conversation with
miss curry consisted of a number of very
false and misleading statements
finally
the president made perjurious false and
misleading statements through aids
regarding his relationship with miss
lewinsky
in his grand jury testimony the
president tried to have it both ways on
this issue
he testified that his statements the
aids were both true and misleading
true
and misleading
the evidence will show that he met with
four aides who would later be called to
testify before the grand jury
they included mr sidney blumenthal mr
john podesta mr erskine bowles and mr
heraldickis
each of them related to the grand jury
the untruths they had been told by the
president
i have recited this long catalog of
false statements to show that the
president's false statements to the
grand jury were neither few and numbered
nor isolated but rather pervaded his
entire testimony
there can be no question that the
president's false statements to the
grand jury were material to the subject
of the inquiry
grand juries are utilized to obtain
sworn testimony from witnesses to
determine whether a crime has been
committed
the attorney general and the special
division of the united states court of
appeals for the district of columbia
circuit
appointed an independent council
pursuant to law
and added areas of inquiry because they
believe that there was evidence that the
president may have committed crimes
grand jury testimony relevant to the
criminal probe is always material to the
issue of materiality whether someone has
committed a crime
based upon the president and the judge
nixon impeachment
the law the facts and the evidence
if you find the president made
perjurious false and misleading
statements under oath to the grand jury
i respectfully submit that your duty
will be to find william jefferson
clinton guilty with respect to article
one
and to remove him from office
article two impeaches william jefferson
clinton for preventing obstructing and
impeding the administration of justice
in mrs paula jones case by either
directly or through subordinates and
agents engaging in a scheme to delay
impede
cover up and conceal the existence of
evidence and testimony relating to mrs
jones federal civil rights action
as in the case of article one
the president's direct and indirect
actions were not isolated mistakes but
were multi-faceted actions specifically
designed to prevent mrs paula jones from
having her day in court
while the senate determined in the judge
nixon trial that the making of false
statements to a federal grand jury
warranted conviction and removal from
office
no impeachment on an obstruction of
justice charge has ever reached the
senate
therefore this article is a matter of
first impression
however the impeachment inquiry of the
house judiciary committee into the
conduct of president richard nixon
as well as the relevant federal criminal
statutes clearly show president
clinton's actions to be within the
definition of high crimes and
misdemeanors contained in the
constitution
the first article of impeachment against
president nixon approved by the
judiciary committee charged mr nixon
with quote
engaging personally and through his
subordinates and agents
than the course of conduct or plan
designed to delay impede and obstruct
the investigation of such unlawful entry
to cover up conceal and protect those
responsible
and to conceal the existence and scope
of other unlawful activities unquote
the article charged that the
implementation of the plan included nine
separate areas of misconduct
included among these were
one
making or causing to be made false and
misleading statements to investigative
officers and employees of the united
states
two
withholding relevant and material
evidence from such persons
three
approving condoning acquiescing in and
counseling witnesses with respect to the
giving of false and misleading
statements to such persons as well as in
judicial and congressional proceedings
history shows us that president nixon's
resignation was the only act that
prevented the senate from voting on this
article
and that the president's conviction and
removal from office were all but certain
there are two sections of the federal
criminal code placing penalties on those
who obstruct justice
title 18 united states code section 1503
punishes quote
whoever corruptly or by threats or force
obstructs or impedes or endeavors to
influence obstruct or impede the due
administration of justice unquote
the courts have held that this section
relates to pending judicial process
which can be a civil action
mrs jones case fits that definition at
the time of the president's actions as
alleged in article two
as does the office of independent
council investigation
title 18 united states code section 1512
punishes quote
whoever corruptly persuades another
person or attempts to do so or engages
in misleading conduct toward another
person with intent to influence delay or
prevent the testimony of any person in
an official proceeding
or cause or induce any person to
withhold testimony or withhold a record
document or other object from an
official proceeding unquote
the evidence will show that president
clinton's actions constituted
obstruction of justice in seven specific
instances as alleged in article two
paragraph one alleges that on or about
december 17 1997 the president
encouraged miss lewinsky who would be
subpoenaed as a witness in ms jones case
two days later to execute a sworn
affidavit he knew would be perjurious
false and misleading
the evidence will show the president's
actions violated both federal criminal
obstruction statutes
second
article two alleges that on or about
that same day the president corruptly
encouraged miss lewinsky to give for
jurious false and misleading testimony
if and when called to testify personally
in that proceeding
ms lewinsky on the witness list at that
time could have been expected to be
required to give live testimony in the
jones case and in fact she was
subsequently subpoenaed for a deposition
in that case
the evidence will show the president's
actions violated both federal criminal
obstruction statutes
third article two alleges that honor
about december 28 1997
the president corruptly engaged in
encouraged or supported a scheme to
conceal evidence which had been
subpoenaed in mrs jones civil rights
case
he did so by asking miss betty curry to
retrieve evidence from ms lewinsky that
had been subpoenaed in the case of jones
versus clinton
the evidence will show the president's
actions violated the second
federal criminal obstruction statute
fourth
article two alleges that beginning on or
about december 7 1997 and continuing
through and including january 14 1998
the president intensified and succeeded
in an effort to secure job assistance to
miss lewinsky in order to corruptly
prevent her truthful testimony in the
jones case at a time when her truthful
testimony would have been harmful to him
while miss lewinsky had sought
employment in new york city long before
the dates in question helping her find a
suitable job was clearly a low priority
for the president and his associates
until it became obvious she would become
a witness in the jones case
the evidence will clearly show an
intensification of that effort after her
name appeared on the witness list
this effort was ultimately successful
and the evidence will show that the
president's actions violated both
federal obstruction statutes
fifth article two alleges that on
january 17 1998 the president corruptly
allowed his attorney to make false and
misleading statements to judge wright
characterizing the lewinsky affidavit in
order to prevent questioning deemed
relevant by the judge
the president's attorney robert bennett
subsequently acknowledged such false and
misleading statements and a
communication to judge wright
the evidence will show the president's
actions clearly violated the second
federal criminal obstruction statute
sixth article two alleges that on or
about january 18th
20th and 21st 1998 the president related
a false and misleading account of events
relevant to mrs jones civil rights suit
to miss betty curry a potential witness
in the proceeding in order to corruptly
influence her testimony
the evidence will show that president
clinton attempted to influence the
testimony of miss betty curry his
personal secretary by coaching her to
recite inaccurate answers to possible
questions that might be asked of her if
called to testify in miss paula jones's
case
the president did this shortly after he
had been dispo deposed in the criminal
action excuse me in the civil action
during the deposition he frequently
referred to miss curry
and it was logical that based upon his
testimony ms curry would be called as a
witness
the evidence will show that two hours
after the completion of the deposition
the president called ms curry to ask her
to come to the office the next day
which was a sunday when miss curry
testified to the grand jury she
acknowledged that the president made a
series of leading statements or
questions and concluded that the
president wanted her to
agree with him
the evidence will show that the
president's actions violated both
statutes but most particularly section
1512.
in united states versus robolitz the
united states court of appeals for the
second circuit said quote
the most obvious example of a section
1512 violation may be the situation
where a defendant tells a potential
witness a false story as if the story
were true
intending that the witness believed the
story and testify it testify to it
before the grand jury unquote
if the president's actions do not fit
this example
i am at a loss to know what actions do
seventh and last
article two alleges that on or about
january 21st 23rd and 26 1998 the
president made false and misleading
statements to potential witnesses in a
federal grand jury proceeding in order
to corruptly influence the testimony of
those witnesses
the article further alleges these false
and misleading statements were repeated
by the witnesses to the grand jury
causing the grand jury to receive false
and misleading information
the evidence will show these statements
were made to presidential aides mr
sidney blumenthal mr erskine bowles
and mr harold ickes
they all testified to the grand jury
by his own admission seven months later
on august 17 1998
during his sworn grand jury testimony
the president said that he told a number
of aides that he did not have an affair
with miss lewinsky and did not have sex
with her
he told what made mr sidney blumenthal
that miss monica lewinsky came on to him
and that he rebuffed her
president clinton also admitted that he
knew those aides might be called before
the grand jury as witnesses
the evidence will show they were called
they related the president's fault
statements to the grand jury and that by
the time the president made his
admission to the grand jury the damage
had already been done
this is a classic violation of title 18
united states code section 1512.
the seven specific allegations of
obstruction of justice contained in
article two
were designed to prevent the judicial
branch of government
a separate and co-equal branch from
doing its work in mrs paula jones
lawsuit
based upon the allegation of article one
against president nixon in 1974
as well as the repeated and calculated
violations of two key criminal
obstruction statutes
william jefferson clinton committed an
impeachable offense
in article two the evidence is
conclusive that president clinton put
himself above the law
in obstructing justice not once not just
a few times but as a part of an
extensive scheme to prevent mrs jones
from obtaining the evidence she thought
she needed to prove her civil rights
claims
complying with the law is the duty of
all parties to lawsuits and those who
are required to give truthful testimony
a defendant in a federal civil rights
action does not have the luxury to
choose what evidence the court may
consider
he or she must abide by the law and
abide by the rules of procedure
william jefferson clinton tried to say
that the law did not apply to him during
his term of office as far as civil cases
were concerned
he properly lost that argument in the
united states supreme court in a
unanimous decision
even though the supreme court decided
that the president wasn't above the law
and that mrs jones case could proceed
william jefferson clinton decided and
decided alone to act as if the supreme
court had never acted and that judge
wright's orders didn't apply to him
what he did was criminal time and time
again
these criminal acts were in direct
conflict with the president's obligation
to take care that the laws be faithfully
executed
based upon the repeated violations of
federal criminal law
its effect upon the courts to find the
truth and the president's duty to take
care that the laws be faithfully
executed
if you find that the president did
indeed obstruct the administration of
justice through his acts i respectfully
submit that your duty will be to find
william jefferson clinton guilty with
respect to article 2 and to remove him
from office
it is truly sad when the leader of the
greatest nation in the world gets caught
up in a series of events where one
appropriate and criminal act leads to
another
and another and another
even sadder is that the president
himself could have stopped this process
simply by telling the truth and
accepting the consequences of his prior
mistakes
at least six times since december 17
1997
william jefferson clinton could have
told the truth and suffered the
consequences
instead he chose lies
perjury and deception
he could have told the truth when he
first learned that miss lewinsky would
be a witness in mrs jones case
he could have told the truth that his
civil deposition
he could have called the truth to betty
curry
he could have told the truth when the
news media first broke the story of his
affair
he could have told the truth to his
aides and cabinet
he could have told the truth to the
american people
instead he shook his finger at each and
every american and said i want you to
listen to me
and proceeded to tell a straight faced
lie to the american people
finally he had one more opportunity to
tell the truth
he could have told the truth to the
grand jury
had he told the truth last january
there would have been no independent
council investigation of this matter
no grand jury appearance
no impeachment inquiry
and no house approval of articles of
impeachment
and we would not be here today
fulfilling a painful and essential
constitutional duty
instead he chose lies and deception
despite warnings from friends
aides and members of the house and
senate that failure to tell the truth
would have grave consequences
when the case against him was being
heard by the house judiciary committee
he sent his lawyers who did not present
any new evidence or rebut the facts and
evidence sent to the house by the
independent council
rather they disputed the committee's
interpretation of the evidence by
relying on tortured convoluted and
unreasonable interpretations of the
president's words and action
during his presentation to the house
judiciary committee the president's very
able lawyer charles ruff
was asked directly
did the president lie
during his sworn grand jury testimony
mr ruff could have answered that
question directly
but he did not
and his failure to do so speaks a
thousand words
is there not something sacred when a
witness in a judicial proceeding raises
his or her right hand and swears before
god and the public to tell the truth the
whole truth and nothing but the truth
do we want to tell the country that its
leader gets a pass when he is required
to give testimony under oath
should we not be concerned about the
effect of allowing perjurious false and
misleading statements by the president
to go unpunished
on the on the truthfulness of anyone's
testimony in future judicial and
legislative proceedings
and what do we tell the approximately
115 people
now in federal prison for the crime of
perjury
the answers to all these questions ought
to be obvious
as elected officials our opinions are
frequently shaped by constituents
telling us their own story
let me tell you one
related to me about the poisonous
results of allowing false statements
under oath to go unpunished
last october when the star report was
being hotly debated
one circuit court judge for dodge county
wisconsin
approached me on the street in mayville
wisconsin
he said that some citizens had business
in his court and suggested that one of
them take the witness stand and be put
under oath to tell the truth
the citizen then asked the judge if he
could tell the truth
just like the president
how many people who have come to court
to testify under oath about matters they
would like to keep to themselves think
about what that citizen asked judge john
stork
and how will the courts be able to
administer the equal justice under law
we all hold so dear
if we do not enforce the sanctity of
that oath
even against the president of the united
states
when each of us is elected or chosen to
serve in public office
we make a contact with the people of the
united states of america to conduct
ourselves in an honorable manner
hopefully setting a higher standard for
ourselves than we expect of others
that should mean we are careful to obey
all the laws we make execute and
interpret
there is more than truth in the words a
public office is a public trust
when someone breaks that trust he or she
must be held accountable
and suffer the consequences for the
breach
if there is no accountability that means
that a president can set himself above
the law for four years
a senator for six
a representative for two
and a judge for life
that mr chief justice poses a far
greater threat to the liberties
guaranteed to the american people by the
constitution than anything imaginable
for the past 11 months the toughest
questions i've had to answer come from
parents who want to know what to tell
their children about what president
clinton did
every parent tries to teach their
children to know the difference between
right and wrong
to always tell the truth
and when they make mistakes to take
responsibility for them
and to face the consequences of their
actions
president clinton's actions at every
step since he knew miss lewinsky would
be a witness in mrs jones's case have
been completely opposite to the values
parents hope to teach their children
but being a poor example is not grounds
for impeachment
undermining the rule of law is
frustrating the court's ability to
administer justice turns private
misconduct into an attack upon the
ability of one of the three branches of
our government to impartially administer
justice
that is a direct attack upon the rule of
law in our country and a very public
wrong that goes to the constitutional
workings of our government and its
ability to protect the civil rights of
even the weakest american
what is on trial here is the truth and
the rule of law
failure to bring president clinton to
account for his serial lying under oath
and preventing the courts from
administering equal justice under law
will cause a cancer to be present in our
society for generations
those parents who have asked the
question should be able to tell their
children
that even if you are the president of
the united states
if you lie when sworn to tell the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth
you will face the consequences of that
action even when you will not accept the
responsibility for it
how those parents answered those
questions
is up to the united states senate
while how today's parents answer those
questions is important equally important
is what parents tell their children in
the generations to come
about the history of our country and as
what has set our government in the
united states of america apart from the
rest of the world
above the president's dais in this
senate chamber appears our national
motto
e pluribus unum
out of many one
when that motto was adopted more than
200 years ago the first congress
referred to how 13 separate colonies
turned themselves into one united nation
as the decades have gone by that motto
has taken an additional meeting
people of all nationalities faiths
creeds and values have come to our
shores
shed their allegiances to their old
countries and achieved their dreams to
become americans
they came here to flee religious
persecution
to escape corrupt tyrannical and
oppressive governments
and to leave behind the economic
stagnation and endless wars of their
homelands
they came here to be able to practice
their faiths as they saw fit
free of government dictates and to be
able to provide better lives for
themselves and for their families by the
sweat of their own brows and the use of
their own intellect
but they also came here because they
knew america has a system of government
where the constitution and laws protect
individual liberties and human rights
everyone yes everyone can argue that
this country has been a beacon for the
individual citizens ability to but be
what he or she can be
they fled countries where rulers ruled
at the expense of the people to america
where the leaders are expected to govern
for the benefit of the people
and throughout the years america's
leaders have tried to earn the trust of
the american people
not by their words but by their actions
america is a place where government
exists by the consent of the govern
and that means our nation's leaders must
earn and re-earn the trust of the people
with everything they do
whenever an elected official stumbles
that trust is eroded and public cynicism
goes up
the more cynicism that exists about
government its institutions and those
chosen to serve in them
the more difficult the job is for those
who are serving
and that's why it's important
yes vital that when a cancer exists in
the body politic
our job
our duty is to excise it
if we fail in our duty i fear the
difficult and dedicated work done by
thousands of honorable men and women
elected to serve not just here in
washington but in our state capitol city
halls courthouses and school board rooms
will be swept away in a sea of public
cynicism
we must not allow the beacon of america
to grow dim
or the american dream to disappear with
each waking morning
in
1974
congress did its painful duty when the
president of the united states broke the
public trust
during the last decade both houses is
impeached and removed from discipline
two speakers for breaking the rules and
their trust with the public
and less than six years ago
this honorable senate did the same thing
to a senior senator whose
accomplishments were widely praised
in each case congress did the right
thing to help restore the vital trust
upon which our government depends
it wasn't easy
nor was it always popular
but congress did the right thing
now this honorable senate must do the
right thing
it must listen to the evidence
it must determine whether william
jefferson clinton repeatedly broke our
criminal laws and thus broke his trust
with the people
a trust contained in the presidential
put into the constitution by the framers
an oath that no other federal official
must take
and oath to ensure that the laws be
faithfully executed
how the senate decides the issues to be
presented in this trial will determine
the legacy that we pass to future
generations of americans
the senate can follow the legacy of
those who made america what it is
the senate can follow the legacy of
those who put their lives fortunes and
sacred honor on the line when they
signed the declaration of independence
the senate can follow the legacy of the
framers of the constitution whose
preamble states that one of its purposes
is to establish justice
the senate can follow the legacy of
james madison and the members of the
first congress who wrote and passed the
bill of rights to preserve the liberties
of the american people
the senate can follow the legacy of
those who achieved equal rights for all
americans during the 1960s in congress
in the courts on the streets and in the
buses and at the lunch counters
the senate can follow the legacy of
those who brought president nixon to
justice during watergate and the belief
that no president can place himself
above the law
the senate can follow the legacy of
theodore roosevelt
who lived and governed by the principle
that no man is above the law
within the walls of the capitol and
throughout this great country their
rages and impassioned and divisive
debate over the future of this
presidency
this senate now finds itself in the
midst of the tempest
an already immense and agonizing duty is
made even more so because of the whims
of public opinion polls
the popularity and unpopularity of
individuals even questions over the
strength of our economy
risks assuming the true nature of this
grave and unwelcome task we have all
anguished over the sequence of events
that have led us to this the conclusive
stage of this process
we have all identified in our own minds
where it could have and should have
stopped
but we have ended up here before the
senate of the united states where you
the senators will have to render
judgment based upon the facts
a scientist in search of the basic
nature of a substance begins by boiling
away what is not of the essence
similarly the senate will sift through
the layers of debris that shroud the
truth
the residue of this painful and divisive
process is bitter even poisonous at
times
but beneath it lies the answer
the evidence will show that at its core
the question over the president's guilt
and the need for his conviction will be
clear
because at its core the issues involved
are basic questions of right versus
wrong
deceptive criminal behavior versus
honesty
integrity and respect for the law
the president engaged in a conspiracy of
crimes to prevent justice from being
served
these are impeachable offenses for which
the president should be convicted
over the course of the days and weeks to
come we the house managers will endeavor
to make this case
may these proceedings be fair and
thorough
may they embody our highest capacity for
truth and mutual respect
with these principles as our guides we
can begin with the full knowledge our
democracy will prevail and our nation
will emerge a stronger better place
our legacy now
must be not to lose the trust of the
people
should have in our nation's leaders
our legacy now
must be not to cheapen the legacies left
by our forebearers
our legacy must be to do the right thing
based upon the evidence and for the sake
of our country
the senate must not fail thank you
the chair recognizes mr manager bryant
mr chief justice
members of the senate
and my distinguished colleagues from the
bar
i am ed bryant the
representative from the seventh district
of tennessee
during this portion of the case
i along with representative asa
hutchison of arkansas
representative jim rogan of california
and representative bill mccullum of
florida
will present the factual elements of
this case
our presentation is a very broad roadmap
in which
well first we will provide i will
provide the history and background of
the parties followed by mr hutchinson
and mr rogan who will review the
articles of impeachment
mr mccollum will close
with a summation of the facts and
evidence
it is our intent to proceed in a
chronological fashion although by
necessity
there will be some overlap of the facts
and circumstances arising from what i
have called the four-way intersection
collision
of president william jefferson clinton
ms paula corbin jones
monica lewinsky and the united states
constitution
a further preference preference to my
remarks permit me to say that none of us
today are here in these hollywood
chambers
that relish doing this job before us
but we did not choose to be involved in
that reckless misconduct
nor did we make those reasoned and
calculated decisions to cover up that
misconduct
which underlies this proceeding
however this collision at the
intersection if you will
of the president
miss jones and ms lewinsky
is not in and of itself
enough to bring us together today
but had truth been a witness at this
collision
and prevailed
we would not be here
and when it was not present even under
oath
to tell the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth in a judicial
matter
the impact of our constitution must be
felt
hence we are here today to do our
respective duties
by voting these articles of impeachment
the house is not attempting to raise the
standard of conduct to perfection for
our political leadership
such a person does not walk the world
today
everyone falls short of this mark every
day
but political not life is not so much
about how an individual fails but rather
how that person reacts to that failure
for example
a person campaigning for a political
office admits wrongdoing in the past and
says he will not do that again
most people accept that commitment
he is elected
thereafter he repeats this wrongdoing
and is confronted again
what does he do
he takes steps to cover up this
wrongdoing by using his workers and his
friends he lies under oath in a lawsuit
which is very important to the person
he is alleged to have harmed
he then takes a political poll as to
whether he should tell the truth under
oath
the poll indicates the voters would not
forgive him for lying under oath
so he then denies the truth in a federal
grand jury
if this person is the president of the
united states the house of
representatives would consider articles
of impeachment
it did and voted to impeach this
president
but do not let it be argued in these
chambers that we are not electing saints
we are electing presidents
rather let it be said that we are
electing people who are imperfect and
who have made mistakes in life
but who are willing to so respect this
country
and the office of the president that he
or she will now lay aside their own
personal shortcomings
and have the inner strength to
discipline themselves sufficiently
that they do not break the law
which they themselves are sworn to
uphold
every trial must have a beginning and
this trial begins on a cold day in
january 1993.
will you please raise your right hand
and repeat after me
i william jefferson clinton do solemnly
swear i
william jefferson clinton do solemnly
swear
that i will faithfully execute the
office of president of the united states
that i will faithfully execute the
office of president of the united states
and will to the best of my ability
and will to the best of my ability
preserve protect and defend the
constitution of the united states
preserve protect and defend the
constitution of the united states so
help me god so help me god
congratulations
[Applause]
i had expected a a video portion but all
of you heard the audio portion but as
you can hear from the audio production
perhaps some of you could see
william jefferson clinton placed his
left hand on the bible in front of his
wife
the chief justice and every american
watching that day and affirmatively
acknowledged his oath of office on that
very day and again in january of 1997
the president joined a privileged few
he became only the 42nd president person
in our nation to make the commitment to
faithfully execute the office of the
president and to preserve protect and
defend the constitution
he has the complete executive power of
the nation invested in him by virtue of
this constitution
and as we progress throughout the day i
would ask that you would be reminded of
the importance of this oath and before
you as a copy of it and certainly
available as anyone would like to look
at it
on breaks
william jefferson clinton is a man of
great distinction
he is well educated with degrees from
georgetown university and yale law
school
he has taught law school courses to
aspiring lawyers he served as governor
and as attorney general for the state of
arkansas enforcing the laws of that
state
the president now directs our great
nation
he sets our agenda
and creates national policy
in a very public way
he is in fact a role model for many
president clinton also serves as the
nation's chief law enforcement officer
it is in this
primarily in this capacity that the
president appoints federal judges
within the executive branch he selected
attorney attorney general janet reno
and appointed each of the 93 united
states attorneys who are charged with
enforcing all federal civil and criminal
law and federal courthouses from
anchorage alaska
to miami florida and from san diego
california to bangor maine
before you we have another chart which
shows the schematics of the department
of justice and how
it's under the direct control of the
president through his cabinet secretary
cabinet attorney general and then down
to such functions as the federal bureau
of investigation the drug enforcement
administration the immigration
u.s marshal's office
bureau of prisons and so many other very
important legal functions this federal
government performs
as the protectors of our constitution
the united states attorneys which he
supervises through the u.s attorney and
their assistance prosecute more than 50
000 cases per year
through these appointments and his
administration's policies the president
establishes the climate in this country
for law and order
each and every one of these fifty
thousand cases handled by his united
states attorneys is dependent upon the
parties and the witnesses telling the
truth under oath
equally as important in these
proceedings is that justice not be
obstructed by tampering with witnesses
nor hiding evidence
quoting from the november 9 1998
constitution subcommittee testimony of
attorney charles j cooper a washington
d.c attorney
he states
that the crimes of perjury and
obstruction of justice like the crimes
of treason and bribery are
quintessentially offenses against our
system of government
visiting injury immediately upon society
itself
whether or not committed in connection
with the exercise of official government
powers
before the framing of our constitution
and since our laws has consistently
recognized that perjury primarily and
directly injures the body politic
for it subverts the judicial process and
this strikes at the heart of the rule of
law itself
professor gary mcdowell the director at
the institute for united states studies
at the university of london also
testified in the same hearing and
referenced the influential writer
william paley and i have this quote also
in a chart form for those of you who
would like to review it later
paley saw the issue of oath and perjury
as one of morality as well as law
because a witness swears that he will
speak the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth a person under
oath cannot cleverly lie and not commit
perjury
if the witness conceals any truth
paley rights that relates to the matter
in adjudication that is as much a
violation of the oath as to testify a
positive falsehood
shame or embarrassment cannot justify
concealment of truth
linguistic contortions with the words
used cannot legitimately conceal a lie
or if under oath perjury
and professor mcdowell concludes with a
quote from paley which accurately
provides i believe the essence of a lie
or perjurious statement quote
it is willful deceit that makes the lie
and we willfully deceive where our
expressions are not true in the sense in
which we believe the hearer apprehends
them
unquote
neither has the this united states
senate been silent on the issue of lying
under oath and perjury you have
rightfully recognized through previous
impeachment proceedings the unacceptable
nature of a high government official
lying under oath even in matters
initially arising from what would some
would argue here are merely personal
in 1989 many of you present today using
the very same standard which is section
4 of the constitution which is set forth
there for impeaching a federal judge or
the president
many of you actually voted in support of
a conviction and the removal of a u.s
district judge for lying under oath
indeed truth-telling is the single most
important judicial precept underpinning
this great system of justice we have a
system which permits the courthouse
doors to be open to all people
from the most powerful man in america to
a young woman from arkansas
on may 6 1994 paula corbin jones
attempted to open that courthouse door
when she filed a federal sexual
harassment lawsuit against president
clinton
the case arose from a 1991 incident when
she was a state employee and he the
governor further details of the
underlying allegations are not important
to us today but ms jones pursuit for the
truth is worth a careful study
the parties first litigated the question
of whether ms jones lawsuit would have
to be deferred until after the president
left office
the supreme court unanimously rejected
the president's contention and allowed
the case to proceed without further
delay
ms jones sought and appropriately won
her day in court
now incumbent with this victory
however was the reasonable expectation
that the president would tell the truth
after all this was the most important
case in the whole world
to paula corbin jones
notwithstanding this
that fact didn't happen that the
president told the truth
even after the president was ordered to
stand trial pursuing the truth for miss
jones remained an elusive task
the evidence will indicate that
president clinton committed perjury and
orchestrated a variety of efforts to
obstruct justice all of which all of
which had the effect of preventing the
discovery of truth
in paul jones's case
during the discovery phase judge susan
weber wright of the u.s district court
for the eastern district of arkansas
ordered the president to answer certain
historical questions about his sexual
relations with either either state or
federal employees
in part judge wright said the court
finds therefore that the plaintiff is
entitled to information regarding
individuals with whom the president had
sexual relations or proposed or sought
to have sexual relations and who were
during the relevant time frame state or
federal employees
judge wright validated mrs ms jones's
right to use this accepted line of
questioning in sexual harassment
litigation
more often than not
these cases involve or involved
situations where he said she said
they produce issues of credibility and
often done in pride in private because
of this they are very difficult for for
a victim to prove
such standard questions are essential in
establishing whether the defendant the
defendant has committed the same kinds
of acts before or since in other words a
pattern and practice of harassing
conduct
the existence of such corroborative
evidence or the lack thereof is likely
to be critical in these types of cases
both the equal employment opportunity
commission guidelines and the federal
rules of evidence permit the use of this
type of evidence in short a defendant's
sexual history at least with respect to
other employees is ordinarily
discoverable
in a sexual harassment lawsuit
to not expect a defendant in this type
of litigation to speak the truth
creates in its worst case a very real
danger to the entire area of sexual
harassment law which would be
irreparably damaged and in its best case
sends out a very wrong message
as such the will and intent of congress
with regard to providing protection
against sexual harassment in the
workplace would be effectively
undermined the pattern and practice
witnesses from paula corbin jones whom
paula corbin jones was entitled to
discover should have included the name
of monica lewinsky
but before i discuss miss lewinsky
further i want to offer three matters of
caution to each of us jurors in this
very important matter
number one
i do not intend to discuss the specific
details of pres of the president's
encounters with ms lewinsky
however i do not want to give the senate
the impression that those encounters are
irrelevant or lack serious legal
implications
in fact every day in courtrooms all
across america victims of sexual
harassment of rape assault
abuse
must testify
in k in many in
public cases in order to vindicate
their personal rights and society's
right to be free from these intolerable
acts
the president's lies about his conduct
in the oval office with miss lewinsky
also make these unseemly details highly
relevant
if you are to accept the president's
version about the relationship you must
in effect say to ms lewinsky that she is
the one who is disregarding the truth
but beyond this
his denials also directly contradict ms
lewinsky's testimony or not only
directly constant uh contradict miss
lewinsky's testimony but also contradict
eight of her friends and the statements
by two professional counselors with whom
she contemporaneously shared details of
her relationship
by law their testimony may serve as
proper and admissible evidence to
corroborate her side of this unfortunate
story
number two
the evidence and testimony of this
proceeding must be viewed as a whole it
cannot be compartmentalized
please do not be misled into considering
each event in isolation and then
treating it separately
remember events and words that may seem
innocent or even exculpatory in a vacuum
may well take on a sinister or even
criminal connotation when observed in
the context of the whole plot
for example we all agree that ms
lewinsky testified
quote no one ever told me to lie unquote
when considered alone this statement
would seem exculpatory
in the context of other evidence however
we see that this one statement gives a
misleading inference
of course no one said now monica you go
down there and lie
they didn't have to
based upon their previous spoken and
even unspoken words miss lewinsky knew
what was expected of her
surely if the president were to come
into the senate floor and give testimony
during this proceeding he would not tell
you that he honestly expected her to
tell the truth about their personal
relationship
after all the purpose of her filing the
false affidavit was to avoid testifying
in the jones case
and discussing the nature of their
relationship
if she had told the truth in that
affidavit instead of lying she would
have been invited to testify immediately
if not sooner
number three throughout our presentation
the facts especially as it relates to
the various illegal acts
i ask you to pay particular attention
to what i call the big picture
look at the results of those various
acts as well as who benefited
please make a mental note now if you can
and ask yourself always as you look at
each and one of these indiv illegal acts
that are presented to you a what was the
result of that illegal act and b
who benefited from that illegal act
i believe that you will find that the
evidence will show that while the
president's quote fingerprints may not
be directly on the evidence proving
these illegal acts the results of the
acts usually innure to the benefit of
the president and the president alone
subordinates and friends alike are drawn
into this web of deceit
the president is insulated
crimes are committed
justice is denied the rule of law is
suspended and this president is the
beneficiary
some examples
one
subpoenaed evidence disappears from ms
lewinsky's apartment and reappears under
miss curry's bed
what was the result of that
who had the benefit of that
two ms lewinsky's file files a false
affidavit in the jones case what's the
result of filing that false affidavit
and who benefited from that
number three the president's attorney
files the lewinsky affidavit not knowing
it was false representing to the court
that quote there is absolutely no sex of
any kind in any matter shape or form
unquote while the president sits in the
deposition
and does not object to that very
silently sits in the deposition what was
the result of that and who benefited
from that filing of the affidavit
before and finally ms lewinsky after
months of job searching in new york city
has offered a job with a fortune 500
company in new york city within 48 hours
of her signing this false affidavit
who shared the results of that with ms
lewinsky and who obtained the benefit of
that
another example occurred in a meeting
between the president and ms lewinsky in
july
july 4th 1997 to be specific when as a
part of their conversation she mentioned
that she had heard someone from newsweek
was working on a story about kathleen
willey
president had ms lewinsky back for a
visit on july 14th some 10 days later
following his return from an overseas
trip
she was questioned about the willy story
and specifically if linda tripp had been
her source
important to this point now important to
this point the president then asked ms
lewinsky to try to persuade miss tripp
to call white house counsel legal
counsel bruce lindsay
president told her to notify ms curry
the following day
quote without getting into the details
with her
even mentioning names with her
unquote whether miss curry had quote
mission accomplished
with linda
and as you will learn from mr hutchinson
who will follow me with his presentation
this is very similar to the method of
operation
with another job the president requested
be done which in that case succeeded
with a
quote mission accomplished unquote and i
ask you to watch for that in mr
hutchinson's presentation
i want to now rewind the clock
back to november of 1995.
we are here in washington where ms
lewinsky has been working at the white
house since july of 1995.
as you continue to listen to the
evidence
from this point on november the 15th
forward
remember that ms lewinsky and the
president were alone in the oval office
workplace area at least 21 times
and i have listed these in chart form
beginning again in november of 1995 and
going through in the 96
and
into the early part of 1997
uh continuing through the year
during that time they had at least 11 of
the so-called salacious encounters there
in the workplace at various times during
the day and night three in 1995 five in
1996 and three in 1997.
they also had an excess of 50 telephone
conversations most of which appear to
have been telephone calls to and from
miss lewinsky's home and i have
scheduled all these telephone calls to
show you the 50 plus telephone calls
also they exchanged exchanged some 64
gifts with the president receiving
40 of these gifts and ms lewinsky
receiving 24 of these gifts and
again we have charts
that
reflect the receipt of both sets of
gifts and again these charts will be
here in the front always available for
for your inspection
we also know that their affair began on
november 15th
interestingly there's even a conflict
here with the president
according to miss lewinsky they had
never spoken to each other up to that
point
yet he asked this unknown intern into
the private area of his office that day
the oval office her he then invited her
back to return later that day when the
two engaged in the first of these 11
acts of misconduct
now the con contradiction is in the
in the statement that the president
relied upon in his grand jury testimony
that's been referenced earlier
very carefully worded in that statement
the president
gave this testimony before the grand
jury about meeting
in this relationship and it says he says
i quote i regret that what began as a
friendship
came to include this conduct almost as
if it had evolved over a period of time
so there's very clearly a conflict there
as miss lewinsky's internship
was ending that year she did apply for
and receive a paying job with the white
house office of legislative affairs
this position allowed her even more
access to the oval office area
she remained a white house employee
until april 1996 when she was reassigned
to the pentagon
the proof would show that ms evelyn
lieberman deputy chief of staff at the
time believed that the transfer was
necessary because miss lewinsky was so
persistent
in our efforts to be near the president
although ms lieberman could not recall
having heard any rumors linking her and
the president she acknowledged that the
president was vulnerable to these kinds
of rumors
while ms lewinsky tried to return to
work in the white house her absence was
appreciated by those on the president's
staff who wanted to protect him
after she began her job at the pentagon
in april there was no further physical
contact with the president through the
1996 election and the remainder of that
year
the two communicated by telephone and
occasionally saw each other at public
events their only attempt at a private
visit in the oval office was thwarted
because ms lieberman was nearby
on december the 17th she attended a
holiday celebration at the white house
and had a photograph made shaking hands
with the president
however the evidence establishes that in
1997
ms lewinsky was more successful in
arranging visits to the white house
this was because she used the discrete
assistance of miss curry the president's
secretary to avoid the likes of ms
lieberman
ms curry indicated that she did not want
to know the details of this relationship
ms curry testified that on one occasion
when miss lewinsky told her quote as
long as no one saw us and no one did
then nothing happened unquote
miss curry responded quote don't want to
hear it don't say any more i don't want
to hear anymore unquote
early on during their secret liaisons
the two had concocted a cover story to
use if discovered
ms lewinsky was to say that she was
bringing papers to the president the
evidence will show this statement to be
false the only papers that she ever
brought were personal messages having
nothing to do with her duties or the
presidents
the cover story plays an important role
in the later perjuries and obstruction
of justice
ms lewinsky stated that the president
did not expressly instruct her to lie
he did however suggest misleading
the misleading cover story
and when when she assured him that she
planned to lie about that relationship
he responded approvingly
on the frequent occasions that she
promised that she would always deny
the relationship and always protect him
for example the president responded in
her recollection that's good or
something affirmative
not don't deny it
the evidence will establish further that
the two of them had in her words a
mutual understanding that they would
keep this private so that meant deny it
and take whatever appropriate steps
needed to be taken when she and the
president both were subpoenaed in the
jones case ms lewinsky anticipated that
as we had had on every other occasion in
every instance of this relationship we
would deny it
in his grand jury testimony president
clinton acknowledged that he and ms
lewinsky
might have talked about what to do in a
non-legal context to hide their
relationship and that he might have said
that miss lewinsky should tell people
that she was bringing letters to him or
coming to visit mrs curry miss curry
but he always stated that i never asked
miss lewinsky to lie
but neither did the president ever say
that they must now tell the truth under
oath
to the contrary as ms lewinsky stated it
wasn't as if the president called me and
said you know monica you're gonna you're
on the witness list and this is gonna be
really hard for us we're going to have
to tell the truth and be humiliated in
front of the entire world about what
we've done
which i would have thought him on
probably she said
that was different and by not calling me
and saying that you know i knew what
that meant
according to monica lewinsky
in a later but in a related but later
incident that mr hutchinson may refer to
monica lewinsky testified that president
clinton telephoned her at home around
two to three o'clock one morning on
december the 17th 1997
2 to 2 30 a.m
he told her that her name was on the
list of possible witnesses to be called
in the paula jones lawsuit
when asked what to do if she was
subpoenaed
the president suggested that she could
sign an affidavit
ms lewinsky indicated that she was a 100
percent sure
that he had suggested that she might
want to sign an affidavit
and she understood his advice to mean
that she might be able to execute an
affidavit that would not disclose the
true relationship
and when miss lewinsky agreed to that
false affidavit she told the president
by telephone that she would be signing
it
and asked him if he wanted to see it
before she signed it
according to miss lewinsky the president
responded that he did not
as he had already seen about 15 others
concurrent with these events i have just
described the evidence will further
demonstrate that as ms lewinsky
attempted to return to work at the white
house after the 1996 elections
she spoke with the president according
to betty curry the president instructed
betty curry and marcia scott the deputy
director of personnel to assist in her
return to the white house
in the spring of 1997 miss lewinsky met
with miss scott she complained with the
sub with subsequent notes to ms god and
to the president about no progress being
made with her getting back to the white
house on july third of that year she
dispatched a more formal letter to the
president in fact using the salutation
dear sir
and raising the possible threat that she
might have to tell her parents about why
she no longer had a job at the white
house if she didn't get another job
she also indicated her possible interest
with a job in new york at the united
nations
the president and ms lewinsky met the
next day in what ms lewinsky
characterized as a very emotional visit
including the president scolding her
that it was illegal to threaten the
president of the united states
their conversation eventually moved on
to other topics though primarily her
complaints about his failure to get her
a job at the white house
continuing miss lewinsky's effort to
return to work near the president there
was a july 16 meeting and a september
third telephone call with ms scott on
the evening of september 30th the
president advised ms lewinsky that he
would have chief of staff erskine bowles
help in the job search and bowles later
pass this on to john podesta although
each recall their involvement occurring
earlier in the year
just a few days later however her hopes
of a job at the white house quickly
ended
on october the 6th she had a
conversation with linda tripp who told
her that she would never return to work
at the white house and this was
according to a friend of hers on the
staff
learning this second hand was according
to ms lewinsky the straw that broke the
camel's back
she decided to ask the president for a
job in new york with the united nations
and sent him a letter to that effect on
october 7th
during an october 11th meeting with the
president she suggested he suggested
that she give him a list of new york
companies which interested her
she asked if vernon jordan might also
help her
five days later she provided the
president with her wish list and
indicated that she was no longer
interested in the un position although
she did receive an offer on november
24th and declined it on january the 5th
1998.
after this meeting with the president
arrangements were made through the
president and miss curry for miss
lewinsky to meet mr jordan
on the morning of november the 5th
1997 mr jordan spoke by telephone with
the president for about five minutes and
later met with ms lewinsky for the first
time
for about 20 minutes
according to ms lewinsky mr jordan told
her that he had spoken with the
president that she came highly
recommended and that quote we're in
business unquote
however the evidence reflects that mr
jordan took no steps to help ms lewinsky
until early december of that year after
she appeared on the witness list in the
jones case
actually mr jordan testified in his
grand jury testimony that he had no
recollection of even having met miss
lewinsky on november 5th and when he was
shown documentary evidence demonstrating
that his first meeting with ms lewinsky
occurred then he acknowledged that such
a meeting was entirely possible
so you can see that was not indeed a
high priority for mr jordan at that time
until december
for many months ms lewinsky had not been
able to find a job to her satisfaction
even without the
perceived help
of various people then in december of
1997 something happened which caused
those interested in finding ms lewinsky
a job in new york to intensify their
search
within 48 hours her of her signing this
false affidavit in the paula jones case
ms lewinsky had landed a job with a
prestigious
fortune 500 company
it is anticipated that the attorneys for
the president will present arguments
which will contest much of the
relationship with
monica lewinsky the president has
maintained throughout the last several
months that while there was no sexual
relationship or sexual affair in fact
there was some type of inappropriate
intimate contact with her
what has now been dubbed as legal
gymnastics on the part of the president
has made its appearance
other examples followed within his
definition of the word alone he denies
being alone with ms lewinsky at any time
in the oval office
he also
questions the definition of the word is
and depends on what the word is means
and how to answer a particular question
further we would expect the president to
continue to disavow knowledge of why
evidence detrimental to his defense
in the jones case was removed from ms
lewinsky's apartment
and hidden beneath ms curry's bed
or knowledge of how ms lewinsky found
herself with employment with an
employment offer in new york virtually
at the same time she finally executed an
affidavit in the jones case
unfortunately for your search for the
truth
in these proceedings the president
continues today to parse his words and
use legal hair splitting in his defense
i cite for your consideration his answer
filed with this body just days ago
for instance one
responding in part to the impeachment
article one the president persists
in a wrong-headed fashion
with his legal hair splitting of the
term sexual relations
which permits him to define that term in
such a way that
in the in the particular salacious act
that we're talking about here one person
has sex and the other person does not
as a graduate of one of the finest law
schools in america
and as a former law professor and
attorney general for the state of
arkansas the president knows better
number two
and i have this the state here this
statement here
extracted out of the president's answer
to this proceeding responding to both
articles of impeachment one and two the
president now would have you to believe
that he was
not focusing the quote was not focusing
when his attorney bob bennett was
objecting
during the deposition and attempting to
cut off
a very important line of questioning to
the president
by representing to judge wright that ms
lewinsky's affidavit proved that there's
no need to go into this testimony about
the president's life
this affidavit proves there is
absolutely no sex of any kind
ma any any kind in any manner shape or
form
and remember
this is the same president who now
pleads he he lost his focus during this
very important part of this deposition
this is the very same president who is
renowned
for his intelligence and his ability to
compartmentalize
to concentrate
to to focus on whatever matter is at
hand
and now he comes before this senate
to each one of you in his answer buying
through his attorneys and pleads that he
simply
wasn't paying attention at this very
important part during his own deposition
in tennessee we have a saying for
situations like that
it's that dog won't hunt
number three in further response to
article one
which effective he the president
effectively admits
he effectively admits his
guilt to obstruction as i as i read this
his pleadings refer to the president
himself and he states he the president
truthfully explained to the grand jury
his efforts to answer the questions in
the jones deposition without disclosing
his relationship
with miss lewinsky
so he says i i did explain to the to the
in the deposition my relationship
but without without explaining my i did
i did answer the questions in the jones
deposition in a way so as not to
disclose my relationship with ms
lewinsky
then at the bottom of the same page
he says that
he he denies that he attempted to impede
the discovery of evidence in the jones
case now think about this with me a
minute the purpose of the basically the
purpose of the jones deposition of the
president was to secure truthful
testimony about these kinds of pattern
and practice witnesses
and and therein discover the likes of
monica lewinsky that's the purpose of
being there and the president has just
admitted in his answer that he purposely
answered questions so as not to disclose
his relationship with ms lewinsky
said another way he intentionally
answered questions to avoid the
discovery of one of his female employees
with whom he was sexually involved and
that is precisely folks that's precisely
what impeding the discovery of evidence
is
so i'd ask you to if you get an
opportunity to look at that very closely
number four in his answer to article two
the president denies that he encouraged
monica lewinsky to execute a false
affidavit in the jones case
when everything is said and done
miss lewinsky had no motivation had no
reason whatsoever to want to commit a
crime by willfully submitting a false
affidavit with a court of law
she really did not need to do this at
that point in her life
but this 20-something young lady was
listening to the most powerful man in
the united states
a man she greatly admired and hearing
him effectively instruct her to file a
false affidavit
to avoid having to testify about their
relationship
and in order to do that
she had to lie about the physical
aspects of their relationship
according to her the president didn't
even want to see that actual affidavit
because he had seen 15 more just like it
and as as such
knew it would be right
number five in addition in an additional
response to article 2 the president
answers and asserts that he quote
believed that ms lewinsky could have
filed a limited but truthful affidavit
that might have enabled her to avoid
having to testify in the jones case
that is an incredible statement
that is an incredible statement given
the fact that the president knew
firsthand
of the extent of their sexual
relationship and he also knew that the
jones discovery efforts were
specifically after that type of conduct
even with the best of legal hair
splitting it's still difficult to
envision a truthful affidavit for miss
lewinsky which could have skirted the
issue enough
to avoid testifying
and
and if you really
believe the president had this belief
don't you think he would have accepted
ms lewinsky's offer to review her
affidavit and and perhaps share this bit
of wisdom he had with her before she
signed it and lied
after all
in this answer he just filed he says
he had an out for her he had a way for
her to have the best of both worlds not
to have to lie and still avoid
testifying in the jones case
why didn't he share that with her when
she gave him the opportunity if he in
fact had such an idea in those days i
suggest to you that perhaps that's a
recent idea
but even if for some reason you don't
believe
ms lewinsky offered to share that
affidavit with him don't you think it
still would have been in the president's
best interest to give ms lewinsky his
thoughts before she violated the law
with a completely false affidavit
now indeed is the time
to stop the legal gymnastics and the
legal hair splitting and to deal with
these charges and these facts
appropriately
as a house manager i believe that i can
speak for all of us out of a sense of
fairness and again request that we and
the president be permitted to call
witnesses
i would submit that the state of the
evidence is such that unless and until
the president has the opportunity to
confront and cross-examine witnesses
like ms lewinsky and himself to testify
if he desires there can be no there can
be any there cannot be any doubt of his
guilt on on the facts
a reasonable and impartial review of
this record as it presently exists
demands nothing less than a guilty
verdict
and while it's
been the consistent defense of the white
house to be inconsistent
it still comes as something of a
surprise that the president has not made
a stronger case for calling witnesses
before now he has aggressively sought
the opportunity to challenge the truth
and the veracity the veracity of
witnesses in these impeachment
proceedings
during their hearings in the house which
many believe are analogous to a grand
jury proceeding the president's
defenders and his attorneys consistently
complained of the failure to call
witnesses and the lack of fairness and
due process almost every day there were
partisan attacks from the white house
and its emissaries who were dispatched
throughout the media talk shows with the
same complaints of no witnesses and
always
our measured response was a calm
assurance that there would be witnesses
called during the trial phase
in the senate
is there any doubt that our forefathers
intended a two-step impeachment
proceeding
the house would function as the grand
jury and determine whether to charge to
impeach
then you as the trier of fact would
function as the jury to try the case and
weigh the testimony and the credibility
of the fact witnesses
in recent days some have publicly
asserted that the house was hypocritical
or is hypocritical because
we didn't call some of the fact
witnesses it now asked to call in the
senate we asked a call in the senate
for the record it must be noted that
noted that the house judiciary committee
out of an abundance of fairness did
allow the president's defense team 30
hours
in which to present any witnesses they
could have chosen and they could have
examined
but any allegation of hypocrisy
certainly appears to miss the point that
the writers of our constitution never
contemplated two separate trials
for an impeachment proceeding
but now we would respectfully request is
the time or suggest is the time for
witnesses
all americans including the president
are entitled to enjoy a private family
life free from public or governmental
scrutiny
but the privacy concerns raised in this
case are subject to limits and three of
these i will briefly discuss first the
first limit was imposed when the
president was sued in federal court for
alleged sexual harassment
the evidence in such litigation is often
personal
at times that evidence is highly
embarrassing for both the plaintiff and
the defendant as judge wright noted at
the president's january 1998 deposition
i have never had a sexual harassment
case where there has not been some
embarrassment
nevertheless congress and the supreme
court have concluded that embarrassment
related concerns must give way to the
greater interest in allowing aggrieved
parties to pursue their claims courts
have long recognized the difficulties of
proving sexual harassment in the
workplace inasmuch as improper and
unlawful behavior often takes place in
private to excuse a party who lied or
concealed evidence on the ground that
the evidence covered only personal or
private behavior would frustrate the
goals that congress and the courts have
sought to achieve
in enacting and interpreting the
nation's sexual harassment laws
that is particularly true when the
conduct that is being concealed sexual
relationship in the workplace between a
high official and a young subordinate
employee itself conflicts with these
goals
second
the second limit was imposed when judge
wright required disclosure of the
precise information that is in part the
subject of this hearing today
a federal judge specifically ordered the
president on more than one occasion
to provide requested information about
relationships with other women including
miss lewinsky
the fact that judge wright later
determined the evidence would not be
admissible at the trial or still later
granted judgment in the president's
favor does not change the president's
legal duty at the time he testified
like every litigant the president is
entitled to object to discovery
questions and to seek guidance from the
court if he thought those questions were
improper but having failed to convince
the court that his objections were well
founded the president was duty-bound to
testify truthfully and to testify fully
perjury and attempts to obstruct the
gathering of evidence can never be an
acceptable response to a court order
regardless of the eventual course or
outcome of that litigation
the supreme court has spoken forcefully
about perjury and other forms of
obstruction of justice quote in this
constitutional process of securing a
witness's testimony perjury simply has
no place whatsoever perjured testimony
is an obvious and flagrant affront to
the basic concepts of judicial
proceedings
effective restraints against this type
of egregious offense are therefore
imperative
the insidious effects of perjury curve
whether the case is civil or criminal
only a few years ago the supreme court
considered a false statement made in a
civil administrative proceeding quote
false testimony and a formal proceeding
is intolerable we must neither reward
nor condone
such a flagrant affront to the truth
seeking function of adversary
proceedings
perjury should be severely sanctioned in
appropriate cases
stated more simply perjury is an
obstruction of justice
third and final
the third limit is unique to the
president presidency is more than an
executive responsibility
it is the inspire inspiring symbol of
all that is highest in america
in purpose and ideals
as the head of the executive branch the
president has the constitutional duty to
take care that the laws are faithfully
enforced and executed the president gave
his testimony in the jones case under
oath and in the presence of a federal
judge a member of a co-equal branch of
government
he then testified before a federal grand
jury a body of citizens who had
themselves taken an oath to seek the
truth
in view of the enormous trust and
responsibility attendant to this high
office the president has a manifest duty
to ensure that his conduct at all times
complies with the law of the land
in some
perjury and acts that obstruct justice
by any citizen whether in a criminal
case a grand jury investigation a
congressional hearing a civil trial a
civil discovery proceeding are
profoundly serious matters when such
acts are committed by the president of
the united states
those acts are grounds for conviction
and removal from office
the chair recognizes the majority leader
of the proceedings for 15 minutes
mr chief justice i have just
about one minute and i'll be concluded i
will hold my request very well thank you
mr leader
as i reached the conclusion of my
presentation the timeline is now in
december of 1997.
following her november 5th meeting with
mr jordan miss lewinsky had no
communication with him or the president
for president for a month then in early
december
1997 the parties in the jones case
exchanged witness list and ms lewinsky
was scheduled as a potential witness by
the jones attorneys on about that same
day miss lewinsky attempted to make an
uninvited visit to the white house and
later that day was allowed in by the
president but it was during this time in
december of 1997 that some of the seams
began to unravel for the president i
will conclude my remarks at this point
and thank the chief justice and the
members of the senate for their careful
attention my colleague from arkansas mr
hutchinson will follow me now or at the
end of any recess as may be necessary
the chair recognized the majority leader
the manager for the interruption right
at the end of his remarks but i renew my
request unanimous consent would take a
15-minute break in proceedings
in the absence of objection it's so
ordered
so
the first day of the trial of the
president of the united states is now
standing in real life
americans will agree that this this
whole issue is not about sex prepared to
rise from the chief justice of
jacksonville thanks for your call
so
the senate will be in order
the majority leader is recognized
mr chief justice we're
prepared now to go forward with the next
manager's presentation
very well the chair recognizing manager
hutchinson
mr chief justice
senators
i'm lisa hutchinson a member of congress
from the third congressional district of
arkansas
grateful for this opportunity although
it is
comes with deep regret to be before you
i do want to tell you in advance that we
have presented to you on your tables a
selection of charts that i'll be
referring to here so everyone will have
advantage of being able to see at least
in some fashion
the charts that i'll be referring to
and
we'll have the charts here as well
this is certainly
a humbling experience for a small town
lawyer i learned to love and to respect
the law trying cases in the courtrooms
of rural arkansas
and the scene is different
in this setting in this historic chamber
with the chief justice presiding and
senators sitting as jurors but what is
at stake
remains the same
in every case
heard in every courtroom across this
great country
it is the truth it is justice it is the
law that are at stake
in this journey on earth there is
nothing of greater consequence for us to
devote our energies than to search for
the truth to pursue equal justice
and to uphold the law
it is for those reasons that i serve as
a manager
and as you i hope that i can help in
some way bring this matter to a
conclusion
for our country
this afternoon i will be discussing the
evidence
and the testimony from witnesses that we
do hope to call
and during my presentation i'll be
focusing on the evidence that
demonstrates obstruction of justice
under article 2.
now you might wonder well why are we
going to article 2 before we've covered
article 1 on perjury and the answer is
that in a chronological flow
article 2 the obstruction facts precede
much of the perjury allegations and so
following my presentation manager rogan
will present article 1 on perjury
the presentation i make will be based
upon the record
the evidence the facts that have been
accumulated
and i want you to know that i am going
to be presenting those facts and from
time to time i will argue those facts
i believe that they're well supported
the record but i urge each of you if you
ever find anything that you question
to search the record and verify the
facts because i do not intend to
misrepresent anything to this body
and in fact we'll be submitting to each
of your offices my presentation with
annotations to the record to the grand
jury transcripts which will tie in the
facts that i present to you and again i
believe and trust that you will find
that they are well supported
so let's start with obstruction of
justice
later on there will be a full discussion
of the law on obstruction of justice but
for our purposes
it is simply any corrupt act
or attempt to influence or impede the
proper functioning of our system of
justice
it is a criminal offense
a felony
and it has historically been an
impeachable offense
let me first say
it is not a crime nor an impeachable
offense to engage in inappropriate
personal conduct
nor is a crime
to obstruct or conceal imperson personal
embarrassing facts or relationships it
might be offensive but there are no
constitutional consequences
but as we go through the facts of the
case the evidence will show in this case
that there was a scheme that was
developed to obstruct the administration
of justice
and that is illegal
and the obstruction of justice is of
great consequence and significance to
the integrity of our nation when
committed by anyone
but particularly by the chief executive
of our land the president of the united
states
now mr bryant took us factually
up to a certain point pertaining
to the job search and this is chart
number one that you have before you and
this puts it in perspective a little bit
and just for a brief review
if you go back
in the calendar
back into october that's when ms
lewinsky sends the president her wish
list for a list of jobs
and then shortly after that miss curry
faxes lewinsky the resume to ambassador
richardson
and ambassador richardson gets involved
in the job search october 30 the
president promised to arrange a meeting
between lewinsky and jordan
this was set up if you go to november
in november it was actually november 5
but preceding that there was a job offer
at the un extended to miss lewinsky now
miss lewinsky decided that she was not
interested in
a job at the united nations she wanted
to go into the private sector and so
that was the purpose of november 5 of
the meeting between jordan and lewinsky
and that's when
mr jordan says we're in business
but the facts will show that there was
nothing really done in november and
that's when i will get in a little bit
more to my presentation and then we'll
go into december when some things happen
there that that picked up speed on this
issue
the obstruction for our purposes started
on december 5
1997 and that is when the witness list
from the paula jones case was faxed to
the president's lawyers at that point
the wheels of obstruction started
rolling and they did not stop until the
president successfully blocked the truth
from coming out in the civil rights case
these acts of obstruction included
attempts to improperly influence a
witness in the civil rights case that's
monica lewinsky
the procurement and filing of a false
affidavit in the case
unlawful attempts to influence the
testimony of a key witness betty curry
the willful concealment of evidence
under subpoena in that case which are
the gifts of december 28
and illegally influencing the testimony
of witnesses that is the aids that
testified before the grand jury before
the grand jury of the united states
each of these areas of obstruction
will be covered in my presentation today
as i said it began on friday december 5
when the witness list came from the
paula jones case
shortly thereafter the president learned
that the list included monica lewinsky
this had to be startling news to the
president
because if the truth about his
relationship with a subordinate employee
were known the civil rights case against
him would be strengthened and it might
have totally changed the outcome
but to compound the problem less than a
week later judge wright federal district
judge in arkansas on december 11
issued an order
and that order directed that the
president had to answer
questions concerning other relationships
that he might have had
during a particular time frame with any
state or federal employee
and when i say relationships i'm
speaking of sexual relationships and so
judge wright
entered the order that is not in your
stack but i have it here it is december
filed on december 11th in the district
court in arkansas and directs the
president that he has to answer those
questions within a time frame as mr
bryant said which is typical in
a civil rights case of this nature
now the white house knew that monica was
on the witness list the president knew
that it was likely that she would be
subpoenaed as a witness and that her
truthful testimony would hurt his case
what did the president do
what he had to do was he made sure that
monica lewinsky was on his team and
under control
and then on december 17th the president
finally called miss lewinsky to let her
know she was on the list this was a call
between 2 a.m and 2 30 a.m in the
morning
now what happened in the time between
the president learning monica lewinsky
was on the list
and when he notified her of that fact on
december 17th is very important
the president during that time frame
talked to his friend
his confidante and his problem solver
vernon jordan
mr jordan had come to the president's
rescue on previous occasions he was
instrumental in securing consulting
contracts
contracts for mr webb hubble while mr
hubbell was under investigation by the
independent council
let me parenthetically go to that point
right before mr hubble announced his
resignation
from the justice department during that
time frame there was a meeting at the
white house in which the president the
first lady and others were present
after that meeting vernon jordan agreed
to help
obtain financial assistance for mr
hubbell mr jordan then introduced mr
hubbell to the right people
the introduction was successful and mr
hubbell obtained a 100 000 contract the
right people that mr jordan contacted
happened to be the same right people for
both mr hubbell and ultimately for
monica lewinsky which is the parent
company of revlon
and so the president was aware that mr
jordan had the contacts and the tri
track record to be of assistance to the
president in delicate matters
now let's go back a little
monica lewinsky had been looking for a
good pain and high profile job in new
york since the previous july as i
pointed out
she had been offered a job at the un but
she wanted to work in the private sector
she wasn't having much success and then
in early november it was betty curry who
arranged a meeting with vernon jordan
which ultimately was on november five
at this meeting
miss lewinsky met with mr jordan for
about 20 minutes
now let's refer to mr vernon jordan's
grand jury testimony on that meeting
that occurred on november 5.
and you have that
it should be your chart number two or
exhibit two
as mr jordan testified before the
federal grand jury on march 3 1998 in
reference to the november 5 meeting he
testifies i have no recollection of an
early november meeting with miss monica
lewinsky i have absolutely no
recollection of it and have no record of
it
he goes on to testify at page 76 of the
grand jury testimony question
is it fair to say that back in november
getting monica lewinsky a job on any
fast pace was not any priority of yours
his answer i think that's fair to say
now let's stop there for a moment what
happened as a result of this meeting
no action followed whatsoever no job
interviews were arranged and there were
no further contacts with mr jordan mr
jordan made no effort to find a job for
miss lewinsky for over a month indeed it
was so unimportant to him that he had no
recollection of that early november
meeting and in fact he testified that
finding her a job was not a priority
and then you'll see that during this
time frame the president's attitude was
exactly the same and so look at the same
exhibit two
the last item on that uh chart where it
refers to monica lewinsky's grand jury
testimony and there
she is referring
uh to a december 6 meeting with the
president i think i said that i was
supposed to get in touch with mr jordan
the previous week and that things did
not work out and that nothing had really
happened yet
on the job front and the question was
did the president say what he was going
to do the answer i think he said he
would you know this was sort of typical
of him to sort of say oh i'll talk to
him i'll get on it and so you can see
from that that it was not a high
priority for the president either it was
sure i'll get to that i will do that and
it was clear from monica lewinsky that
nothing was happening but then the
president's attitude suddenly changed
what started out as a favor for betty
curry dramatically changed after miss
lewinsky became a witness
and the judge's order was issued again
on december 11th
and at that time the president talked
personally
personally to mr jordan and requested
his help in getting miss lewinsky a job
and that would be again back on exhibit
two on that chart the third item of
testimony there
back to mr jordan his grand jury
testimony may 5th of 1998. the question
is but what is also clear is that as of
this date december 11 you are clear that
at that point you had made a decision
that you would try to make some calls to
get
help to get
her a job his answer there is no
question about it and so what triggered
let's look at the chain of events
the judge the witness list came in the
judge's order came in that triggered the
president to action and the president
triggered vernon jordan into action that
chained reaction here is what moved the
job search along
now if we had mr jordan on the witness
stand which i hope to be able to call mr
jordan
you would need to probe where his
loyalties lie
listen to the tone of his voice look
into his eyes and determine the
truthfulness of his statements
you must decide whether he is telling
the truth or withholding information
and so let's go to exhibit three uh in
your
booklet
again recalling mr jordan
he testifies
about that meeting
he testifies
on his march 3 1998 grand jury testimony
i am certain
after the 11th that i had a conversation
with the president and as a part of that
conversation i said to him that betty
curry had called me about monica
lewinsky
and the conversation was that he knew
about her situation which was that she
was pushed out of the white house that
she wanted to go to new york and he
thanked me for helping her
remember what else happened on that day
again that is the same day that judge
wright ruled that the questions about
other relationships could be asked by
the jones attorneys now let's go back
again
to mr
jordan's testimony what does he say
about the involvement of the president
of the united states in regard to these
jobs
if you look at exhibit four that is in
your booklet this is again vernon
jordan's grand jury transcript of june
9th 1998. now the question is on a
different issue the question is about
why did he tell the white house that
frank carter frank carter was the
attorney for monica lewinsky that vernon
jordan arranged and introduced to monica
lewinsky he was hired and whenever at
that point that he was terminated
then
the
vernon jordan notified the president and
so the question relates to that why are
you trying to tell someone at the white
house that this happened
carter had been fired answer thought
they had a right to know why and here
the answer is what is critical for my
point the president asked me to get
monica lewinsky a job
i got her a lawyer the drudge report is
out and she has new counsel i thought
that that was information that they
ought to have
the president asked me to get monica
lewinsky a job clear
straightforward testimony no doubt about
it and then go on down to page 58 of his
grand jury testimony of june 9. the
question why did you think the president
needed to know that frank carter had
been replaced answer information
he knew that i had gotten her a job he
knew that i had gotten her a lawyer
information he was interested in this
matter he is the source of it coming to
my attention in the first place he is
the source of it coming to my attention
in the first place remember he had
already met with betty curry
nothing was happening in the november
time frame nothing was happening vernon
jordan was it was not a priority and
then the president united states called
him and it became a priority and that
is who he was acting for in trying to
get monica lewinsky a job
at this point
we do not know all that the president
was telling vernon jordan but we do know
that there were numerous calls back and
forth between mr jordan and the
president there were numerous calls
being made
by mr jordan in behalf of monica
lewinsky searching for a job and that
despite the fact that monica lewinsky
did not know that she was a witness she
did not know she was a witness the
president knew that she was a witness
during his intensified efforts to get a
job
now the president's counselors have made
a defense that the
job search started before monica
lewinsky was a witness and there was
nothing wrong with that my response to
that is it is true there is nothing
wrong with a public official under the
right circumstances helping someone get
a job and what might have started out
being innocent if you accept that
argument
cross the line
cross the line
whenever it was tied and interconnected
with the president's desire to get a
false affidavit from monica lewinsky and
whenever the job is out there and
hearing the false affidavit you will see
that they are totally interconnected
intertwined interrelated and that's
where the line is crossed into
obstruction
for example when the president was
waiting on ms lewinsky to sign the false
affidavit in the jones case during the
critical time in january a problem
developed
the job interviews were unproductive
despite the numerous calls by mr jordan
on one particular day monica called mr
jordan and said the interview with
revlon did not go well mr jordan what
did he do
he picked up the phone to the ceo of the
president accompany mr pearlman
to as vernon jordan testified
make things happen if they could happen
that is the request from mr jordan to
the ceo of a country after a job
interview with monica lewinsky did not
go well what happened
things happened
he did he made things happen monica
lewinsky got a job the affidavit was
signed and the president was informed by
mr jordan through betty curry that the
mission was accomplished end quote
the question here is not why did the
president do a favor for an ex-intern
but why did he use the influence of his
office to make sure it happened
the answer is that he was willing to
obstruct impede justice by improperly
influencing a witness in order to
protect himself in a civil rights case
the next step step in the obstruction is
the false affidavit and this is directly
related to the job mission the president
needed the signature of ms lewinsky on
the false affidavit and that was assured
by the efforts to secure her a job
again the president brought miss
lewinsky into the loop on december 17th
over 10 days after the witness list was
received by the president now the
president was ready to tell monica the
news and that time frame is important
he gets the witness list he could have
called monica lewinsky immediately but
he waited seven days because it because
he needed to make sure the job situation
was in gear and in fact
the day after if you look back on
exhibit one you'll see that the day
after the december 17
time frame that she was informed that
she was on the witness list the next day
they already had lined up job interviews
for her so she felt confident but she
was notified on december 17th between 2
and 2 30 a.m her phone rang
it was the president of the united
states
the president said that he had seen the
witness list in the case and her name
was on it
miss lewinsky asked what she should do
if subpoenaed
and the president responded quote
well maybe you can sign an affidavit end
quote
well how would this work
both parties knew that the affidavit
would need to be false and misleading in
order to accomplish the desired result
clearly truthful testimony by monica
lentz lewinsky would make her a witness
would not keep her away from testifying
only a false affidavit would avoid the
deposition and so let me look at what
i've marked as exhibit 4.1
which is just a review of the key dates
on this job search again november 5th
was the first meeting between jordan and
lewinsky
in november nothing happened
according to jordan not a high pro
priority december 5th the president
receives the witness list the 11th
things intensified with judge wright's
order the 11th the president talks to mr
jordan about the job for monica he gets
into action on the 17th they're ready to
tell monica that she is on the witness
list and then on the 19th she has
actually served with a sabine
and so again remember that after she was
finally notified it was the next day
that she had the job interviews
now still we're going to spend some time
on this december 17th the
conversation the day that monica
lewinsky was notified that she was on
the witness list
and during that conversation the
president had a very pointed suggestion
for miss lewinsky and a suggestion that
left no doubt about his purpose and the
intended consequences he did not say
specifically go in and lie
and this is something that you will hear
that
and monica lewinsky testified in her
grand jury testimony the president never
told me to lie
well how do you tell people to lie you
can tell them
the facts that they can use that would
in substance be a false statement
or you can say go in and lie and make up
your own false testimony the president
chose to give her the ideas as to what
she could testify to
that would be false but he never said
the words you need to go in and lie
and so what he did say to her was quote
you know you can always say you were
coming to see betty or that you were
bringing me letters end quote
that
ladies and gentlemen the senate is a
false representation is a false
statement that he is telling miss
lewinsky to utter
now remember at this point the president
knows she's a witness and what does he
do as evidenced by the testimony of
monica lewinsky he encourages her to lie
to say you can always say you are coming
to see betty or that you're bringing me
letters
it should also be remembered that the
president
when questioned about encouraging monica
lewinsky to lie has denied these
allegations and therefore there is
certainly a conflict in the testimony it
is our belief that ms lewinsky's
testimony is credible and that she has
the motive to tell the truth
because of her immunity agreement with
the independent council where she gets
in trouble only if she lies whereas the
president has the motive to cover up and
to testify falsely
in order to understand the significance
of this statement made by the president
it is necessary to recall the cover
stories that the president
and mr lewinsky had previously concocted
in order to deceive those people
who might inquire it was to see those
people that they worked with
the difference in the initial cover
stories though to protect the president
and monica from an embarrassing personal
relationship from friends and co-workers
in the media
now it is in a different arena with the
pending civil rights case and miss
lewinsky being on the witness list
despite the legal responsibilities the
president made the decision to continue
the pattern of line which ultimately
became an instruction of the
administration of justice
we're still on december 17th
when the president called monica at 2 am
on that particular day to tell her she
was on the witness list he made sure
remind her of the cover stories miss
lewinsky testified that when the
president brought up the cover story she
understood that the two of them would
continue their pre-existing pattern of
deception
and it became clear that the president
had no intention of making his
relationship with a subordinate federal
employee an issue in that civil rights
case no matter what the federal court
told him he needed to answer
and he would use lies deceit and
deception to carry out that purpose it's
interesting to note that the president
when he was asked by the grand jury
whether he remembered
calling monica lewinsky at 2 am
on that december 17 day he responded
quote no sir i don't but it would it is
quite possible that that happened end
quote
and when he was asked whether he
encouraged monica lewinsky to continue
the cover stories of coming to see betty
or bringing the letters he answered
quote
i don't remember exactly what i told her
that night end quote
this is not a denial and therefore i
believe you should accept the testimony
of monica lewinsky if you say in your
mind well i'm not going to believe her
then
if you say in your mind well i'm not
going to believe her
then you should first give us the
opportunity to present this witness so
that you as jurors could fairly and
honestly determine her credibility
as expected two days later on december
19th
miss lewinsky received the subpoena to
testify in the jones case and this sets
about an immediate flurry of activity
there is a series of telephone calls
between miss lewinsky vernon jordan the
president and his staff you will see
this pattern of telephone calls repeated
and generated at any point in time when
it appears that the truth may be told in
the civil rights case
now let's look at exhibit five which is
the activity on friday december 19th
this is the day that monica lewinsky is
served with a subpoena
now
if you look after mr jordan is notified
that monica lewinsky has served with
subpoena what does he do
the 351 352 notation jordan telephones
the president and talks to deborah
schiff his assistant
so the subpoena is issued monica calls
jordan jordan immediately calls the
president
he makes some other telephone calls
lewinsky that day meets with mr jordan
and request that the jordan notify the
president about her subpoena and this is
at 4 47 p.m
presumably in the middle of that meeting
at 501 pm the president of the united
states telephones mr jordan
and jordan notifies the president about
miss lewinsky's subpoena
and then that's whenever he arranges for
miss lewinsky's attorney jordan
telephones attorney frank carty carter
for the representation and that night
vernon jordan goes to the white house
later that evening to meet privately
with the president on these particular
issues
now in that meeting and i'm speaking of
the meeting that happened late
that night at the white house mr jordan
told the president again that miss
lewinsky had been subpoenaed and related
to the president to the president the
substance and details of his meeting
with ms lewinsky it wasn't a casual
conversation the details were discussed
including
her fascination with the president and
other such issues
this led mr jordan to ask the president
about his relationship with miss
lewinsky
and the response by the president united
states was the first of many denials to
his friends and aides
the president stated in his deposition
that he does not recall that meeting
but you should remind yourselves of the
testimony and description provided by
vernon jordan when he said quote the
president has an extraordinary memory
end quote in fact we all know that he is
world famous for that memory
now the subpoena had been delivered but
the testimony of monaco was not
scheduled until january 23 and the
president's deposition which is even
more critical was not scheduled until
january 17th and so the president and
his team had some time to work
the work was not the business of the
nation
but it was the distraction of
self-preservation in the civil rights
case
under the plan mr jordan would be the
buffer he would obtain an attorney which
was mr carter and that attorney would
keep mr jordan informed on the progress
of the representation including
reviewing a copy of the affidavit
knowing about the motion to quash and
the general progress of the
representation
all along the way
when mr jordan gets information what
does he do with that mr jordan keeps the
president informed both about the
affidavit and the prospects of the job
in new york on which ms lewinsky was
totally dependent on the help of her
friends in high places
now let me go back again there is
nothing wrong with helping someone get a
job but we all know there's one thing
forbidden in public office we must avoid
a quid pro quo
that is this is for that but vernon
jordan testified that he kept the
president informed on the status of the
false affidavit
the job search and the status of ms
lewinsky's representation why
is this just idle chatter with the
president united states
or are these matters the president is
vitally interested in and in fact
coordinating
mr jordan answers this question himself
at page 25 of his grand jury testimony
where he testified quote i knew the
president was concerned about the
affidavit and whether it was whether or
not it was signed
it
he was obviously
and that was his march 5th 98
grand jury testimony the president was
concerned not just about the affidavit
but specifically whether it was signed
the president knew that monica was going
to make a false affidavit he was so
certain of the contents that when monica
lewinsky asked if he wanted to see it he
told her no
that he had seen 15 of them
besides the president had suggested the
affidavit himself and he trusted mr
jordan to be certain to keep things
under control
in fact that was one of the main
purposes of mr jordan's continued
communication with monica lewinsky's
attorney frank carter
even though
mr jordan testifies at one point he
never had any substantive discussions on
the representations of mr carter he
contradicts himself in his march 3 grand
jury testimony where he states quote
mr carter at some point told me this is
after january that she had signed the
affidavit that he had filed a motion to
quash her subpoena and that i mean there
was no reason for accountability but he
reassured me that he had things under
control end quote
mr jordan was aware of the substance of
the
drafting of the affidavit the
representation the motion across quash
even ahead apart in the re-drafting this
was clearly important to mr jordan and
it was clearly important to the
president
now let's go to the time when the false
affidavit was actually signed january 5
98 and these will be exhibits 7 8 and 9
that is in front of you
let's go to january 5.
this is sort of a summary of what
happens on that day
ms lewinsky meets with her attorney mr
carter for now
mr carter drafts the affidavit of miss
lewinsky
that's on the deposition and then let's
go the second paragraph miss lewinsky
telephones betty curry stating that she
needs to speak to the president
this is about an important matter
specifically that she was anxious about
something she needed to sign an
affidavit
frank carter drafts the affidavit she's
concerned about it
she calls the president
the president returns monica lewinsky's
call big question should the president
return monica lewinsky's call
he does
that day quickly lewinsky mentions the
affidavit should be signing offers to
show it to the president and that's
where he says no
that he's seen 15 others
let's go to the next day
the next exhibit january 6th
on this particular day
monica lewinsky picks up the affidavit
the draft affidavit at 208 to 2 10 pm
and delivers that affidavit to whom mr
jordan
that's after she got it delivered to
jordan
and then
uh
at 3 26 pm mr jordan telephones mr
carter
at 3 38 mr jordan telephones nancy hearn
right at the white house
again mr jordan telephones lewinsky
telephones lewinsky about the draft
affidavit and at 3 49 you'll see in red
that both agree to delete a portion of
the affidavit that created some
implication that maybe she had been
alone with the president and so mr
jordan was very involved in drafting the
affidavit and the contents of that
and then at 419 presumably this in
response to some of the calls by mr
jordan earlier in the day the president
telephones mr jordan
and they have a discussion and then mr
jordan telephones mr carter and the
conversations go back and forth the end
of the day mr jordan telephones the
white house
and so the affidavit is still in the
drafting process go to the next day
exhibit nine
here monica signs the affidavit
at 10 a.m
ms lewinsky finds a false affidavit in
mr carter's office then what does she do
she delivers the signed affidavit to mr
jordan
and then what does he do the usual at 11
58 mr jordan telephones the white house
at 5 46 mr jordan telephones the white
house
at 6 50
mr jordan telephones the white house and
tells the president that miss lewinsky
signed the affidavit is this important
information for the president to know he
was vitally interested in it
and then go to the next day exhibit 10
january 8th
after the affidavit is signed what is
important the next day that the other
part of the arrangement that she has the
job interview with mcandrews
in new york
and she had that job interview the only
problem was it went poorly
the interview went very poorly and so at
4 43 p.m on this particular day miss
lewinsky telephones jordan and advises
that the new york interview went very
poorly
and so what does mr jordan do
mr jordan telephones ron perlman the ceo
the subsidiary of
revlon to
make things happen if they could happen
and what does he do next
jordan telephones lewinsky saying i'm
doing the best i can to help you out
and they set up another interview for
the next day
jordan telephones the white house
counsel's office and then in the evening
revlon in new york telephones lewinsky
to set up a follow-up interview they
said the first interview didn't go well
but because mr jordan intercedes
and he intercedes why because
we the false affidavit has been signed
we want to make sure all this is carried
out and then at 902 lewinsky telephones
jordan about the revlon interview in new
york that presumably hopefully it went
better on that particular day
and then on january 9 exhibit 11
monica is confirmed that the she has the
job
lewinsky is offered the revlon job in
new york and accepts lewinsky telephones
jordan
and then at 414
jordan notifies curry calls betty curry
and says mission accomplished and
request that she tell the president
jordan notifies the president lewinsky's
newark job offer
says thank you very much from the
president and then that evening the
president telephones curry and so on but
the president is notified that the job
has been secure mission is accomplished
now
let me ask you a question after i've
gone through these exhibits
would mr jordan have pushed for a second
interview
without cooperation on the affidavit
would monica lewinsky have received the
support and security job if she had said
i don't want to sign an affidavit i'm
just going to go in there and tell the
truth
whatever they ask me i'm going to answer
i'm going to tell the truth does anyone
in this room believe that she would have
been
granted that mr jordan had made that
call to get that second interview that
she would ever have the help from her
friends in high places
and now the affidavit has been signed
the job is secure monica lewinsky is on
the team and the president of the united
states is armed for the deposition
so let's move there just how important
was monica lewinsky's false affidavit to
the president's deposition
well let's look to see what did the
president's attorney robert bennett say
about that affidavit to the federal
judge during the deposition
that false affidavit allowed mr bennett
the attorney for mr clinton when talking
about
the question of whether there's a
relationship between the president and
miss lewinsky it allowed him to assert
quote there is absolutely no sex of any
kind in any manner shape or form with
president clinton end quote
and that is the statement of robert
bennett that his representation to the
court
about that relationship it is a
representation
that he had to later
probably based upon his own professional
embarrassment he had to withdraw and to
correct that inaccurate part of the
record
when questioned by his own attorney in
the deposition the president stated
specifically
the key paragraph
of miss lewinsky's affidavit was quote
absolutely true
and that paragraph eight of her
affidavit states i have never had a
sexual relationship with the president
now if it enters your mind at this point
as to what was meant by sexual
relationship
please remember that this affidavit was
draft upon common understanding of that
phrase at that point and not based upon
any definition used in the deposition of
the president
i'm sure it was the president's hope
and belief that the false affidavit used
the deposition to bolster his own
testimony would be the end of the matter
but that was not the case
we know in life
one lie leads to another well so it is
when we attempt to thwart the
administration of justice one
obstruction
leads to another
and now we move to another key witness
betty curry
by the time the president concluded his
deposition he knew there were too many
details out about his relationship with
miss lewinsky he knew that the only
person that could probably be talking
was miss lewinsky herself
he knew the cover story that they had
carefully created converted into the
false statements the affidavit was now
in jeopardy
it had to be backed at this point by the
key witnesses monica lewinsky and betty
curry
after the deposition the president
needed to do two things he had to
contact miss lewinsky to see if she was
still on the team but he also had to
make sure his secretary betty curry
would lie to protect him
and so let's look at how the concern
became a frenzied and concerted effort
to keep the holes plugged in the dike
and let's look at exhibits 12 and 13.
what happened on the day of the
deposition really the night of the
deposition on january 17th the president
finishes testifying in the deposition
around 4 pm
at 5 38 p.m the president telephones mr
jordan at home
and then at 702 the president telephones
miss curry at home doesn't get to her at
702 the president places a call to mr
jordan's office and then at 7 13 he gets
miss curry at home
finally and asks her to meet with him on
sunday
it's vitally important that he meet with
miss curry at this point because he
knows
his whole
operation is coming unglued and so the
next day on january 18th which is
exhibit 13.
now there's a whole flurry of activity
here i'm not going to go through all of
them but you can see the frantic pace at
the white house because
at
6 11 in the morning
the president had some more bad news the
drudge report was released
and that created a greater flurry then
between 11 49
and 2 55 pm three phone calls were made
between mr jordan and the president
and then at 5 pm
we see the meeting that's on the
second page at 5 p.m miss curry meets
with the president and the president
then tells miss curry to find monica
lewinsky the telephone calls were
generated and there was no success in
that and then that evening the president
calls miss curry at home to try once
again to see if she had found monica
lewinsky but it was on that day that
there was that critical meeting on that
sunday in the oval office between betty
curry and the president of the united
states and for that reason we next we
need next to hear from betty curry the
president's personal secretary as to
what occurred
during that most unusual meeting on
sunday following the deposition
betty curry testified in the grand jury
that the president said that he had just
been deposed and that the attorneys had
asked several questions about monica
lewinsky
and now this was a violation of the
judge's gag order and the president
you know made some comments that were
not in line with that he had some
choices to make and he made the wrong
choice but let's look at exhibit 14
which covers the series of statements
made to miss
miss curry at this point this is the
testimony of betty curry
she is reciting to the grand jury each
of the statements the president made to
her
after his grand jury testimony
the first one i was never alone with
monica lewinsky right
second you were always there
here when she was here right
monica lewinsky came on to me and i
never touched her right i'm not going to
read each one of those you can read them
for yourself you've heard those as well
but the president is making those simple
declaratory statements to her
there's three areas that are covered
here first of all the president makes
the case
that he was never alone with monica
lewinsky secondly he's making the point
to her that she was the aggressor not me
and the third point he is making i did
nothing wrong
those are the basic three points of
those five statements that the president
made to betty curry
during betty curry's grand jury
testimony she was asked whether she
believed that the president wished her
to agree with the statement now let's
look at betty curry for a second she is
the classical
reluctant witness
where are her loyalties as you would
examine her testimony where is she
uncomfortable in her testimony when
she's asked a question how does she
shift in a chair
those are the kinds of ways you have to
evaluate the truthfulness of the
testimony where their loyalties lie and
where their motives are but during the
question she's clearly reluctant but
she's asked a series of questions and
she finally acknowledges that it was
that the president was intending for her
to agree with the statements that were
made she says that is correct
and that is at page 74 of betty curry's
grand jury testimony
now when the president testified in the
august 17 grand jury he was questioned
about his intentions when he made those
five statements to miss curry in the
office on that sunday
and the president's
explanation
is as follows to the grand jury the
president
i thought we were going to be deluged by
the press comments and i was trying to
refresh my memory about what the facts
were
and he goes on to testify so i was not
trying to get betty curry to say
something that was untruthful
i was trying to get as much information
as i quickly could
ladies and gentlemen of the senate you
have to determine what the purpose of
those five statements to betty curry
were
were they to get information or whether
they get her
to falsely testify when she was called
as a witness
logic tells us that the president's
argument that he was just trying to
refresh his memory is well
so much of a novel legal defense
strategy
first consider the president's option
after he left to that position he could
have abided by the judge's gag order not
said anything secondly he could have
called betty curry in and ask a
a question an open ended question
miss curry or betty
what do you remember happened the third
option was to call her in and to make
these declaratory statements violate the
judge's order and tamper with the
anticipated testimony of betty curry and
that is the course that the president
chose
he made sure it was a face-to-face
meeting
not a telephone call
he made sure no one else was present
he made sure that the meeting was on his
territory in his office where he could
feel comfortable and he could utilize
the power and prestige of the of his
office the greatest influence on our
future testimony
after ms curry was in the president's
office he made short clear
understandable declarative statements
telling miss curry what the story was
he was not interested in what she knew
why because he knew the truth
but he did not want miss curry to tell
the truth the only way to ensure that
was by telling her what to say
not asking her what she remembered you
do not refresh someone's memory by
telling that person what he or she
remembers and you certainly do not make
declarative statements to someone
regarding factual scenarios of which the
listener was unaware
the statements that were made to her
betty curry could not have any possible
knowledge about as to whether they were
ever alone as to whether she came on to
him
no this was not any attempt for the
president to refresh his recollection it
was witness tampering pure and simple
understanding the seriousness of the
president's attempting to influence the
testimony of ms curry his attorneys have
tried to argue that those statements
could not constitute obstruction of
justice
because she had not been subpoenaed and
the president did not know that she was
a potential witness at this time
well the argument is refuted by both the
law and the facts
the law is clear that a person may be
convicted of obstructing justice if he
corruptly influenced the testimony of a
prospective witness the witness does not
actually have to give testimony the
witness does not have to be under any
subpoena the witness does not have to be
on any witness list
and so the law is clear
secondly let's examine the defense in
light of the facts the president himself
brought miss curry into the civil rights
case as a corroborating witness when he
repeatedly used her name in the
deposition
and just as significantly the president
had to be concerned about a looming
perjury charge against him in light of
his false testimony in the deposition
at least six times in that deposition
the president challenged the plaintiff's
attorneys to question ms curry about a
particular issue
you don't have it in front of you but
you will see it when we distribute the
copies of my remarks
i'll go through those six times at page
58 of the deposition the president when
asked whether he was alone with ms
lewinsky
said
the president said that he was not alone
with her or that betty curry was there
with monica
at page 70 when asked about the last
time the president saw mr lewinsky he
falsely testified the only
he only recalled that she was there to
see betty
at page 64 he told the jones lawyers to
ask betty
whether linsky was alone with him in the
white house or not or with betty in the
white house between the late hours
at page 65 of the deposition
the president was asked whether miss
lewinsky sent packages to him and he
stated that betty handled the packages
at page 72 the president was asked
whether he may have assisted in any way
with the job search
he stated that he thought betty
suggested vernon jordan talk to ms
lewinsky at page 74
he said that monica asked betty to ask
someone to talk to ambassador richardson
he asserted betty as a corroborating
witness at least six times in the
deposition there is no question but that
miss curry was a prospective witness and
the president clearly wanted her to be
deposed as a witness as his ask betty
questions
testimony demonstrates
but there's another very important fact
that has been thus far overlooked and
let me draw your attention to this
two days before the president's
deposition
betty curry
receives a call from michael isikoff
a reporter with newsweek magazine
inquiring about the
records of the cur the courier records
of gifts going from miss lewinsky to the
president
you've got a news reporter for a
national publication
two days before the president's
deposition talking to the president's
secretary saying i need to see the
courier records of the white house what
does betty curry do
she testified that she probably told the
president this
then she tells bruce lindsay but he also
goes to see vernon jordan
why
why would the secretary go see vernon
jordan because she had a press inquiry
the reason is
as we see later on remember this is
january 15th what happened on december
28th that we'll get to a little bit
later december 28th betty curry went and
put those gifts under her bed why is she
nervous because michael isakoff is
calling about the gifts that are
presently under her bed
and she's nervous
i would be nervous
and so she goes to see
bruce lindsay she goes to see
vernon jordan i need help what do i do
and she probably told the president
she it's all breaking loose the house of
cards is falling down and she is either
going to report to mr jordan or to seek
advice from him either way she knows
it's serious and it all has legal
consequences and she is a witness to it
all
and not only does
betty curry's testimony talk about this
call from michael isakoff and going to
see vernon jordan but vernon jordan's
testimony confirms this visit as well
the president claims that he called miss
curry into work on that sunday night
only to find out what she knew
but the president knew about the truth
on the relationship and if he told the
truth and deposition the day before he
would have no reason to be refreshed by
betty curry more importantly
the president's demeanor miss curry's
reaction and the suggested lies clearly
prove that the president was not merely
interviewing miss curry rather he was
looking for corroboration for his false
cover-up
and that is why he coached her he needed
a witness for him
not against him
now let's go to exhibit five of betty
curry's testimony
excuse me exhibit 15.
this is betty curry's testimony before
the grand jury on january 27 1998
and betty curry has asked about this
now remember it was on a sunday that
betty curry was first called
into the white house to go through these
five statements
this coaching by the president and then
she testified the grand jury question
did there come a time after that that
you had another conversation with the
president about some other news about
what was going on that would have been
tuesday or wednesday when he called you
into the oval office
betty curry's answer it was tuesday or
wednesday i don't remember which one
this was either but the best i remember
when he called me in the oval office it
was sort of a recapitulation of what we
had talked about on sunday quote you
know i was never alone with her that
sort of thing question did he pretty
much list the same
answer to my recollection sir yes
question and did he say it in sort of
the same tone and demeanor that he used
the first time he told you on sunday
answered the best i remember yes sir and
this needs to be emphasized not only was
that witness coaching taking place on
sunday
but
it took place a couple days later it was
twice repeated by the president to betty
curry he needed to have her good and in
line
this is more than witness tampering it
is witness compulsion of false testimony
by an employer to a subordinate employee
this has nothing to do with facts
nothing to do with media inquiries it
has to do with keeping his team on board
keeping the ship from sinking and the
hiding of facts that are important at
this point we are not talking about
hiding personal facts from inquiring
minds but an effort to impede the
legitimate and necessary functioning of
our court system
and now let's go to martin luther king
holiday almost exactly a year ago monday
january 19th
and again you'll see the example of the
frantic search for monica lewinsky it
continues exhibit 16. and i'm just i'm
not going to go through all of this but
i just want to briefly show
the
the frenetic activity on this particular
day
first of all you'll see betty curry is
trying to fulfill her responsibility to
get a hold of miss kawinsky she uses the
pager system and she says please call k
at home now k is the code name that is
used for betty curry
that's the agreed upon signal and she
uses
three messages please call k please call
k please call k then she starts using
different techniques to get her
attention it's a social call
and then
she later uses it's a family emergency
then she later uses this good news she's
using every means possible to get the
attention of monica lewinsky
and then at 8 50 a.m the president
telephones curry at home at 8 50
6 a.m
the president telephones jordan at home
going down to 10
a.m the president telephones jordan at
his office
and so what is going on here
they're
nervous they're afraid it is all
breaking loose they're trying to get a
hold of monica lewinsky to find out what
is going on
why
who she is talking to
later that days things continue to
destabilize for the president
at 4 54 p.m mr jordan learned from the
attorney frank carter that he no longer
represented miss lewinsky and so mr
jordan's link
had been cut off
mr jordan continued to
attempt to reach the president or
someone at the white house between 58
and 5 22 p.m
he made six calls
trying to
get a hold of someone at the white house
the president
when mr jordan was asked why he was
urgently trying to get a hold of the
white house he responded quote
because the president asked me to get
monica lewinsky a job
and he thought it was quote information
they ought to have
well jordan finally reaches the
president about 6 pm and tells him that
mr carter had been fired why this flurry
of activity it shows how important it
was for the president united states to
find ms lewinsky
betty curry was in charge of contacting
monica and it could not happen it did
not happen
mr lewinsky was a co-conspirator in
hiding this relationship from the
federal court and he was losing control
over her fast in fact she ultimately
agreed to testify truthfully under
penalties of perjury in this matter and
this was trouble for the president
and so now let's continue
let's continue exploring the web of
obstruction but to do this we have to
backtrack to what i've already referred
to and that was the incident on december
28th the episode with the gifts
on december 28th another brick in the
wall of obstruction was laid
it was the concealment of evidence
ms lewinsky testified that she discussed
with the president the fact that she had
been subpoenaed and that the subpoena
called for her to produce gifts
and this is what miss lewinsky was
telling the president at the meeting
with him on december
28th she testified before the grand jury
that she recalled telling the president
that the subpoena in question had
requested the hat pin and other items
and this concerned her the specificity
of it and the president responded it
bothered him too
well let's look at the testimony of miss
lewinsky which is exhibit seven in your
booklet
she's referring to this meeting
excuse me i'm sorry exhibit 17 thank you
exhibit 17. this is wilwinski testifying
about the meeting
and then at some point i said to him the
president
well you know
should i maybe i should put the gifts
away outside my house somewhere or give
them to someone maybe betty end quote
and he sort of said i think he responded
i don't know or let me think about that
and left that
topic not exactly the response you would
hope for or expect from the president
but the answer led to action
later that day miss lewinsky got a call
from miss curry who said
i understand you have something to give
to me
or according to mrs lewinsky the
president said you have something to
give me she wasn't exactly sure the
phrase but it was either i understand
you have something to give me what betty
curry said or betty curry said the
president said you have something to
give to me
and so
ladies and gentlemen if you accept
the testimony of monica lewinsky on that
point you must conclude that the
directive to retrieve the gifts came
from the president
i will concede
that there is a conflict in the
testimony on this point with the
testimony of betty curry miss curry in
her grand jury testimony had a fuzzy
memory a little different recollection
she testified that the best she can
remember miss lewinsky called her but
whenever she was asked further she said
that maybe miss lewinsky's remembering
is better than hers on that issue
but there is helpful evidence to clear
up this discrepancy or this
inconsistency
monica you recall in her deposition said
she thought that she that betty had
called her and she thought that the call
came from her cell phone number
well it was not known at the time of the
questioning of monica lewinsky but since
then
the cell phone record was retrieved
and you don't have it in front of you
but it will be available the cell phone
record was retrieved that showed
on betty curry's cell phone calls that a
call was made
at 332
from betty curry to monica lewinsky
and this confirms the testimony of
monica lewinsky that the
follow-up to get the gifts came from
betty curry the only way she would know
about it if the president directed her
to go retrieve the gifts as was
discussed with monica earlier
[Applause]
now the president will argue
that monica's timeline does not fit with
the time of the cell phone call
but remember the cell phone record was
retrieved subsequent to both the
testimony of monica lewinsky and betty
curry before the grand jury and
therefore the record was not available
to refresh the recollection or to make
inquiry with them about that
monica lewinsky's time estimate as to
when betty curry arrived to pick up the
gifts was based upon her memory without
the benefit of records
the questions raised by the president on
this issue are legitimate and
demonstrate the need to call the key
witnesses to a trial of his case and to
assess which version of the events is
believable and substantiated by the
corroborating evidence
this is certainly an area of testimony
where the juror needs to hear from betty
curry and monica lewinsky and to examine
all of the circumstantial evidence and
documentary evidence to determine the
truth it is my belief based upon common
sense and based upon the documentary
evidence that the testimony of monica
lewinsky is supported in the record and
it leads the conclusion that it was the
president who initiated this retrieval
of the gifts
and the concealment of the evidence
now there are many lawyers here in this
room
and you know that in federal cases all
across this country judges instruct
juries on circumstantial evidence we
have presented to you a great amount of
direct evidence grand jury testimony
eyewitness testimony
documentary evidence but
juries can use circumstantial evidence
as well
in a typical
line from the instruction that is given
to federal courts federal juries all
across the land
the law makes absolutely no distinction
between the weight or value to be given
either to direct or circumstantial
evidence
nor is a greater degree of certainty
required of circumstantial evidence than
of direct evidence and so i think it's
incumbent upon you to evaluate the
circumstances very carefully in addition
to the testimony
now let's examine the key question for a
moment why did betty curry pick up the
gifts for monica lewinsky monica
lewinsky states that she did not request
this and the retrieval was initiated by
the call from betty curry
this was after the meeting with the
president monica lewinsky's version is
corroborated by the cell phone record
and the pattern of conduct on the part
of betty curry what do i mean by that
as a loyal secretary to the president it
is inconceivable that she would go to
retrieve gifts that she knows the
president is very concerned about and
could bring down
the whole house
betty curry a subordinate employee would
not engage in such activity on such a
sensitive matter without the approval
and direction of the president himself
in addition let's look further the
actions of betty curry it becomes clear
that she understands the significance of
these gifts their evidentiary value in
the civil rights case and the fact that
they're under subpoena she retrieves
these items and where does she place
them she hides them under her bed
significantly a place of concealment
now let's look at the president's
defense
the president stated in his response to
questions 24 and 25 that was submitted
from the house to the president he said
he was not concerned about the gifts in
fact
he recalled telling monica that if the
jones lawyers request a gift she should
just turn them over to them
the president testified
he is not sure if he knew the subpoena
asked for gifts
now why in the world would monica and
the president discuss turning over gifts
to the jones lawyer if miss lewinsky had
not told him that the subpoena asked for
gifts
on the other hand if he knew the
subpoena requested gifts why would he
give monica more gifts on december 28th
this seems odd but miss lewinsky's
testimony reveals the answer
she said that she never questioned but
that quote
that we were ever going to do anything
but keep this private end quote
and that means to take quote whatever
appropriate steps need to be taken end
quote that's for monica's grand jury
testimony of august 6.
why would the president even meet with
monica lewinsky on december 28 when
their relationship was in question and
he was had a deposition coming up
certainly he knew he would be questioned
about it
certainly if mona became a witness she
would be questioned about their
relationship
that she would be asked when was the
last time you met with the president and
now they have to say december 28th if
they were going to tell the truth
the answer is the president knew that he
had to keep monica lewinsky on the team
and he is willing to take more risk
so that she would continue to be a part
of the conspiracy to obstruct the
legitimate functions of the federal
court in the civil rights case
it should be remembered that the
president has denied each and every
allegation of the two articles of
impeachment he has denied each element
of the obstruction of justice charges
including this allegation
that he encouragedly encouraged a scheme
to conceal evidence in a civil rights
case
this straightforward denial illustrates
the dispute in the evidence and
testimony it sets the credibility of
monica lewinsky the credibility of betty
curry the credibility of vernon jordan
and others
against the credibility of the president
of the united states
how can you as jurors determine who is
telling the truth
i've pointed to the corroborating
evidence the circumstantial evidence as
well as common sense supporting the
testimony of monica lewinsky but let me
ask you two questions
can you convict
the president of the united states
without hearing personally the testimony
of one of the key witnesses the second
question is
can you dismiss the charges under this
strong set of facts and circumstances
without hearing and evaluating the
credibility of the key witnesses
now let me take this a step further and
evaluate the credibility of the
president
let's first look back at his testimony
on the december 28th meeting that he
gave in his deposition in that case he
seriously misrepresented
the nature of his meeting with miss
lewinsky and that was the gift exchange
first he was asked
question
did she tell you that she had been
served with a sabine in this case
the president answered flatly
no
i don't know if she had been
again this is his testimony in the
deposition
he was also asking the deposition if he
ever talked to monic lewinsky about the
possibility of her testifying his answer
quote i'm not sure
he said
he then added he may have joked that the
jones lawyer might subpoena every woman
he'd ever spoken to and that i don't
think we ever had more of a conversation
about it than that not only does monica
lewinsky directly contradict this
testimony but the president later had to
answer questions in the grand jury about
these same set of circumstances and the
president directly contradicted himself
speaking of this december 28 meeting he
said that quote
he knew by then of course that she had
gotten a subpoena and they quote had a
conversation about the possibility of
her testifying end quote
i submit to this body that the
inconsistencies of the president's own
testimony as well as common sense
seriously diminish
his credibility on this issue
now let's go forward once again
to the time period in which the
president gave his deposition to paula
jones case
the president testified under oath on
january 17th and immediately thereafter
remember he brought
betty curry in to present the set of
false facts to her seeking her agreement
and coaching her but the president is
fully convinced he can get by with his
false denials because no one would
really be able to prove what did or did
not happen in the oval office there were
no witnesses and it boils down to a he
said she said scenario and as long as
that's the case he believes he can win
if the president can simply destroy
monica lewinsky's credibility in public
and before the grand jury then he will
escape the consequences for his false
statements under oath and the
obstruction in the civil rights case now
remember
this viewpoint though is all before the
dna tests were performed on the blue
dress
forcing the president to acknowledge
certain items
in order to carry out this cover-up and
obstruction the president needed to go
further he needed not only betty curry
to repeat his false statements but also
other witnesses that would assuredly be
called before the federal grand jury and
who would also be questioned by the news
media in public forums and this brings
us to the false statements that the
president made to his white house
staff and presidential aides let's call
sidney blumenthal and john podesta to
the witness stand
and i would concede that they would be
adverse witnesses
and this is referred to in exhibit 8 18
exhibit 18 that you have in front of you
first the testimony of sidney blumenthal
mr blumenthal to put this in perspective
is testifying
about his conversations when the
president called him in to go through
this fact these facts and what happened
and so mr blumenthal testified that it
was at that point that he referring the
president gave his account as to what
happened to me and he said that and it
was coming very fast he said monica
lewinsky came at me and made a sexual
demand on me
he rebuffed her he said i've gone down
that road before i've caused pain for a
lot of people and i'm not going to do
that again
look at this next line she threatened
him she said that she would tell people
they had an affair that she was known as
a stalker among her peers and that she
hated it and if she had an affair or she
had an affair
then she wouldn't be the stalker anymore
and he said he talks about this
character in the novel and i haven't
read that book but the last line and i
said to him i said when this happened
with monica lewinsky were you alone
he said
well i was within eyesight or earshot of
someone
then let's go to john podesta's
testimony where he was
called in the same fashion the president
talked to him about what has happened
a question okay share that with us
answer well i think he said that there
was some spate of you know what sex acts
were counted and he said that he had
never had sex with her in any way
whatsoever okay that they had not had
oral sex
and then just very briefly dick morris
we've heard this i'll just briefly refer
to the last
they're not ready for it
meeting the voters and he told the
president well we just have to win then
as the president has testified before
the grand jury he knew these witnesses
would be called before
the grand jury
at page
106
of the president's
testimony before the grand jury i just
want to confirm this point because it's
important he
testified the question was you know
that they and this is referring to john
podesta sidney blumenthal and his aides
that they might be witnesses you knew
they might be called into the grand jury
didn't you his answer that's right
so there's no question that these are
witnesses are going to testify for the
grand jury he was giving him false
information
and he did not limit it to that but his
false statements to them constitute
witness tampering and obstruction of
justice but i think there are two
significant points
in
the statements the president made to his
aides first of all the president who
wants to do away with the politics of
personal destruction indicates a
willingness to destroy the credibility
and reputation of a young person who
worked in his office for what reason in
order to preserve not only his
presidency but more significantly to
defeat the civil rights case against him
it's not a matter of saying he didn't do
it because he could have simply uttered
a denial
but he engaged in character
assassination that he knew would be
repeated to the federal grand jury and
throughout the
republic she was a stalker she
threatened me she came on to me
and it was it was repeated secondly it
makes it clear in his statements to john
podesta that he denies any sexual
relations with monica lewinsky including
oral sex there's no quibbling about
definitions in this statement it clearly
reflect reflects an intent to deceive
lie and obstruct our system of justice
in this case at every turn he used
whatever means available to evade the
truth destroy evidence tamper with
witnesses and any other actions required
to prevent evidence coming forth in the
civil rights case that would prove a
truth contrary to the president's
interest he had obstructed the
administration of justice before the
united states district court in a civil
rights case and before the federal grand
jury
but as we move toward a conclusion
let's focus on the supporting not just
on the supporting cast that we've talked
about but we need to look at the direct
and personal actions of the president
and i want to look at exhibit 20.
and this just summarizes the seven
pillars of its
of obstruction
what did the president do that
constitutes evidence of obstruction
he personally encouraged a witness
monica lewinsky
to provide false testimony
number two the president had direct
involvement involvement in ensuring a
job for a witness underlying direct
involvement he made the calls
and vernon jordan did
and it was connected with the filing of
the false affidavit by that witness
third the president personally with
corrupt intentions tampered with the
testimony of a prospective witness betty
curry fourthly the president personally
provided false statements under oath
before a federal grand jury
fifth by direct and circumstantial
evidence the president personally
directed the concealment of evidence
under subpoena in a judicial proceeding
sixth the president personally allowed
false representations to be made by his
attorney robert bennett to a federal
district judge on january 17th
seven the president intentionally
provided false information to witnesses
before a federal grand jury
knowing that those statements will be
repeated with the intent to obstruct the
proceedings before that grand jury and
that is the statements that he made
to the aides
the seven pillars of obstruction case
were personally constructed by the
president of the united states it was
done with the intent that the truth and
evidence would be suppressed in a civil
rights case pending against him
the goal was to win and he was not going
to let the judicial system stand in his
way
at the beginning of my presentation
i tried to put this case into
perspective for myself by saying that
this proceeding is the same as to what
takes place in every courtroom in
america the pursuit of truth
seeking equal justice and upholding the
law
all of that is true
but we know there is even more even more
at stake
in this trial
what happens here affects the workings
of our constitution
it will affect the presidency in future
decades and it will have an impact on a
whole generation of americans
what is at stake is our constitution
and the principle of equal justice for
all
i have faith in the constitution of the
united states
but the checks and balances of the
constitution are carried out
by individuals
individuals who are entrusted under oath
with upholding the trust
given to us by the people
of this great land if i believe in the
constitution
that it will work
then i must believe in you
ladies and gentlemen of the senate i
trust the constitution of the united
states but today it is most important
that i believe in you
i have faith in the united states senate
you have earned the trust of the
american people and i trust each of you
to make the right decision for our
country
thank you mr chief justice
the chair recognized the majority leader
the chief justice asking him we take
another 15-minute break of the
proceedings and i urge the senators
return profit to the chamber so that we
can begin after a 15-minute break
without objection it's so ordered
the senate now standing in recess for
about 15 minutes scheduled to come back
at about five minutes past the top of
the hour this year's old just turned 78
and i uh was um mississippi going to
have to let you go they're back in
session i believe we're ready to resume
the final presentation of the afternoon
several senators had inquired about
um
what would happen to the balance today i
believe that the presentation by
congressman rogan would be the last of
the day uh it's anticipated that would
go to sometime
around 6 30 or 6 45.
yielded four
the chair recognized mr manager rogan
mr chief justice
counsel for the president
members of the united states senate
my name is congressman james e rogan and
i represent the 27th district of
california
may i say at the outset that some of the
facts and evidence you will hear in my
presentation
may sound familiar in light of the last
presentation
although at times the facts may appear
to be a crossover the relevance will be
presented in a different light
mr manager hutchinson's presentation
offered the evidence as it relates to
the obstruction of justice charge
against the president in article two
i will be inviting this body
to view the evidence
within the framework of article one
perjury before the grand jury
on behalf of the house of
representatives and in the name of the
people of the united states
i will be presenting to the senate
evidence against the president to
demonstrate he committed perjury before
a federal grand jury
as set forth in article one
of the articles of impeachment
article one of the impeachment
resolution against president clinton
alleges that he committed felony strike
that he had committed perjury before the
grand jury
on august 17 1998
president clinton swore to tell the
truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth
the evidence shows that contrary to that
oath
the president willfully provided
perjurious false and misleading
statements
to the grand jury in four general areas
first
he perjured himself when he gave a false
account to the grand jury about the
nature and details of his relationship
with a 21 year old intern monica
lewinsky who was a subordinate
federal government employee
second he purged himself before the
grand jury when he repeated previous
perjured answers he gave under oath in a
sexual harassment suit which was a
federal civil rights action brought
against him
by paula jones
third
he perjured himself before the grand
jury
when he repeated
previous perjured answers to justify his
attorney's false representations to a
federal judge in the paula jones sexual
harassment lawsuit against him
finally he perjured himself before the
grand jury
when he testified falsely
about his attempts to get other
potential grand jury witnesses to tell
false stories to the grand jury and to
prevent the discovery of evidence in
paula jones's sexual harassment lawsuit
against him
in a judicial proceeding
a witness has a very solemn obligation
to tell the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth
perjury is a serious crime
because our judicial system can only
succeed
if citizens are required to tell the
truth
in court proceedings
if witnesses may lie with impunity
for personal or political reasons
justice is no longer the product
of the court system
and we descend into chaos
that is why the united states supreme
court
has placed a premium on truthful
testimony
and shows no tolerance for perjury
more than 20 years ago
the court addressed this very concept of
perjury
and its dangerous effect on our system
of law listen to the words
of the united states supreme court
in this constitutional process of
securing a witness's testimony
perjury simply has no place whatever
perjured testimony is an obvious and
flagrant affront to the basic concepts
of judicial proceedings
congress has made the giving of false
answers a criminal act
punishable by severe penalties
in no other way
can criminal conduct be flushed into the
open where the law can deal with it
that is the framework under which the
house of representatives acted
in impeaching the president of the
united states
and now respectfully urges this body
to call the president
to constitutional accountability
the key to understanding the facts of
this case is to understand
why the president was asked under oath
questions about his private life in the
first place
despite the popular spin
it wasn't because members of congress or
lawyers from the office of independent
counsel or a gaggle of reporters
suddenly decided to invade the
president's privacy
no
this all came about because of a claim
against the president from when he was
the governor of arkansas
during the discovery phase of the paula
jones sexual harassment case against the
president
federal judge susan weber wright
ordered him to answer questions under
oath relating to any sexual relationship
he may have had while governor and
president
with subordinate female government
employees
these orders are common
in similar cases
and the questions posed to president
clinton are questions routinely posed to
defendants in civil rights sexual
harassment cases every single day in
this country
in courthouses throughout the land
during the president's deposition in the
paula jones case
he was asked questions about his
relationship with monica lewinsky
the judge allowed these questions
because they possibly could lead mrs
jones
to discover if there was any pattern of
conduct
to help prove her case
the president repeatedly denied
that he had a sexual relationship with
monica lewinsky
a few days later
the story about his relationship with ms
lewinsky broken the press
a criminal investigation began to
determine whether the president perjured
himself
in the paula jones sexual harassment
case
and obstructed justice by trying to
defeat her claim against him by corrupt
means
on the afternoon of august 17
1998
president clinton raised his right hand
and took an oath before the grand jury
in their criminal investigation
[Music]
[Music]
i do
note the incredible
solemn obligation
of the oath the president took
do you solemnly swear
that the testimony you are about to give
in this matter
will be the truth
the whole truth
and nothing
but the truth
when the president made that solemn
pledge
he was not obliging himself
to tell the grand jury
the partial truth
he was not obliging himself
to tell the i didn't want to be
particularly helpful truth
he was not obliging himself to tell the
this is embarrassing so i think i'll
fudge on it a little bit truth
he was required to tell the truth
the whole truth
and nothing but the truth
and he made that pledge
in the name of god
the attorneys for the office of
independent counsel
showed great deference to the president
when they questioned him that day
the president's attorneys were allowed
to be there with him during the entire
proceeding
so that he could confer with them at his
leisure if he was unsure
of how to respond to a question
as a matter of fact
the attorney who questioned the
president encouraged him to confer with
his lawyer
if there arose in the president's mind
any reason to hesitate
before answering a question
the following exchange occurred
at the beginning of the president's
testimony
the president was told normally grand
jury witnesses
while not allowed to have attorneys in
the grand jury room with them
can stop and consult with their
attorneys under our arrangement today
your attorneys are here and present for
consultation
and you can break to consult with them
as necessary do you understand that the
president responded i do understand that
as a practical matter
the president had three options
as he appeared before the grand jury to
testify
first the president could tell the truth
about his true relationship
with monica lewinsky
however the evidence will clearly show
that the president rejected the option
of telling the truth
second the president could invoke his
fifth amendment privilege against
self-incrimination
the independent counsel's attorney
explicitly reminded the president about
his right to refuse to answer any
question that might tend to incriminate
him
the president was asked
you have a privilege against
self-incrimination
if a truthful answer to any question
would tend to incriminate you you can
invoke the privilege and that invocation
will not be used against you
do you understand
the president's response
was i do
the president knew he had the right to
refuse to answer any incriminating
questions
and that no legal harm would come to him
for doing so
but he rejected that option
just as he rejected the option of
telling the truth
instead
he selected a third path
he continued to lie
about corrupt efforts to destroy
paula jones's sexual harassment case
against him
if a trial is permitted before this body
where live witnesses can be called
and where their credibility can be
scrutinized
the evidence will show this
distinguished body
that the chart the president
that the course the president charted
was a course of perjury
despite the president's unique level of
judicial sophistication
and expertise
the attorneys at the grand jury were
careful
to make sure the president understood
the responsibilities to tell the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth
they did this at the outset of his
testimony before any questions were
asked that might tempt the president
to lie under oath
and they specifically warned him
that if he were to lie or intentionally
mislead the grand jury
he could face perjury and obstruction of
justice charges both of which are
felonies
under federal law
this exchange occurred before the
president's testimony mr president
you understand that your testimony here
today
is under oath
answer i do
and you understand that because you have
sworn to tell the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth that if you
were to lie or intentionally mislead the
grand jury you could be prosecuted for
perjury and or obstruction of justice
answer i believe that's correct
question
is there anything
that i've stated to you regarding your
rights
and responsibilities
that you would like me to clarify or
that you don't understand
answer
no sir
despite this ominous warning
the prosecutors continue emphasizing the
need for the president to resist lying
to the grand jury
still intent on making sure the
president understood his obligations
the attorneys further advised him
mr president
i would like to read for you a portion
of federal rule of evidence 603 which
discusses the important function the
oath has in our judicial system it says
that the purpose of the oath is
calculated to awaken the witnesses
conscience and impress the witnesses
mind
with the duty to tell the truth
could you please tell the grand jury
what that oath means to you
for today's testimony
the president responded
i have sworn an oath to tell the grand
jury the truth
and that's what i intend to do
when the president said
in that very last answer i just read
that he swore an oath to tell the grand
jury
the truth
the prosecutor immediately
followed up with another question
here is what he was told
question to the president you understand
that the oath requires you
to give
the whole truth
that is a complete answer to each
question sir
answered by the president
i will answer each question as
accurately and fully
as i can
now one would think
these repetitive explanations to the
president of the united states
would be enough to warn even the most
legally unsophisticated witness
about the need to treat a grand jury
criminal investigation seriously and the
need to tell the whole truth at any cost
no reasonable person could believe at
this point that the president did not
understand his obligations
yet just to be sure
the attorneys impressed on the president
his solemn duty to tell the truth
question to the president
now you took the same oath to tell the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth on january 17 1998
in a deposition in the paula jones
litigation is that correct sir
answered by the president i did take an
oath then
question
did the oath you took on that occasion
mean the same to you then
as it does today
answer
i believed then
that i had to answer the questions
truthfully that is correct
question and it meant the same to you
then
as it does today answer
well
no one read me a definition then and we
didn't go through
this exercise then
i swore an oath to tell the truth and i
believed i was bound to be truthful and
i tried to be
having just received his refresher
course
on either taking the fifth and remaining
silent
or telling the whole truth and nothing
but the truth the president acknowledged
he was required to tell the truth
when he gave answers to questions eight
months earlier in the paula jones sexual
harassment civil rights lawsuit
question to the president
at the paula jones deposition you were
represented by mr robert bennett your
counsel is that correct
answer that is correct
question
he was authorized by you to be your
representative there your attorney is
that correct answer that is correct
question your counsel mr bennett
indicated and i'm quoting
the president intends to give full and
complete answers as ms jones is entitled
to have
my question to you is do you agree with
your counsel that a plaintiff in a
sexual harassment case is to use his
words entitled
to have the truth
answered by the president
i believe that i was bound to give
truthful answers yes sir
question
but the question is sir do you agree
with your counsel that a plaintiff
in a sexual harassment case is entitled
to have the truth
answered by the president
i believe when a witness is under oath
in a civil case or otherwise under oath
the witness should do everything
possible to answer the questions
truthfully
thus the groundwork was laid
for the president to testify under oath
before the grand jury
he knew how the rules worked respecting
testimony before the grand jury
if a question was vague or ambiguous the
president could ask for a clarification
if he was unsure how to answer or indeed
whether to answer a question he could
stop the questioning take a break
and consult privately with his attorneys
who were present with him
if giving an answer would tend to
incriminate him
he could refuse to answer the question
by claiming his fifth amendment rights
but if after all of this
he decided to give an answer
the answer he gave was required to be
the truth
the whole truth
and nothing but the truth
and it was no different than the
obligation when he testified in the
paula jones deposition
same oath
same obligation
let's look at how the president chose
to meet his obligation
as noted in my opening remarks the
president's grand jury perjury is the
basis for article one of the impeachment
resolution
the evidence shows
and live witnesses
clearly will demonstrate
that the president repeatedly committed
perjury before the grand jury when he
testified as a defendant in the sexual
harassment civil rights lawsuit
against him
he intentionally failed in his lawful
obligation to tell the truth
in four general areas
first
the president committed perjury before
the grand jury when he testified about
the nature of his relationship with
monica lewinsky a 21 year old white
house intern who by definition
was a subordinate government employee
on december 5th 1997
monica lewinsky's name appeared on the
paula jones witness list
later
the president was ordered by federal
judge susan weber wright to answer
questions about monica lewinsky because
the president was a defendant in a
sexual harassment case at his deposition
in the paula jones case the president
was shown
a definition approved by judge wright
of what constitutes
sexual relations
take the chart down
i'm going to read
the definition that was presented
to the president
and let me say at the outset that i'm
going to slightly sanitize it
you have in your materials members of
this body a copy of the actual
definition that was given to him so you
will be able to understand precisely
what was put before the president
definition of sexual relations
for the purposes of this deposition
a person engages in sexual relations
when the person knowingly engages in or
causes contact
with
the certain enumerated body parts
of any person
with an attempt to arouse or gratify the
sexual desire of any person members of
the senate just for clarification i did
not feel the need to actually relate to
this body what those enumerated body
parts are
after reviewing the definition
the president then denied
that he ever had a sexual relationship
with monica lewinsky
as we have already seen
from the day in january when the
president testified in the jones
deposition
until the day he appeared in august for
his grand jury testimony he vehemently
denied
ever having a sexual relationship
with monica lewinsky
listen to the president addressing the
american people
on the subject of his credibility
the date is january 26
1998
five days after the lewinsky story
broken the press
but i want to say one thing to the
american people
i want you to listen to me i'm going to
say this again
i did not
have
sexual relations with that woman
miss lewinsky
i never told anybody to lie not a single
time never
these allegations are false
and i need to go back to work for the
american people thank you
beginning in january 1998
the president went on an eight-month
campaign both under oath
and in the press
denying any sexual relationship with
monica lewinsky
in any way shape or form
but eight months after his deposition
testimony and these passionate denials
the tide had turned against his story
by august monica lewinsky was now
cooperating with the office of the
independent council
if she was telling the truth in her
sworn testimony
then the president's january denial in
the paula jones case would have been a
clear case of him committing perjury and
obstructing justice
why
because she was describing
in very graphic detail
conduct occurring between her and the
president that clearly fit the
definition of sexual relations as used
in the paula jones deposition
conduct that he repeatedly denied under
oath
so by the time the president sat down
for his grand jury testimony
to answer these questions under oath
he had put himself
in a huge box
he could not continue the outright lie
because ms lewinsky had turned over her
blue dress for dna testing
and at the time of his grand jury
testimony he didn't know what the
results were
of that fbi test
under such circumstances continuing the
lie was too risky of a strategy
even for the most accomplished of
gamblers
but if he told the truth
his earlier perjury and obstruction of
justice would have ended his presidency
he was sure
he would have been driven from office
remember that the president had actually
authorized that a poll be taken for him
by dick morris and the poll wasn't just
taken on whether the american people
would forgive him for adultery
the president asked dick morris
to poll in two other areas
he asked dick morris to poll
whether the american people would
forgive him
for perjury
and obstruction of justice
when he got the poll results back he
learned that the american people would
forgive the perjury
but they would not forgive strike that
they would forgive him for the adultery
but they would not forgive him for
perjury or for obstruction of justice
once he got the bad news from dick
morris
that his political career was over if he
perjured himself
he told dick morris
we'll just have to win
so at his grand jury testimony
once the first question was asked about
his relationship with monica lewinsky
the president produced a prepared
statement
and read from it
this prepared statement he read to the
grand jury on august 17
1998 was the linchpin in his plan to win
mr president were you physically
intimate with political reality
goodman i think maybe i can save the
view and the grandeur is a lot of time
if uh i read a statement
which
i think will make it clear what the
nature of my relationship with miss
lewinsky was how it related to the
testimony i gave what i was trying to do
in that testimony
and i think it will perhaps make it
possible for you to
ask even more
relevant questions from your point of
view and with your permission
i'd like to read that statement
absolutely please
[Applause]
[Applause]
when i was alone with miss lewinsky
on certain occasions
in early 1996
and once in early 1997
i engaged in conduct that was wrong
these encounters did not consist of
sexual intercourse
they did not constitute sexual relations
as i understood that term to be defined
at my january 17 1998
deposition but they did involve
inappropriate animal contact
these inappropriate encounters ended at
my insistence
in early 1997.
i also had occasional telephone
conversations with mr winsky
that included an appropriate sexual
banner
i regret
that what began as a friendship
came to include this conduct
and i take full responsibility for my
actions
while i will provide the grand jury
whatever other information i can
because of privacy considerations
affecting my family
myself
and others
and in an effort to preserve the dignity
of the office i hold
this is all i will say about the
specifics of these particular matters
i will try to answer to the best of my
ability
other questions
including questions about my
relationship with ms lewinsky
questions about my understanding of the
term sexual relations
as i understood it to be defined
at my january 17 1998 definition
and questions concerning
alleged submarination of perjury
obstruction of justice
and the intimidation
of witnesses
that mr bittman is
my favorite
beyond that statement
the president generally refused
to answer specific questions about his
relationship with monica lewinsky
the president used that prepared
statement as a substitute answer for
specific questions about his conduct
with ms lewinsky 19 separate times
during his testimony before the grand
jury
the purpose of the prepared statement
was to avoid answering the types of
specific harassment lawsuit questions
for which the united states supreme
court and judge susan weber wright had
earlier cleared the way
the evidence shows the president used
this prepared statement
in order to justify the persuarious
answers he gave at his deposition which
were intended to affect the outcome
of the paula jones case
the fact that this statement was
prepared in advance
shows his intent to mislead the grand
jury in this very area
ironically this prepared statement was
supposed to inoculate the president from
perjury
instead it opened him up to 19 more
examples of giving produce false and
misleading answers under oath
for example
in that prepared statement
the president said his sexual contact
with ms lewinsky began in 1996
and not in 1995 as ms lewinsky had
testified
this was not a mere slip of memory
over a meaningless time frame
there is a discrepancy in the dates
for a reason
you see under the president's version
in 1996
monica lewinsky was a paid white house
employee
under the facts as testified to by ms
lewinsky when the relationship really
began in 1995 she was not a paid
employee at the white house she was a
young 21 year old white house intern
the concept of a president
having a sexual relationship in the
white house with a young intern
less than half his age was a public
relations disaster for the president
as everyone vividly remembers
it is clear that the president somehow
viewed the concept as less combustible
if he could take the young intern phrase
out of the public lexicon
yet in his deposition testimony the
president admitted he met her and saw
her when she was an intern working in
the white house in november 1995
during the government shutdown
monica lewinsky confirmed this
in fact she testified that the first
time she ever spoke to the president was
on november fifteenth nineteen ninety
eight
during the government shutdown
and she also said
that the very first time that she ever
spoke to the president
was the same day he invited her back to
the oval office
and began a sexual relationship with her
it is obvious that the reference in the
president's prepared statement to the
grand jury that this relationship began
in 1996 was intentionally false
the president's statement was
intentionally misleading when he
described being alone with ms lewinsky
only on certain occasions
actually
they were alone in the white house at
least 20 times
and had at least 11 sexual encounters at
the white house
the president attempted to use language
that subtly minimized the number of
times they were alone the president's
statement was intentionally misleading
when he described his telephone
conversations with monica lewinsky
as occasional
in fact there are at least 55 documented
telephone conversations between the
president of the united states
and the young intern
and without going into further graphic
detail
the evidence shows
that at least on 17 of those occasions
those conversations included much more
than mere sexual banter
as the president described it
the most unsettling part
of that statement
was uttered near the close
listen to what the president said
i regret
that what began as a friendship
came to include
this conduct
friendship
the very day
the president met and spoke
with a young white house intern for the
first time
was the day he invited her back to the
oval office
to perform sex acts on him
in fact monica lewinsky said that after
their sexual relationship was over a
month old
she didn't even think the president knew
her name
the president's statement about his
relationship with monica lewinsky
beginning as a friendship
is a callous and deceptive
mischaracterization
of how his relationship
with this young woman
really began
thus the president began his deposition
testimony by reading a false and
misleading statement to the grand jury
he then used that statement as an excuse
not to answer specific questions that
were directly relevant to allowing the
grand jury to complete its criminal
investigation
had he given specific answers to
specific questions about the true nature
of his relationship
the grand jury would have been able to
learn the whole truth about whether the
president perjured himself and
obstructed justice in the paula jones
sexual harassment civil rights lawsuit
paula jones
had a legal
and constitutional right
to learn if the president
while as president or governor
used his position of power and influence
to get sexual favors from subordinate
female employees in the workplace
or to reward subordinate female
employees for granting such favors to
him
instead the president intentionally
provided on 19 separate occasions
a misleading statement instead of giving
a true characterization of his conduct
as required by his oath
he had no legal or constitutional right
to refuse to answer such questions
without claiming a fifth amendment
privilege and then allowing judge wright
to make a determination as to whether
the privilege applied
the president's preliminary statement
delivered 19 times was an initial shot
across the perjury bow offered by the
president throughout his grand jury
testimony
it showed a premeditated effort to
thwart the grand jury's criminal
investigation to justify his prior
wrongdoing and to not to deny paula
jones her constitutional right to bring
forward her claim in a court of law
the president gave further perjurious
false and misleading testimony regarding
the nature and details of his
relationship with monica lewinsky
one of the ways the president tried to
justify
his perjurious answers in the jones
deposition about his relationship
was to deconstruct the english language
remember the president was shown a copy
of the definition of sexual relations
that judge wright approved in his
january deposition
this definition was directed by judge
wright to be used as the guide
under which the president was to answer
questions about his relationship with
monica lewinsky
after carefully reviewing that
definition the president said under oath
that it did not apply to his
relationship with her
it is important to remember
that at the time the president testified
that he never had sexual relations with
monica lewinsky
this was not a risky perjury strategy
after all
he had successfully used vernon jordan
to get monica lewinsky a good job in new
york despite her questionable
qualifications
she had filed a false affidavit in the
jones case denying a sexual relationship
with the president
she and the president had previously
agreed to comprehensive cover stories
to deny the truth of their relationship
if anyone ever confronted them about it
and the bevy of gifts the president had
given to monica were now nestled safely
under betty curry's bed so that they
would never be produced to or discovered
by mrs jones's attorneys in compliance
with their subpoena to have those gifts
produced
the perjury strategy was a safe bet
in january at his deposition but it soon
turned upside down for the president
by the time of his grand jury testimony
in august
the president knew things had changed
drastically
but not in his favor
in light of miss lewinsky's cooperation
with the independent council the
impending fbi report on her d on the dna
testing on the blue dress and the
president's decision not to confess to
his crime the president needed to come
up with some excuse
here is how the president at his august
grand jury appearance tried to explain
away his january deposition denial of
engaging in sexual relations with monica
lewinsky
did you understand the words
in the
first portion of the exhibit mr
president that is for the purposes of
this
deposition a person engages in
a person knowingly engages in or causes
did you understand do you understand the
words there
in that phrase
because
my i can tell you what my understanding
of the definition is if you want me to
do it
my understanding of this definition is
that
it covers contact by the person being
deposed
with the enumerated areas
if the contact is done with an intent to
arouse or gratify
that's my understanding of the
definition
what did you believe
because the
definition to include and excellent what
kinds of activities
i thought the definition included any
activity by the the person being deposed
where the person was the actor and
came in contact with those parts of the
body with the purpose of intent for
gratification
and excluded any other activity
for example kissing's not covered by
that i don't think
did you understand the definition to be
limited to sexual activity
yes i understood the definition to be
limited to to physical contact with
those areas of the body
with the specific intent to arouse or
gratify
that's what i understood it to be
what specific act
is the definition include as you
understood the definition on january 17
1919
any contact with the areas they are
mentioned sir
if you contacted the if you contacted
those parts of the body with an intent
to arouse or gratify that is covered
what did you understand the person being
deposed if the person being deposed
contacted
those parts of another person's body
with an intent to arouse or gratify
that was covered
if that answer
sounded confusing to you there's a
reason for that
it was meant to be
what the president now was saying to the
grand jury
is that during their intimate
relationship in the oval office
monica lewinsky
had sexual relations with him
he didn't have
sexual relations with her
consider that for a moment
the president is asking everyone to
believe that between the years 1995 and
1997
while monica lewinsky was engaged in a
pattern of explicit availability for him
as she described in her testimony
the president carefully avoided having
any intimate contact with her
as described in judge wright's very
detailed definition
and according to the president
since he never
intimately touched her at descri as
described in the definition she only
touched him
then he was under no obligation to
answer questions in the harassment suit
about monica lewinsky as federal judge
susan weber wright ordered him to do
under oath
not only does the president's claim
strain all boundaries of common sense
it is directly in conflict with monica
lewinsky's detailed
and corroborated accounts
of their relationship
and if this ridiculous expansion of
judge wright's definition of what
constituted sexual relations wasn't
enough
the president then decided to take his
interpretation of the judge's definition
one step further
he added a new element as to why he
claimed the definition didn't apply to
him
when asked again at his grand jury
testimony what he thought the definition
of sexual relations meant
here is the new twist that the president
came up with
as i remember from the previous
discussion they said
this was
some kind of definition that had
something to do with sexual harassment
so uh
that implies it's forcing to me
and i and there was never any issue of
forcing in the in the case involving uh
well any of these questions they were
asking they made it clear in this
discussion i just reviewed that what
they were referring to was intentional
sexual conduct not some sort of forcible
abusive behavior
so i i basically
i don't think i paid any attention to it
because it appeared to me that that was
something that was had no reference to
the facts that they admitted they were
asking me
the president now took the position that
the definition didn't apply to him
because it would only have applied if he
forced himself on monica lewinsky
remember the definition
and i will read it again
for the purposes of this deposition a
person engages in sexual relations when
the person knowingly engages in or
causes contact with the enumerated body
parts of any person with an intent to
arouse or gratify the sexual desires of
any person
as you can see this straightforward
definition did not include the subject
of force or harassment
yet when the independent council's
attorney tried to clarify the
president's newfound position
the president gave no ground he simply
plowed ahead with his new interpretation
i'm just trying to understand mr
president
you put the definition in the context of
sexual harassment no no i think it was
not in the context of sexual harassment
i just reread those four pages which
obviously the grand jury doesn't have
but there was some reference to the fact
that this definition apparently bore
some had some connection to some
uh definition in another context
and that this was being used
not in that context not necessarily in
the context of sexual harassment so
i would think that this causes would be
what means to force someone to do
something that's what i read it that's
the only point i'm trying to make
therefore i did not believe that anyone
had ever suggested
that i had
uh
forced anyone to do anything
and that i and i did not do that and so
that could not have had any bearing on
any questions related to ms lewinsky
the evidence clearly shows from monica
lewinsky's sworn testimony that the
president deconstructed the english
language to deny paula jones the
opportunity to find out if other
witnesses were out there who would help
her bolster her case against the
president and she was legally entitled
to do that
under our sexual harassment laws
no reasonable interpretation of the
president's testimony could be made that
he fulfilled his legal obligation to
testify to the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth his statements
were pejurious
they were designed to defeat paula
jones's right to pursue her sexual
harassment civil rights lawsuit
against this president
and by the way
in his testimony the president conceded
that if monica lewinsky's recitation of
the facts was true
he
nation of the facts was true
he would have perjured himself both in
his deposition testimony and in
repeating his denials before the grand
jury listen to this
you
testified that you didn't have sexual
relations with monica lewinsky in the
jones deposition under that definition
that's right excellent
if the person being deposed
uh touched the genitalia
of another person would that be in with
the intent to arouse the
sexual desire arouse or gratify
as defined in
definition one
would that be under your understanding
then and now
sexual relations yes sir
yes it was yes it would if you had a
direct contact with
any of these places in the body if you
had direct contact with intent to arouse
or gratify
that would fall within the definition so
you didn't do any of those three things
you were free to infer that my testimony
is that i did not
have sexual relations as i understood
this term to be defined
so who is telling the truth
the only way to really know
is to bring forth the witnesses
put them under oath
and give each juror
each member of this body the opportunity
to make that determination of
credibility
because the record shows
that monica lewinsky delivered
consistent and detailed testimony under
oath
regarding many specific encounters with
the president
that clearly fell within the definition
of sexual relations
from the jones deposition
monica lewinsky's memory
and accounts of these incidents are
amazingly corroborated by her
recollection of dates places and phone
calls
which correspond with the official white
house entrance logs and phone records
monica lewinsky's testimony is further
corroborated through dna testing and the
testimony of her friends and family
members to whom she made near
contemporaneous statements about the
relationship
most importantly
monica lewinsky had every reason to tell
the truth
to the grand jury
she was under a threat of prosecution
for perjury not only for her grand jury
testimony but also for the false
affidavits she filed on behalf of the
president
in the jones case
she knew then
and she knows today
that her immunity agreement
could be revoked at any time
if she lies under oath
or if she lied under oath in the past
truthful testimony was and remains a
condition for her immunity from
prosecution
by way of contrast the president was
under obligation to give complete
answers
instead he offered false answers that
violated the oath to tell the truth the
whole truth and nothing but the truth
and incidentally
during his grand jury testimony
the president actually suggested
that he had a right to give less than
complete answers
why
because he questioned the motives
of mrs jones
in bringing her
lawsuit if this standard is acceptable
what does that do to the search for
truth when an oath is administered in a
courtroom to one who claims
to question the motives of their
opponent in a trial
this suggestion has no basis in law
and it is destructive to the
truth-seeking function of the courts
the president's furious legal hair
splitting used to bypass the requirement
of telling the complete truth denied
paula jones her constitutional right to
have her day in court
and an orderly disposition of her claim
in the sexual harassment case against
the president
to dismiss this conduct with a shrug
because it is just about sex
is to say that the sexual harassment
laws protecting in the work protecting
women in the workplace do not apply to
powerful employers or others in high
places of privilege
as one wag recently noted if this case
is just about sex then robbery is just a
disagreement over money
next the president perjured himself
before the grand jury
when he repeated previous perjured
answers he gave
in the deposition in the paula jones
case
in his grand jury testimony in august
the president admitted he had to tell
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth when he testified in the
paula jones deposition
question to the president
now you took the same oath to tell the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth on january 17th 1998 and a
deposition in the paula jones litigation
is that correct sir answer
i did take an oath then
question
did the oath you took on that occasion
mean the same to you then as it does
today answer i believe then that i had
to answer the questions truthfully that
is correct
when the president testified in his
january deposition
he knew full well that monica lewinsky's
affidavit she filed in the case stating
that they never had sexual relations was
false
yet when this affidavit was shown to him
at the deposition
he testified that her false claim
was in his words
absolutely true
he knew that the definition of sexual
relations used in the earlier jones
deposition was meant to cover the same
activity that was mentioned in monica
lewinsky's false affidavit
rather than tell the complete truth the
president lied about the relationship
the cover stories the affidavit the
subpoena for gifts and the search for a
job for ms lewinsky
later he denied to the grand jury in
august that he committed any perjury
during his january deposition
this assertion before the grand jury
that he testified truthfully in the
jones case is in and of itself for
jurious testimony because the record is
clear he did not testify truthfully in
january in the paula jones case he
perjured himself
thus when the president testified before
the grand jury in august he knew he had
given perjurious answers
in the january deposition if the
president really thought as he testified
that he had told the truth in his
january deposition testimony he would
not have related a false account of
events to his secretary betty curry whom
he knew by his own admission might be
called as a witness in the jones case
he would not have repeatedly denied he
was unable to recall being alone with
monica lewinsky
and he would not have told false
accounts to his aides whom he knew by
his own admission
were potential witnesses
in later proceedings
the evidence of perjury and obstruction
of justice is overwhelming in this case
he continued to use illegal means to
defeat mrs jones constitutional right to
bring her harassment case against him
next the president committed perjury
before the grand jury when he testified
that he did not allow his attorney to
make false representations
while referring to monica lewinsky's
affidavit before the judge in the jones
case an affidavit that he knew
was false
remember at the jones deputies
deposition in january 1998
monica lewinsky previously had filed a
false affidavit that said quote
i have never had a sexual relationship
with the president
and that she had no relevant information
to provide on the subject to mrs jones
when mrs jones's attorneys
attempted to question the president
about his relationship with ms lewinsky
the president's attorney mr bennett
objected to him even being questioned
about the relationship
mr bennett claimed that in light of
monica lewinsky's affidavit saying that
there was no sexual relationship between
the two and there never had been
that the paula jones lawyers had no good
faith belief even to question the
president about a relationship with
monica lewinsky listen to what mr
bennett told judge
wright in the deposition
i need some guidance from the court at
this point i i'm going to object to the
innuendo i'm afraid
as i say that this will leak i don't
question the predicates here i question
the good faith of counsel
uh the innuendo in the question council
is fully aware
that miss lewinsky
has filed has an affidavit which they
are in possession of
saying that there is absolutely no sex
of any kind in any manner shape or form
with president clinton and yet
listening to the innuendo in the
question no now just a minute let me
make my ruling i do not know
uh whether council
is basing this question on any affidavit
but i will direct mr bennett not to
comment on other evidence
that might be pertinent and could be
arguably coaching the witness
at this juncture now i
mr fischer is an author of this court
and i have to assume that he has a good
faith basis for asking this question if
in fact he has no good faith basis for
asking the question he could later be
sanctioned if you would like i would be
happy to review on camera any good faith
basis he might have
well your honor with all due respect i i
would like to know the proper i'm not
coaching the witness
and prep he doesn't know
but i think when he asks questions like
this where he's sitting on an affidavit
from the witness he should at least have
a good base profile i i agree with you
that he needs to have a good space basis
for asking questions maybe yes
and i am assuming that he does and i
will be willing to review this in camera
if he does not want to reveal it to
counsel
i would i would welcome an opportunity
to explain to the court that what our
good faith basis is in an in-camera
hearing all right
i would prefer that we not take the time
to do that now but i can tell the court
i am
very confident there is
this
basis i'm going to permit the question
he's an officer of the court and
as you know mr bennett count
this court has ruled on prior occasions
that
a good-faith basis can exist
notwithstanding the testimony of the
witness
of the opponent in
the other party
may i say as an aside
that by presenting that
i am in no way questioning
the quality
or the integrity of the president's
attorney mr bennett
on that date mr bennett was doing his
job as the president's lawyer he had an
affidavit from monica lewinsky that said
none of this ever happened
and so i hope that none of you will
assume that by my showing this
deposition
tape today
that i am trying to draw any unfair
inference against the president's
attorney on that date
but you can tell
from what you have just observed
that mr bennett was using monica
lewinsky's false affidavit in an attempt
to stop questioning
of the president about ms lewinsky
and what did the president do during
that
exchange he sat mute
he did not say anything to correct mr
bennett even though the president knew
that the affidavit upon which mr bennett
was relying
was utterly false
judge wright overruled mr bennett's
objection
and allowed the questioning about monica
lewinsky to proceed
later in the deposition
mr bennett read to the president the
portion of ms lewinsky's affidavit
in which she denied having a sexual
relationship
with the president
mr bennett then asked the president who
was under oath
if miss lewinsky's statement that they
never had a sexual relationship
was true and accurate
listen to the president as he responds
in paragraph eight of her affidavit she
says this i have never had a sexual
relationship with the president
he did not propose that we have a sexual
relationship he did not offer me
employment or other benefits in exchange
for a sexual relationship
he did not deny me employment or other
benefits for rejecting a sexual
relationship
[Applause]
is that a true and active statement as
far as you know that is absolutely true
the president's answer
that is absolutely true
when president clinton was asked during
his grand jury testimony eight months
later
how he could have sat silently at his
earlier deposition
while his attorney made the false
statement that there is no sex of any
kind in any manner shape or form
to judge right
the president first said
that he was not paying a great deal of
attention
to mr bennett's comments
president
before i go into a new subject area
briefly over something you were talking
about with
mr barron
the statement of
this paul uh deposition
council is fully aware page 54 line five
council is fully aware that mr winsky
has filed
has an affidavit which they are in
possession of
saying that there is absolutely no sex
of any kind in any manner shape or form
with president clinton
that statement is made by your attorney
judge susan
that's
horizor
your
that statement is
a completely false statement
whether or not mr bennett knew
of your relationship
with
of any kind in any manner
shape or form of president clinton
was an utterly false statement
is that correct
it depends upon what the meaning of the
word is
yes
if the if
it is means is and never has been that
is not
that's one thing if it means
there is none
that was a completely
true statement
but as i have testified i'd like to
testify again
this is
it is somewhat unusual
for a client to be
asked about his lawyer's statements
instead of the other way around
i
was not paying a great deal of attention
to this exchange
i was focusing on my own testimony
the president added this explanation
he was giving to the attorney
questioning him
this is what the president said
and i'm not sure
as i sit here today
that i sat there and followed all those
interchanges between the lawyers i'm
quite sure that i didn't follow all the
interchanges between the lawyers all
that carefully
and i don't really believe therefore
that i can say mr bennett's testimony or
statement is testimony
and is imputable to me i didn't i don't
know that i was really paying attention
paying that much attention to him
this denial of the president
that while his attorney was proffering a
false statement
to judge right in an effort to keep the
paula jones lawyers from even
questioning the president about his
relationship with monica lewinsky simply
does not withstand the test of truth the
videotape of the president's january
deposition
shows the president paying very close
attention
to mr bennett when mr bennett was making
the statement about no sex of any kind
view again the video clip of the
president
during mr bennett's argument that the
jones lawyers have no right to ask
questions about monica lewinsky
only this time
watch the president as he focuses on his
lawyer speaking about one of the most
important subjects he has ever faced in
his entire life
the survival of his presidency
your honor excuse me mr president
i need some guidance from the court at
this point i i'm going to object to the
innuendo i'm afraid
as i say that this will leak i don't
question the predicates here i question
the good faith of counsel
uh the innuendo in the question council
is fully aware
that miss lewinsky
has filed has an affidavit which they
are in possession of
saying that there is absolutely no sex
of any kind in any manner shape or form
with president clinton and yet
listening to the innuendo in the
question no now just a minute let me
make my ruling i do not know
uh whether council
is basing this question on any affidavit
but i will direct mr bennett not to
comment on other evidence
that might be pertinent and could be
arguably coaching the witness
at this juncture now i
mr fischer is an officer of this court
and i have to assume that he has a good
faith basis for asking this question
if in fact he has no good faith basis
for asking the question he could later
be sanctioned if you would like i would
be happy to review on camera any good
faith basis he might have
well your honor with all due respect i i
would like to know the proper i'm not
coaching the witness
in preparation of the witness for this
deposition the witness is fully aware
of miss lewinsky's affidavit so i've not
told him a single thing he doesn't know
but i think when he asks questions like
this where he's sitting on an affidavit
from the witness he should at least have
a good faith proper i now i agree with
you that he needs to have a good faith
basis question maybe yes and i am
assuming that he does and i will be
willing to review this in camera if he
does not want to reveal it to council
i would i would welcome an opportunity
to to explain to the court that what our
good faith basis is in an in-camera
hearing all right
but
i would prefer that we not take the time
to do that now but i can tell the court
i am
very confident there is
i'm going to permit the question he's an
officer of the court and
as you know mr bennett count
this court has ruled on prior occasions
that a good-faith basis can exist
notwithstanding the testimony of the
witness
of the opponent in
the other party
by the way lest there be any doubt
in the minds of any member of this body
as to whom the president was looking at
and focusing at we are fully prepared to
bring in a witness for you
who is present at the deposition and who
will draw a map for every member of this
body and show the location of the
president and every other person around
the table
just in case the president's i wasn't
paying any attention excuse didn't fly
the president in his grand jury
testimony decided to try another
argument on precise
he suggested that when mr bennett made
his statement
about there is no sex of any kind
the president was focusing on the
meaning of the word
is
he then said
that when mr bennett made the assertion
that there is
no sex of any kind
mr bennett was speaking
only in the present tense
as if the president understood that to
mean
there is no sex
because there was no sex occurring at
the time mr bennett's remark was made
the president stated
it depends on what the meaning of the
word is
is
and that if it means there is none
that was a completely true
statement listen and watch again to the
same video clip from the president's
grand jury testimony we saw a few
moments ago only this time pay close
attention to the president's excuse as
to why he did not have to comply with
the truth because in his mind
there is some question as to what the
meaning of the word is is
president
before i go into a new secretary and
briefly go over something you were
talking about with
mr barron
the statement of uh
council is fully aware page 54 line five
council is fully aware that mr winsky is
filing
has an affidavit which they are in
possession of
saying that there is absolutely no sex
of any kind in any manner shape or form
with president clinton
that statement is made by your attorney
and finally judge susan morris
that's correct
your
that statement is
a completely false statement
whether or not mr bennett knew
of your relationship
with ms lewinsky the statement that
there was no sex
of any kind in any manner
shape or form with president clinton
was an utterly false state
is that
correct it depends upon what the meaning
of the word is
yes
if if
means is and never has been that is not
that's one thing if it means there is
none
that was a completely
true statement
but as i have testified i'd like to
testify again
this is
it is somewhat unusual
for a client to be
asked about his lawyer statements
instead of the other way around
i
was not paying a great deal of attention
to this exchange
i was focusing on my own testimony
in essence
here is what the president says
in his own defense
i wasn't paying any attention to what my
lawyer was saying
when he offered the false affidavit on
my behalf to the judge however
if i was paying attention
i was focusing on the very narrow
definition
of what the word is is and the tense in
which
that was presented
now i'm a former prosecutor
and that's like the murderer
who says i have an iron-clad alibi
i wasn't at the crime scene i was home
with my mother
eating apple pie
but if i was there it is a clear case of
self-defense
the president now asks this body of
lawmakers to give acceptance to these
ludicrous definitions
of ordinary words and phrases
he asks you to believe
this is what he really thought
when he was asked if he ever had sexual
relations with monica lewinsky and when
he was asked about her false affidavit
by the way as to the president's tense
argument
that he just presented
about what the meaning of the word is is
this fails to take into account
another important fact
the false affidavit of monica lewinsky
that mr bennett was waving that day
before the judge
made no such distinction her affidavit
never said in the present tense
i am not now having a sexual
relationship with the president
her affidavit said
i have
never had a sexual relationship
with the president
the president perjured himself
when he said that mr bennett's statement
that there was no sex of any kind was
quote
absolutely true
depending on what the meaning of the
word is is
the president did not admit to the grand
jury that mr bennett's statement was
false
because to do so
would have been to admit that the term
sexual relations as used in ms
lewinsky's affidavit
meant no sex of any kind
admitting that would be to admit that he
perjured himself previously in his
testimony and in his deposition
now interestingly ms lewinsky
doesn't bother attempting to match the
president's linguistic deconstructions
of the english language
after she was granted immunity
monica lewinsky testified under oath
that the part of her affidavit denying a
sexual relationship with the president
was a lie
i read from page 204
of ms lewinsky's testimony
question to ms
lewinsky let me ask you a
straightforward question
paragraph eight referring to her
affidavit
at the start says quote
i have never had a sexual relationship
with the president
end quote
is that true
answer
no
thus the president engaged in an
evolving series of lies during his sworn
testimony in order to cover previous
lies he told in sworn testimony
and to conceal his conduct
that obstructed justice in the paula
jones sexual harassment suit against him
he did this to deny paula jones her
constitutional right to bring a case of
sexual harassment against him and to
sidetrack the the investigation of the
office of independent counsel
into his misconduct
finally the president committed perjury
before the grand jury when he testified
falsely about his blatant attempts to
influence the testimony of potential
witnesses and his involvement in a plan
to hide evidence
that had lawfully been subpoenaed in the
civil rights action brought against him
this pejorious testimony breaks down
into four categories
first he made false and misleading
statements to the grand jury concerning
his knowledge of monica lewinsky's false
affidavit
second he made false and misleading
statements to the grand jury when he
related a false account of his
interaction with his secretary betty
curry when he reasonably knew she might
later be called before the grand jury to
testify
third he made perjurious and misleading
statements to the grand jury when he
denied engaging in a plan to hide
evidence that had been subpoenaed in the
jones civil rights case against him
and finally he made furious and
misleading statements to the grand jury
concerning statements he made to his
aides about monica lewinsky when he
reasonably knew these aids might be
called later to testify
let's look briefly at the first area
the president made false and misleading
statements before the grand jury
regarding his knowledge of the contents
of monica lewinsky's affidavit
as we now know conclusively monica
lewinsky filed an affidavit in the jones
case in which she denied ever having a
sexual relationship with the president
and that was a lie when it was filed
remember during his deposition in the
jones case the president said that ms
lewinsky's denial of ever having a
sexual relationship was absolutely true
monica lewinsky later testified that she
is 100 sure
that the president suggested she might
want to sign an affidavit to avoid
testifying in the case of jones versus
clinton
in fact the president gave the following
testimony before the grand jury
and did i hope she'd be able to get out
of testifying on an affidavit absolutely
did i want her to execute a false
affidavit
no i did not
this testimony is false
because it could not be possible
that monica lewinsky could have filed a
truthful affidavit in the jones case an
affidavit acknowledging a sexual
relationship with the president that
would have helped her to avoid having to
appear as a witness
in the paula jones case
the attorneys for paula jones were
seeking evidence of sexual relationships
with the president
and ones that the president might have
had with other state or federal
employees
this information was legally obliged to
be produced by the president to paula
jones and her sexual harassment lawsuit
against him to help her prove her claim
judge susan weber wright had already
ruled that paula jones was entitled to
this information from the president for
purposes of discovery
if monica lewinsky filed a truthful
affidavit that acknowledged a sexual
relationship with the president then she
certainly could not have avoided
ever having to testify in a deposition
the president knew this
his grand jury
testimony on this subject is
perjurious
next the president provided false
testimony
concerning his conversations with his
personal secretary betty curry about
monica lewinsky after he testified in
the jones deposition
recall the timeline from mr manager
hutchinson's presentation a short time
ago
the president had just testified on
january 17 1998 in the paula jones
deposition
he said he could not recall being alone
with monica lewinsky and that he did not
have a sexual relationship with her
after his testimony on the very next day
in a separate and in a separate
conversation with her a few days later
president clinton made statements to ms
curry that he knew were false
and he made them to coach ms curry and
to influence her potential testimony
he coached her by reciting inaccurate
answers to possible questions that she
might be asked if she were called to
testify in the paula jones case
by the way
the president discussed his deposition
testimony with ms curry in direct
violation of judge wright's order that
he not discuss his testimony with anyone
judge wright warned the president at the
deposition
before he leaves i want to remind him as
the as the witness in this matter
that this case is subject to a
protective order regarding all discovery
all parties present including the
witness are not to say anything
whatsoever about the questions they were
asked the substance of the deposition
any details
after he coached
betty curry
the president wanted betty curry to be a
witness
during his deposition testimony the
president did everything he could
to suggest to the jones lawyers they
needed to depose betty curry
he did this by referring to her over and
over again as the one with the
information that they need to get their
answers about monica lewinsky
the president stated to the jones
lawyers in his deposition for example
that the last time he had seen ms
lewinsky
was when she had come to the white house
to see miss curry
that miss curry was present when the
president had made a joking reference
about the jones case to ms lewinsky that
ms curry was his source of information
about vernon jordan's assistance to ms
lewinsky and that ms curry had helped
set up the meetings between ms lewinsky
and mr jordan regarding her move to new
york
because the president referred so often
to betty curry it is obvious he wanted
her to become a witness in the jones
case particularly if specific
allegations about the president's
relationship with monica lewinsky came
to light
according to ms curry president clinton
even told her at some point
that she might be asked
about monica lewinsky
two and a half hours
after the president returned from his
deposition in the jones case
president clinton
called betty curry at home and asked her
to come to the white house the next day
which was a sunday
miss curry testified that it was rare
for the president
to ever ask her to come into work on a
sunday
at about 5 p.m on sunday january 18th
the day after his deposition testimony
ms curry went to meet with president
clinton at the white house
listen to what betty betty curry told
the jury the grand jury
he said that he had his deposition
yesterday
and they had asked several questions
about monica lewinsky and i was a little
shocked by that or shrugging
and he said
i don't know if he said i think he may
have said
there are several things you may want to
know
or
there are things
he asked me
some questions
according to betty curry the president
then said to her in rapid succession
you were always
there when she was there right
we were never really alone
you could see and hear everything
monica came on to me and i never touched
her right
she wanted to have sex with me
and i can't do that
ms curry indicated
that these remarks were quote
more like statements
than questions
ms curry concluded
that the president
wanted her to agree with him
ms curry also said
that she felt the president made these
remarks
to see her
reaction miss curry said that she
indicated her agreement
with each of the president's statements
although she knew
that the president and monica lewinsky
had in fact been alone in the oval
office and in the president's study
ms curry also knew
that she could not
and did not hear or see the president
and ms lewinsky
while they were alone
miss curry testified that two or three
days after her conversation with the
president at the white house
he again called her into the oval office
to discuss this
she described their conversation as
quote
sort of a recapitulation of what we had
talked about on sunday you know i was
never alone with her that sort of thing
question to miss curry
did he pretty much list the same
answer to my recollection sir
yes
in his grand jury testimony
the president was asked why he might
have said to ms curry in their meeting
on that sunday
we were never alone together right
and you could see and hear everything
here's how the president responded
what i was trying to determine
was whether my recollection was right
and that she was always in the office
complex when monica was there
and whether she thought she could hear
any conversations we had or did she hear
any i was trying to i knew to a
reasonable certainty
that i was going to be asked more
questions about this
i didn't really expect you to be in the
jones case at the time
i thought what would happen is that it
would break in the press and i was
trying to get the facts down
i was trying to understand
what the facts were the president
told the grand jury that he was putting
those questions to betty curry on that
sunday
to refresh his recollection and trying
to pin down what the facts were
later the president stated that he was
referring to a larger area than simply
the room where he and ms lewinsky
were occupying
he also testified that his statements to
ms curry were intended to cover a
limited range of dates
listen to the president's answer
when i said we were never alone right
i think i also asked her a number of
other questions because there were
several times as i'm sure she would
acknowledge
when i either asked her to be around
i remember once in particular when i was
talking with ms lewinsky when i asked
betty to be in the actually in the next
room in the dining room
and as i testified earlier once in her
own office
but i meant that she was always in the
oval office complex in that complex
while monica was there
and i believe that this was part of a
series of questions i asked her to try
to quickly refresh my memory
so
i wasn't trying to get her to say
something that wasn't so
and in fact
i think she would recall that i told her
just to relax
go to the grand jury and tell the truth
when she had been called as a witness
now the president was treating the grand
jury to his construction of what the
word alone
means to him
when asked
he answered
it depends on how you define alone
and there were a lot of times when we
were alone
but i never really thought we were
the president also was asked about his
specific statement to betty curry
that you could see and hear everything
he testified that he was uncertain what
he intended by that comment
question to the president
when you said to mrs curry that you
could see and hear everything that
wasn't true either was it as far as you
knew
answer
my memory of that was that that she had
the ability to hear what was going on if
she came in the oval office from her
office and a lot of times you know
when i was in the oval office she just
had the door open to her office
then there was
the door was never completely closed to
the hall
so i think there was i'm not entirely
sure what i meant by that but i could
have meant that she generally would be
able to hear conversations even if she
couldn't see them and i think that's
what i meant
the president also was asked about his
comment to ms curry
that monica lewinsky had come on to him
and that he had never touched her
question to the president
if ms curry testified that you told her
monica came on to me and i never touched
her
you did in fact of course touch
ms lewinsky isn't that right in a
physically intimate way
answered by the president
now i've testified about that and that's
one of those questions that i believe is
answered by the statement i made
and incidentally that's the statement
that he read at the beginning of his
deposition testimony that i've already
discussed
question to the president
what was your purpose in making these
statements to mrs curry if it wasn't for
the purpose of trying to suggest to her
what she should say if ever asked
answered by the president
now mr bittman i told you the only thing
i remember is when all this stuff blew
up i was trying to figure out what the
facts were
i was trying to remember
i was trying to remember every time i
had seen ms lewinsky i knew
this was all going to come out i did not
know at the time that the office of
independent council was involved and i
was trying to get the facts and try to
think of the best defense we could
construct in the face of what i thought
was going to be a media onslaught
finally the president was asked why he
would have called ms curry into his
office a few days after the sunday
meeting and repeated the statements
about ms lewinsky to her
the president testified that although he
would not dispute ms curry's testimony
to the contrary he did not remember
having a second conversation with her
along these lines
thus the president referred to ms curry
many times in his deposition when
describing his relationship with monica
lewinsky
he himself admitted that a large number
of questions about ms lewinsky were
likely to be asked in the very near
future
the president reasonably could foresee
that ms curry either might be deposed or
questioned or might need to prepare an
affidavit when he testified he was only
making statements to ms curry to
ascertain what the facts were trying to
ascertain what betty's perception was
this statement was false
and it was perjurious
we know it was perjury because the
president called ms curry into the white
house
the day after his deposition to tell her
not ask her to tell her
that he was never alone with monica
lewinsky to tell her that ms curry could
always see or hear them and to tell her
that he never touched monica lewinsky
these were false statements and he knew
that the statements were false at the
time he made them to betty curry
the president's suggestion that he was
simply trying to refresh his memory when
talking to betty curry is nonsense
what if miss curry
what if miss curry had confirmed these
statements
statements the president knew were false
it could not in any way
remind the president
of what really happened in the oval
office with monica lewinsky because the
president already knew
he was alone with monica lewinsky the
president already knew that obviously
mrs curry couldn't always see him back
in the oval office area with monica
lewinsky and the president already knew
that he had an intimate sexual
relationship
with monica lewinsky
there is no logical way to justify his
claim that he made these statements to
refresh his memory
the only reasonable inference from the
president's conduct is that he tried to
enlist a potential witness to back up
his perjury from the day before at the
deposition
the circumstances surrounding the
president's statements clearly show
clearly show that he improperly sought
to influence ms curry's potential future
testimony his actions were an
obstruction of justice and a blatant
attempt to illegally influence the
truthful testimony of a potential
witness and his later denials about it
under oath or perjury
next the president gave projects false
and misleading testimony before the
grand jury when he denied he was engaged
in a plot to hide evidence that had been
subpoenaed in the paula jones case on
december 19 1997 paula strike that
monica lewinsky was served with a
subpoena in the paula jones case the
subpoena required her to testify at a
deposition in january and the subpoena
required her to produce each and every
gift president clinton had ever given
her
nine days after she received this
subpoena ms lewinsky met with the
president for about 45 minutes in the
oval office
by this time president clinton knew that
she had been subpoenaed in the case
at this meeting they discussed the fact
that the gifts that he had given monica
lewinsky had been subpoenaed including a
hat pin
the first gift the president had ever
given ms lewinsky
monica lewinsky testified that at some
point in the meeting she said to the
president
well you know i maybe i should put the
gifts away outside my house somewhere or
give them to someone maybe betty
and he sort of said i think he responded
i don't know
or
let me think about that
and then left the topic
president clinton provided the following
explanation of the grand jury and of the
house judiciary committee regarding this
conversation
statement by the president
ms lewinsky said something to me like
what if they ask me about the gifts
you've given me
but i do not know whether that
conversation occurred on december 28
1997 or earlier
whenever this conversation occurred i
testified i told her
that if they meaning the jones lawyers
asked her for gifts
she'd have to give them
whatever she had
i simply was not concerned about the
fact that i had given her gifts indeed i
gave her additional gifts on december 28
1997.
the president's statement that he told
ms lewinsky that if the attorneys for
paula jones asked for the gifts then she
had to provide them
his perjury
it strains all logic to believe the
president would encourage monica
lewinsky to turn over the gifts to do so
would have raised questions about their
relationship and would go against all of
their other efforts to conceal the
relationship including filing a false
affidavit about their relationship
the fact that the president gave monica
lewinsky additional gifts on december 28
1997 doesn't exonerate the president it
demonstrates that the president never
believed that monica lewinsky in light
of all of their relationship all of the
cover stories all of the plans that they
had put forward
her willingness to subject herself to a
perjury prosecution by filing a false
affidavit all of that was because he
knew
that monica lewinsky would never turn
those gifts over
pursuant to the subpoena
and as ms lewinsky testified she never
questioned as she said quote
that we were ever going to do anything
but keep
this quiet
this meant that they would take in her
words quote
whatever steps needed to be taken end
quote
to keep it quiet
by giving more gifts to monica lewinsky
after she received a subpoena to appear
in the jones case
the president believed that monica
lewinsky would never testify truthfully
about their relationship
additionally ms lewinsky said she could
not answer why the president would give
her more gifts on the 28th
when he knew she had to produce gifts in
response to a subpoena she did testify
however
that to me it was never a question in my
mind and i from everything he said to me
i never questioned him that we were
never going to do anything but keep this
private
so that meant deny it
and that meant do take whatever
appropriate steps needed to be taken you
know for that to happen
so by turning over these gifts
it would at least prompt the jones
attorneys to question me about what kind
of friendship i had with the president
at this meeting on the morning of
december 28th betty curry called monica
lewinsky and made arrangements to pick
up gifts the president had given to ms
lewinsky
monica lewinsky testified under oath
before the grand jury that a few hours
after meeting with the president on
december 28th where they discussed what
to do about the gifts he gave to her
betty curry called monica lewinsky
monica lewinsky explained it to the
grand jury as follows question
what did betty curry say
answer she said
i understand you have something to give
me
or
the president said
you have something to give me along
those lines
question
and when she said something along the
lines of i understand you have something
to give me or the president said you
have something to give me
what did you understand her to mean
answer
the gifts
later in the day on december 28th
ms curry drove to monica lewinsky's home
ms lewinsky gave miss curry a sealed box
that contained several gifts ms lewinsky
had received from the president
including the hat pin that was
specifically named in the jones subpoena
ms curry testified that she understood
the box contained gifts from the
president
she took the box to her home
and put it under her bed for safekeeping
betty curry testified that she did not
recall the president asking her to
retrieve the gifts
she said she thought monica lewinsky
called
and asked her to come and get the gifts
however when confronted with monica
lewinsky's account
that ms curry had in fact spoken to the
president about the gift transfer ms
curry replied
she may remember better than i
i don't remember
as further cooperation monica lewinsky
had told the fbi earlier that when betty
curry called her about these gifts it
sounded like betty curry was calling on
her cell phone
ms lewinsky gave her best guess on the
time of day the call came on december
28th
although ms lewinsky's guess on the hour
of the call came was a bit off
phone records were later produced
revealing that betty curry in fact
called monica lewinsky on her cell phone
just as ms lewinsky had described
the only logical conclusion
is that betty curry called monica
lewinsky about retrieving the
president's gifts
there would there would have been no
reason for betty curry
out of the blue
to return gifts unless instructed to do
so by the president
betty curry didn't know about the gift
issue ahead of time only the president
and monica lewinsky had
discussed it
there is no other way miss curry could
have known to call monica lewinsky about
the gifts
unless the president told her to do it
president clinton perjured himself when
he testified before the grand jury on
this issue and reiterated to the house
judiciary committee that he did not
recall any conversation with ms curry
around december 28th
he also perjured himself when he
testified before the grand jury that he
did not tell betty curry to take
position of the take possession of the
gifts that he had given ms lewinsky
question to the president
after you gave the gifts on december
28th did you speak with your secretary
ms curry to ask her to pick up a box of
gifts that were some compilation of
gifts that miss lewinsky would have
answered no sir i didn't do that to give
to miss curry answer i did not do that
the president had a motive to conceal
the gifts
because both he and ms lewinsky were
concerned that the gifts might raise
questions about their relationship
by confirming that the gifts would not
be produced the president ensured that
these questions would never arise
the concealment of these gifts from
paula jones attorneys allowed the
president to provide for jurious
statements about the gifts at his
deposition
in the jones case
finally the president gave progeria's
testimony to the grand jury concerning
statements he made to his top aides
regarding his relationship with monica
lewinsky
here is a portion of his grand jury
transcript where the president testified
about his conversations with key aides
once the monica lewinsky story became
public
question to the president
did you deny to them or not mr president
answer
i did not want to mislead my friends but
i want to define language where i can
say that
i also frankly do not want to turn
any of them into witnesses because i and
sure enough they all became witnesses
question
well you knew they might be witnesses
didn't you answer
and so i said to them things that were
true
about this relationship
that i used in the language i used i
said there is nothing going on between
us that was true
i said i have not had sex with her as i
defined it that was true
and did i hope that i would never have
to be here on this day giving this
testimony of course
but i also didn't want to do anything to
complicate this matter further so i said
things that were true
they may have been misleading and if
they were i have to take responsibility
for it and i'm sorry
the president's testimony that day that
he said things that were true to his
aides is clearly project
just as the president predicted several
of the president's top aides later were
called to testify before the grand jury
as to what the president told them and
when they testified before the grand
jury
they passed along the president's false
accounts
just as the president intended them to
do i will not belabor the point any
further with the members of this body
because i think mr manager hutchinson
ably presented that testimony but we
know from the testimony
that erskine bowles john podesta sidney
blumenthal all came before the grand
jury
they all provided testimony to the grand
jury
establishing that the president's
comments to them were the truth
the president had them go in the
president gave them that information so
false information would be shared with
the grand jury
so that the grand jury would never be on
to the truth
and when witnesses are called to come
before this body
you will have an opportunity
to make that determination
mr chief justice
and members of the united states senate
posterity looks to this body
to defend in a courageous way the public
trust
and take care that the basis of our
government is not undermined
on january 17 1998 president clinton
while a defendant in a civil rights
sexual harassment lawsuit
gave sworn testimony in a deposition
presided over by a federal judge
in this deposition he raised his hand
and he swore to tell the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth
on august 17th president clinton
testified before a federal grand jury in
a criminal investigation at this
appearance he raised his hand and he
swore to tell the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth
the evidence conclusively shows that the
president rejected his obligations under
oath on both occasions he engaged in a
serial pattern of perjury and
obstruction of justice
these corrupt acts were done
so he could deny a united states citizen
mrs paula jones her constitutional right
to bring her claim against him in a
court of law
in so doing he intentionally violated
his oath of office his constitutional
duty to take care that the laws be
faithfully executed
and his solemn obligation to respect mrs
jones's rights
by providing truthful testimony under
oath
the evidence reviewed by the house of
representatives and relied upon by our
body in bringing articles of impeachment
against the president was not political
it was overwhelming
he has denied all allegations set forth
in these articles
who is telling the truth there is only
one way to find out
on behalf of the house of
representatives
we urge this body to bring forth the
witnesses and place them all under oath
if the witnesses can make the case
against the president
if the witnesses that make the case
against the president who incidentally
are his employees his top aides his
former interns and his close friends if
all of these people in the president's
universe are lying
then the president has been done
a grave disservice
he deserves not just an acquittal
he deserves the most profound of
apologies
but if they are not lying
if the evidence is true
if the chief executive officer of our
nation
used his power and his influence to
corruptly destroy
a lone woman's right to bring forth her
case in a court of law
then there must be constitutional
accountability
and by that i mean the kind of
accountability the framers of the
constitution intended for such conduct
and not the type of accountability that
satisfies the temporary mood of the
moment
our founders bequeath to us a nation of
laws
not of polls not of focus groups and not
of talk show habituates
america is strong enough to absorb the
truth about their leaders
when those leaders act in a manner
destructive to their oath of office
god help our country's future if we ever
decide otherwise
the the chair recognizes the majority
leader
mr chief justice uh i ask unanimous
consent that the courts stand and
adjournment until 1 pm tomorrow and that
all members remain standing at their
desks as the chief justice departs the
chamber i further ask that after the
court adjourns in a moment the senate
will while in legislative session stand
in recess subject to the call of the
chair
without objection it is so ordered
and
when they ask the right questions like
they did about uh
jennifer flowers he answered truthfully
he had to but when they give him a
little bit of wiggle room like this
definition about what is and what isn't
sex he tried to wiggle out of it
whether he did legally or not i guess is
a big question but
i hope they get the message that please
you politicians don't ever do this to us
again
thanks for that call from san francisco
once again the senate in session
momentarily when they take breaks this
afternoon we'll be back for more of your
calls during those break sessions and
also when the session is over today we
expect that to be about six o'clock
so
foreign
so
foreign
the senate will convene as a court of
impeachment the chaplain will offer
prayer
holy god
with awe and wonder we accept our
responsibilities
and our accountability to you
you are sovereign of this land
when we commit our complexities to you
really seek your guidance
you direct us
make us attentive listeners
dedicated
to the search for absolute truth
in the cacophony of voices
help us to hear
your voice
dear father your faithfulness never
fails
you are consistent reliable and true
you expect nothing less from us
for your glory and the good of america
to that end
fill this chamber with your presence
and the mind of the senators
with your gift of discernment
you are our lord
and savior
amen
the sergeant-at-arms will make the
proclamation
all persons are commanded to keep silent
on pain of imprisonment while the senate
of the united states is sitting for the
trial of the articles of impeachment
exhibited by the house of
representatives against william
jefferson clinton
president of the united states
the majority leader is recognized mr
chief justice
uh there have been a number of uh
inquiries uh from senators and others
about uh some uh clarity with regard to
the approximate times or the times that
we would be
meeting on saturday and tuesday and so
i'd like to go through and also how the
afternoon will proceed so i would make
some unanimous consent requests that
would clarify that and give you a brief
rundown on what i think the schedule
will be this afternoon
mr chief justice as in legislative
session i ask unanimous consent that
when the senate completes its business
today at stand in adjournment until 10
a.m
on saturday january 16th i further asked
when the senate reconvenes on saturday
immediately following the prayer the
senate resumed consideration of the
articles of impeachment
without objection it is so ordered
i further ask consent that when the
senate completes its business on
saturday it then adjourn over until
tuesday january 19th at 9 30 a.m i ask
unanimous consent that on tuesday
immediately following the prayer the
journal proceedings be approved to date
the morning hour be deemed to have
expired and the time for the two leaders
be reserved for their use i further ask
consent that there be a period of
morning business until the hour of 11 30
a.m was 60 minutes under the control of
the majority leader or his designee and
60 minutes under the control of the
minority leader or his design i ask
unanimous consent that on tuesday the
senate recess then for the from the
hours of 11 30
a.m until 1 00
p.m for the weekly policy conferences
and i further ask consent that at 1 pm
on tuesday the senate resume
consideration of the articles of
impeachment
without objection it is so ordered and
mr chief justice i asked consent then
that on tuesday following the conclusion
of the presentation during the court of
impeachment the senate recess until the
hour of 8 35 pm uh on tuesday evening
and i asked consent that upon
reconvening tuesday evening the senate
proceed to the hall of the house of
representatives in order to hear an
address by the president regarding the
state of the union
without objection it is so ordered for
the information of all my colleagues
then i understand that today's
presentation is expected to continue
until approximately 6 pm
there will be periodic breaks during the
day to allow all members to stand and
stretch
i want to remind senators to promptly
return to their desk at the expiration
of those 15-minute breaks in order that
we can continue and complete at the
earliest possible hour i thank all
members for their corporation this
afternoon we will have hear from
congressman mccollum take a 15-minute
break then hear from congressman geekes
and chapman and cannon and then take a
break and then uh congressman barr would
complete the afternoon's presentations
mr chief justice i yield the floor
if there's no objection the journeys of
journal of proceedings of the trial are
approved to date
first on to the provisions of senate
resolution 16 the managers for the house
of representatives have eight hours and
56 minutes remaining to make the
presentation of their case the senate
will now hear you the presiding officer
recognizes mr manager mccollum to resume
the presentation of the case for the
house of representatives
thank you mr chief justice
mr chief justice and my colleagues in
the senate
i
drove in this morning to this capitol i
drove up the george washington parkway
and i looked at the magnificent display
of ice that was all over the trees all
over the grass all over the foliage in a
beautiful panorama and just before i got
to the 14th street bridge i saw this
incredible number of geese
i guess in the hundreds that were lined
up together between the highway and the
potomac river
it looked like they were an invading
army and i thought of the awe of this
the awe the beauty of it the awe of
mother nature
the awe of god
and i thought also
of the awe of the responsibility we have
to our children and our grandchildren
about what we're commencing today this
is an awesome undertaking for all of us
i'm here today to summarize for you what
you heard yesterday
i don't want to bore you i don't intend
to do that i'm going to be as brief as i
can
i'm also here to help you digest the
voluminous quantity of material that you
have before you there's a huge record
out there
and i'm also here to prepare you for the
law discussion that's going to come
after me about the law
of the crimes of perjury and obstruction
of justice and witness tampering
first of all i want you to know that i
bear no personal animosity toward our
president
but i happen to believe
that if the president if any president
commits the crimes of perjury and
obstruction of justice and witness
tampering he should not be allowed
to remain in office for if he is allowed
to do so it would undermine our courts
and our system of justice
but that's for you to determine in the
end really not me that's my opinion but
you are going to have to weigh the
evidence you're going to have to hear
the arguments and ultimately make that
decision in fact the first thing you
have to determine is whether or not
the president committed crimes
it's only if you determine he committed
the crimes of perjury obstruction of
justice and witness tampering that you
ever move on to the question of whether
he is removed from office in fact no one
none of us would argue to you that the
president should be removed from office
unless you conclude he committed
the crimes that he's alleged to have
committed
not every one of them necessarily but
certainly a good quantity and there are
a whole bunch of them in charge and i
would like to call your attention to a
couple of things
first of all i don't want to be a
teacher school teacher i just want to
relate my own experience to you so you
can understand it
i've been involved with this for a lot
longer than most of you probably have
been dealing with the details of it
and i constantly have to refer back to
things and every time i read something
there's so much detail here i learned
something new
and while i'm going to go over this
record today with you and we're going to
summarize the evidence one more time as
you're deliberating as you're thinking
about it i want to call a couple of
places to your attention that are the
easiest places to refer back and find
the facts the evidence and and so forth
first of all there is the report the
official report that's in the record of
the the house's consideration of this
the judiciary committee report
in that report right in the first couple
of pages there's a table of contents and
while a couple of the articles did not
come over to you that are listed in here
there are detailed discussions you can
get to from this table of contents as to
every single count and every single part
of these articles so you can figure out
what we're talking about today and
remind yourself of that
secondly
i'd like to bring to your attention that
there's a star report and i know that's
been blind
you know by some people maligned by them
but this thing is so dog-eared i got
i've underlined it i've torn it apart
practically i've done all kinds of
things with it it's a good reference
source you can go find from the
footnotes in here where else to check it
out and then there are two parts i won't
bring them both up here these are the
appendices to that in the first part
you can find the transcript of all the
key depositions all the key testimony
all of the evidence that we're talking
about and read it for yourselves so i
don't want to leave here today having
summarized this evidence as long as i
may take and i don't want to take a long
time but i'm going to take a little
while and have you go away and think
gosh
you know what all did mccollum say or
hutchinson or rogan or bryant yesterday
or whatever you can find and refresh
yourself through that and through
whatever other information the trial
briefs and all that you have
now let's look at what the record shows
president clinton was sued
by paula jones in a sexual
harassment civil rights lawsuit
to bolster her case she was trying to
show that the president engaged in a
pattern of illicit relations with women
in his employment where he rewarded
those who became involved with him
and disadvantaged those who rejected him
as paula jones did whatever the merits
of that approach
on may 27 1997
the united states supreme court ruled in
a unanimous decision
that like every other citizen and that's
a quote like every other citizen paula
jones has a right
to an ordinary disposition of her claims
then on december the 11th of 1997 judge
susan weber wright issued an order that
said paula jones was entitled to
information regarding any state or
federal employee with whom the president
had sexual relations proposed sexual
relations or sought to have sexual
relations
the record shows that president clinton
was determined to hide
his relationship with monica lewinsky
from the jones court his lawyers will
argue to you next week i'm sure that he
did everything
to keep the relationship hidden and he
did it in a legal way
they'll say that he may have spent the
flu hairs evaded answers given
misleading answers but that it was all
within the framework of responses and
actions that any good lawyer would
advise his client to do
they'll also say that if he crossed the
line technically somewhere he didn't do
it knowingly or intentionally
oh how i wish that were true
we wouldn't be here today
but alas that is not so
if you believe the sworn testimony of
monica lewinsky if you believe her
testimony that's in the record and she's
very credible
the president knowingly
intentionally and willfully
set out on a course of conduct in
december 1997 to lie to the jones court
to hide his relationship and to
encourage others to lie and hide
evidence and to conceal the relationship
with monica lewinsky from the court he
engaged in a pattern of obstruction of
justice perjury and witness tampering
designed to deny the court
what susan
weber wright the judge in that court had
determined paula jones had the right to
discover in order to prove her claim
if you believe the testimony of monica
lewinsky you cannot believe the
president or accept the argument of his
lawyers you simply can't
the record is so clear on this that if
you have any significant doubt
about monica lewinsky's credibility or
testimony you should bring her in here
and let us examine her face to face so
you can judge her credibility for
yourself
as you will hear explained later
this afternoon the same acts can
constitute both the crimes of
obstruction of justice
and perjury
the same acts
and that the same actually constitute
the crimes of obstruction of justice and
witness tampering
they're all cut from the same cloth
they're all crimes that have struck the
administration of justice and keep our
courts from being able to get the
evidence that they need to decide cases
such obstruction is so detrimental to
our system of justice that the federal
sentencing guidelines provide for a
greater punishment for perjury and
obstruction of justice than they do for
bribery and i want to show that to you i
know that everybody can't see these
charts but i think you've got a hand out
of them if you don't we'll certainly get
them to you i'm not going to show many
charts today but this is simply one
about the sentencing guidelines the
guidelines rate
these things in number sequence the most
serious sentencing is a higher number
the lower number is the lower sentence
plain old vanilla bribery writes it a 10
some other things are in eight a seven
of four you get down to murderous up and
it's way on up there in the numbers much
higher but you will see that witness
tampering
is a 12 not a 10. obstruction of justice
is a 12 not a 10. perjury is a 12 not a
10.
all of them are the same and
interestingly enough though i didn't put
it on this chart bribing a witness which
is different from plain vanilla bribery
in other words if you go out and try to
bribe somebody to do something in a
business deal that's one kind of bribery
you go on bribe a witness that's another
bribing a witness is also a 12.
now i want to point that out right up
front to you because the most important
point that makes is that
when you read the phrase in the
constitution
that what's impeachable is treason
bribery and other high crimes and
misdemeanors
bribery is not considered by our court
system pure bribery plain old bribery is
not considered as serious in sentencing
as perjury witness tampering obstruction
of justice and of course bribing a
witness and they're all of the same
cloth why because that interferes with
the administration of justice because we
can't have justice if people block the
courts from getting at the truth
and if you go about doing it
intentionally you've committed these
crimes
it should be pointed out that lies under
oath in a court proceeding whether or
not they rise to the level of crimes of
perjury can be obstruction of justice
so when the president lied in the jones
deposition in the jones deposition this
was part of the obstruction of justice
charged under article 2 that's before
you today even though there is no
separate count
and he lied a lot in that deposition
we'll talk about that a little bit later
the fact that the house did not send you
the article of impeachment for perjury
in the jones deposition does not keep
you from considering the lies in that
deposition as an obstruction of justice
crime under article 2 that's before you
and you know that it's also incorporated
in article 1 because it's one of the
four items specifically listed as the
perjury that he lied about lying in the
deposition
now
having said that think about all of this
as one big obstruction because perjury
can be obstruction just plain lying can
be obstruction witness tampering by the
way witness tampering we talk about is a
separate crime because it's titled that
way but it's one of two
separate uh
obstruction of justice
sections in the united states criminal
code it's just another version of
obstruction of justice so don't be
confused witness tampering is
obstruction of justice literally
figuratively and in every other way but
people think about it separately because
it has a separate element a lesser
element of proof actually than
obstruction of justice but it's all part
of the same fabric again
to put the essence
of all of this in a nutshell for you
think back on the evidence presented
yesterday
i would suggest
that president clinton thought his
scheme out well
he resented the jones lawsuit
he was alarmed with monica lewinsky's
name when it appeared on the witness
list and he was even more alarmed when
judge wright issued her order signaling
that the court would hear the evidence
of other relationships
to keep his relationship with monica
lewinsky from the court once judge
wright issued her ruling he knew he
would have to lie to the court
to succeed
at this he decided that he had to get
monica lewinsky to file a false
affidavit
to try to avoid having her testify
and he needed to get her a job to make
her happy
to make sure she executed that false
affidavit and then stick with her lies
when she was questioned about it
then the gifts were subpoenaed
and he had to have her hide the gifts
the only tangible evidence of his
relationship with her that would trigger
questions
she came up with the idea of giving them
to betty curry
and the president seized on it
who would think betty curry
should be called to produce the gifts
nobody would
then he'd be free to lie in his
deposition
and that's of course what he did
but after he did this he realized that
he had to make sure that betty would lie
and cover for him
he got his age convinced to repeat the
lies to the grand jury and to the public
and all of this worked
until the dress showed up
then he lied to the grand jury to try to
cover up
and explain away his prior crimes
that's the case
in a nutshell
that's why we're here today
that's what this evidence in the record
shows i believe in a compelling
exceptionally compelling way
now let's review what happened and as we
do i ask you to think back on what mr
bryant said to you yesterday
always ask yourself
what are the results of the act
and who benefited
and i think you'll find each time it's
the president who benefited
now we're going to go over the facts
on december
the 5th
1997
a year ago
about a week before a judge right issued
her order
making it clear that the president's
relationship with monica lewinsky was
relevant to the jones case ms lewinsky's
name appeared on the jones witness list
the president learned this fact
the next day
december the 6th
the president telephoned monica lewinsky
at about 2 a.m on december the 17th and
informed her about her name being on the
witness list that was about ten days
after he learned about it and about five
days after judge wright's order
the order that made it clear that his
relationship with monica was
discoverable by the jones attorneys in
that case long before this though long
before the president was called to give
a deposition or monico olinsky was named
on the witness list in the jones case
the evidence shows that she and the
president had concocted cover stories
that they had an understanding that she
would lie about the relationship and so
would he if anybody asked about it
during the telephone conversation on the
17th of december
the president told monica that she might
be called as a witness
and he at that time suggested that she
might file an affidavit
to avoid being called as a witness
to testify in person in that case
in the same conversation
they reviewed these cover stories
that they had concocted to conceal their
relationship he brought him up they went
over them again
why do you think they did that
in her grand jury testimony monica
lewinsky says the president didn't tell
her to lie
but because of their previous
understanding she assumed that they both
expected that she would lie in that
affidavit
in this context the evidence is
compelling
that the president committed both the
crimes of obstruction of justice and
witness tampering right then and there
on december 17th
now monica lewinsky's testimony is so
clear about this so clear about this
that the president's lawyers probably
won't spend a lot of time with you on
this they didn't in the judiciary
committee i could be wrong i'm saying
this either today so they probably will
just to show me i am
but i want us to look at this i want us
to specifically look at her testimony
together because it is so compelling
on pages 123 and 124 of her testimony
and you can find it in appendix a part
one to the star report
i know you can't see all of this that
that well back there but you should have
the charts here and i pointed out in red
on this chart the most important part of
it
this is where she describes the december
17 telephone conversation i'm going to
read you part of it
she says right here and this is what
i've highlighted and read
at some point in the conversation i
don't know if it was before or after the
subject of the affidavit came up he sort
of said you know
you can always say we were coming to see
betty or that you were bringing me
letters which i understood was really a
reminder of things which we had
discussed before
question
so when you say things you had discussed
sort of ruses that you can you developed
monica lewinsky
right
i mean this was this was something that
that was instantly familiar to me
question write
answer
and i knew exactly what that meant
and i knew exactly what that meant had
you talked with him earlier the
questioner asks about these false
explanations about what you were doing
visiting him on several occasions monica
lewinsky answers
down here
several occasions throughout the entire
relationship yes
it was a pattern of the relationship to
sort of conceal it
she says
now let's look at another chart
monica lewinsky's
grand jury august 6th grand jury
testimony pages 233 and 234 both of
these are the august the 6th grand jury
testimony
where in the context of affidavits she
makes the now famous statement no one
asked or encouraged me to lie she did
say that but let's look how she said
that
for me the best way to explain it she
says
for me the best way to explain how i
feel what happened was you know no one
asked or encouraged me to lie
but no one discouraged me either
but no one discouraged me either
i don't know how many times anybody said
that to you when they made the arguments
but that's what she said in the context
in which she said it then later on down
here
she says in her testimony right there on
those same pages
it wasn't as if the president called me
and said you know monica you're on the
witness list
this is going to be really hard for us
we're going to have to tell the truth
and be humiliated in front of the entire
world about what we've done which i
would have fought him on probably that
was different
and by him not calling me and saying
that you know i knew what he meant
i knew what he meant
question did you understand all along
that he would deny the relationship also
and she answers um yes
and questioner says and when you say you
understood what it meant when he didn't
say
oh you know you must tell the truth
what did you understand that to me
monica
lewinsky that that that is we had on
every other occasion and every other
instance of this relationship
we would deny it
after reading this if you believe monica
lewinsky can there be any doubt
that the president was suggesting that
she file an affidavit that contains lies
and falsehoods
that might keep her from ever having to
testify
in the jones case and give the president
the kind of protection that he needed
when he testified and of course
in that same december 17 conversation
the president encouraged monica to use
cover stories and tell the same lies
that he expected to do in the affidavit
she was called to testify live and in
person
both of those would be obstruction of
justice and witness tampering and
together
encouraging her to file this false
affidavit that she clearly describes
here
and the encouraging of her to lie if
she's ever called as a witness both of
them
are counts one and two of the
obstruction of justice charge
if i don't leave you with any other
impression walking away from here today
i want you to think about this this is
the clearest boldest most significant
obstruction of justice charge i don't
see anybody walk away from it explain it
out and it is the beginning of this
whole obstruction it is a pattern it
shouldn't be looked at in isolation but
think about it it's the kickoff to what
really happened it's why we got involved
in this in the first place the president
had a scheme and he went through this
process
and it all ties together the rest of it
two days later
monica lewinsky was subpoenaed and
contacted vernon jordan who put her in
touch with attorney frank carter that's
the attorney he picked out
as we all know this very false affidavit
that
frank carter prepared not of course
knowing it was false when he prepared it
but monica knew it and the president
knew it was filed just before the
president's deposition of the jones case
on january the 17th the record shows the
president was kept abreast of this
participation
by vernon jordan and all of its contents
jordan advised the president that when
monica signed the affidavit on january
7th he advised the president of that
fact two days before monica
says in a conversation she asked the
president if he wanted to see the draft
affidavit and he replied you recall from
yesterday he replied that he didn't need
to see it
because he'd already seen 15 others
i doubt seriously he was talking about
15 other affidavits
of somebody else he doesn't like looking
at affidavits anymore
i suspect and i would suggest to you
he's talking about 15 other drafts
of this proposed affidavit since it had
been around the horn with a lot of
drafting
the circumstantial evidence makes it
clear the president knew the content of
the lewinsky affidavit and he knew it
was false
during the president's deposition in the
jones case on january 17th his attorney
robert bennett at one point tried to
stop the jones lawyers from asking the
president about his relationship with
monica lewinsky by pointing out the
affidavit she'd signed i think we all
remember that because a lot of that on
tv up here yesterday
mr bennett asserted at the time
that the affidavit indicated quote
there is no sex of any kind manner shape
or form that's what he said
after a warning from judge wright mr
bennett stated i'm not coaching the
witness in preparation of the witness
for this deposition the witness is fully
aware
of ms lewinsky's affidavit
so i have not told him a single thing he
doesn't know
the president did not say anything to
correct mr bennett
even though he knew the affidavit was
false
the judge allowed the questioning to
proceed and later mr bennett read to the
president a portion of paragraph eight
of monica lewinsky's affidavit in which
she denied having a sexual relationship
with the president and asked him if ms
lewinsky's statement was true and
accurate to which the president
responded
that is absolutely true
i'm not going back over putting that up
on the screen again but i do
want to put up here for you what you
have in front of you paragraph eight
of monica lewinsky's affidavit
paragraph eight of her affidavit was
absolutely false and the president knew
it
i want to go over that a little bit what
it says up here at the beginning of it
is i have never had a sexual
relationship with the president he did
not propose that we have a sexual
relationship and so on and we've heard a
lot about that but look what's down at
the end of this
what's down at the end of this
and you got in front of you it says down
here the occasions that i saw the
president after i left my employment at
the white house in april 1996 were
official receptions
formal functions
or events related to the us department
of defense where i was working at the
time
there were other people present on those
occasions
i just want to point out to you that
paragraph eight which was the subject of
a lot of discussion which the president
has certainly was fully aware of which
you watched him intensely
uh responding to with regard to mr
bennett yesterday in that deposition
didn't just contain
a lie about a sexual relationship where
you can quibble over the words it is a
full fledged lie
cover story about this none of that's
true
monica lois he saw him a lot of other
times and the president certainly knew
that they weren't all official events or
anything else this is a complete
falsehood paragraph eight and the
president
knew it at that point in time when he
allowed his attorney
on the day of the deposition to make a
false and misleading statement to the
judge and the attorney didn't know that
but it was a false and misleading
statement to the judge characterizing
this affidavit he knew better
and the president at that point in time
committed the crime of obstruction of
justice and that is count five of
article two
now the president's lawyers are going to
argue that he sat silent
because he wasn't paying attention that
he didn't hear or appreciate what mr
bennett was saying
you've already seen the video
and you know that he was looking he was
looking so intently remember he was
intensely following the conversation
with his eyes i don't know if you
watched that i'm sure you did yesterday
observe that it was played twice
i don't know how anybody can say this
man wasn't paying attention he certainly
wasn't thinking about anything else
and that was very obvious from looking
at that video the president's of the
defense also falls apart in his face
during his grand jury testimony the
president argued that when mr bennett
characterized the lewinsky affidavit as
indicating there is no sex of any kind
in any manner shape or form that it was
a completely true statement
because at that particular time at that
moment that the statement was being made
on january 17 1998
there was no
sex going on
that's when the president made his
famous utterings to the jury
it depends on the meaning of the word
what the word is is
that's when he said that of course the
president knew perfectly well the
context of mr bennett's discussion with
the judge and that characterization of
the lewinsky affidavit
was referring to the denial in paragraph
eight of the affidavit that there had
never been any sexual relationship at
any time not that there was no sex or
sexual relationship going on on january
17th the day of the deposition
i implore you not to get hung up on some
of the details in this it's absurd some
of the arguments that are being made and
have been made by the president and his
attorneys to try to explain this stuff
this is a perfect example of that we
start looking around at this you can
you can't uh see the forest sometimes
for the trees the big picture is what
you need to keep in mind not the
compartmentalizations
there will be a lot of effort i'm sure
to try to go and pick it one thing or
another but this is an extraordinarily
good example of how an argument fails
when you put it in that situation and we
shouldn't play word games
when monica lewinsky was subpoenaed to
testify she was also subpoenaed to
produce gifts that the president had
given her when she met with vernon
jordan the day she received the subpoena
she told him
of her concerns about the gifts and she
asked him to tell the president about
the subpoena early in the morning on
december the 28th
near the end of the year
they met the president of monica in his
office and they exchanged gifts and
discussed the gifts being subpoenaed
according to ms lewinsky
she suggested that maybe she should put
the gifts away outside of her house
somewhere or give them to somebody like
betty curry
she says he responded the president
responded with i don't know
or let me think about that
she's very clear at no point did he ever
give her the impression that she should
turn the gifts over to the jones
attorneys
and that's important for a couple of
reasons the one right here and later in
the perjury
where the count discusses his lying
to the grand jury
consistent with their cover stories and
all the plans for denying the
relationship
her testimony in this regard is very
believable on the other hand the
president's testimony in front of the
grand jury that encouraged her to turn
over all the gifts
to the jones attorneys is not believable
how can anybody believe that
when he said that to the grand jury he
committed perjury
when a few hours later according to
monica lewinsky betty curry called her
on the telephone and said i understand
you have something to give me or
maybe she said the president said you
have something to give me and betty
curry came over and got the gifts and
took him back and hit him under her bed
at that moment
the president's crime of obstruction of
justice as described in count three
of article
two was complete
remember by their nature obstruction of
justice charges and crimes are most
frequently proven by circumstantial
evidence
as somebody said here the other day we
don't tell people we're going to go out
into the elm tree
and lie and
obstruct things
usually it's a lot more circuitous than
than that in the context of all that was
going on at the time and the general
truthfulness though of monica lewinsky's
testimony in other respects how can
anyone
come to any other conclusion
than that the president collaborated
with monica and betty to hide these
gifts on december 28th
how can you the sequence is there now
the president's lawyers may spend a lot
of time attacking this particular
obstruction of justice charge they may
question why the president would have
given monica lewinsky more gifts on
december 28th if he was expecting her to
hide the gifts
monica's explanation or testimony is
quote from everything he said to me he
expected her to conceal the gifts
including the ones being given that day
when mrs curry's call came wasn't it the
logical thing
wasn't it the logical thing for monica
to conclude that this was the result of
the president's having thought about
what to do with the gifts which he said
he was going to do according to her and
deciding to have mrs curry
hide them that's the logical thing
the president's attorneys no doubt will
also question the veracity of ms
lewinsky with regard to who made the
phone call since mrs curry's
recollection is not very good and she at
first says she recalls that monica made
and of course the phone records indicate
that mrs curry called ms lewinsky
and that's the much more logical
consequence and sequence also it doesn't
make sense that the president's
secretary who's so close to him think
about this for a minute it doesn't make
sense that she would have taken these
gifts and would have hidden them under
her bed and never talk with the
president about doing so before after
she did so that just doesn't make sense
it's also noteworthy that the president
did everything he could in his january
17 deposition to conceal the true nature
of his relationship with monica lewinsky
this is consistent with the arguments
that he never intended the gifts to be
kept from the jones attorneys
he never intended them to be to be given
to the jones attorneys
you know if he had intended to give
these gifts to the jones attorneys or
have them given why would he have gone
to this elaborate uh series of lies in
that deposition common sense tells us
that if he knew these gifts were
revealed the questions would be raised
and his relationship revealed
so all the logic is there
i don't know how you refute it
another obstruction count the
president's attorneys are likely to
spend time on is one concerning the job
search
there's no question that monica lewinsky
was looking for a job in new york a long
time before we get to december 1997 when
the affidavit and all this took place
long before the president had reason to
be concerned that she would have to
testify or he'd have to testify in the
case there's no question about that
the question
that is not that's not the issue the
question is whether or not the president
intensified his efforts to get her a job
and made sure she got one after
it became clear to him
that he would need her to lie
sign a false affidavit
and stick with her lies in any
questioning that's what counts that's
what's important did he
intensify his efforts and really go
after it was it part of that pattern i
described to you earlier that mr
hutchings described yesterday that's
what's important in other words
as count four of article two alleges did
he make sure she was rewarded for
sticking with him
in his scheme of concealment
in anticipation that this reward would
keep her happy
and keep her from turning on him
did the president make sure monica
lewinsky signed the false affidavit by
getting her a job
the record shows that while she did get
some interviews from earlier contacts
including one involving a job with the
united states ambassador to the u.n
no one of real influence around the
president put on a full court press to
get her a job and she hadn't had any
success as of december the sixth
she had not been able to get in touch
with vernon jordan uh in her recent
efforts he had met with her once in
november but as you recall from
yesterday's discussions something he
didn't even have a good memory of he
certainly wasn't very focused on it and
she wasn't getting where she wanted to
get
and so on december the sixth she
mentioned that fact to the president
remember that's
one day after she was named on the
witness list in fact that's the day
that he learned or may have learned
we know he learned of her being on that
witness list
the president met with vernon jordan the
next day but he apparently didn't
mention ms lewinsky according to mr
jordan's testimony the record shows that
not until december the 11th
did mr jordan act
to help ms lewinsky find a job
when he met with her and gave her a list
of contact names on december the 11th mr
jordan that same day made calls to
contacts at mcandrews and forbes
the parent corporation of revlon and two
other new york companies he also
telephoned the president to keep him
informed of his efforts keep in mind
that on this day this very same day
december the 11th judge wright issued
her order in the jones case entitling
jones lawyers to discover the
president's sexual relations
is that a mere coincidence
later in december monica lewinsky
interviewed with new york-based
companies that had been contacted by mr
jordan
she discussed her move to new york with
the president during their meeting on
december 28th on january the 5th she
declined the united nations offer on
january the 7th ms lewinsky signed the
false affidavit the next day on january
the 8th she interviewed in new york with
mcandrews and forbes but the interview
went very poorly learning of this vernon
jordan that very day called ronald
perlman the chairman of the board of
mcandrews and forbes she was interviewed
the next morning again and a few hours
later she refused she received an
informal offer she told jordan about it
he immediately told betty curry about it
and he personally told the president
about it later
on january 13th her job offer at revlon
was formalized and within a day or so
president clinton told erskine bowles
that ms lewinsky had found a job in the
private sector it was a big relief to
him
then our false affidavit was filed and
on january 17th the president gave his
deposition relying on the false
affidavit using their cover stories to
conceal the relationship was this full
court pressed in december and early
january to ensure monica lewinsky had a
job just a coincidence
logical common sense says no
the president needed her to continue to
cooperate in his scheme to hide their
relationship
keeping her happy
so he could control her
and she would be he would be assured
that she'd file this false affidavit and
testify and truthfully if she was called
it's the only plausible
rationale for this stepped-up job
assistance effort at this particular
time
in doing so the president committed the
crimes of obstruction of justice and
witness tampering as set forth in count
four
of article two
well we've gone through quite a few of
these
and i'm trying to be brief with you on
it but i think each one of them is
important
each one of them
entangles the present further in a web
that fits together and it's kind of
sticky just like the spider weaves
during his deposition in the jones case
the president referred to betty curry
several times
and suggested that she might have
answers to some of the questions he used
the cover stories the same ones he and
monica talked about
and he talked about betty curry a good
deal because she was a part of those
cover stories when he finished the
deposition he telephoned ms curry and he
asked her to come to his office the next
day and talk with him betty curry told a
grand jury when she came in the next day
the president raised his deposition with
her and said there were several things
he wanted to know he then rattle off
what you heard yesterday in succession
you were always there when she was there
right
we never were really alone
you could see and hear everything
monica came on to me and i never touched
her right
she wanted to have sex with me and i
can't do that
all of those weren't true they were all
falsehoods
they were all declaratory statements
they weren't questions it's clear from
the record that mrs curry always tried
her best to be loyal to the president
her boss
that's normal that's natural in
answering the questions in her testimony
she tried to portray the events and the
president's assertions in the light most
favorable to him even so
she acknowledges that she couldn't hear
and see everything that went on between
monica and the president and that she
wasn't actually present in the same room
with them on any number of occasions
so they were alone
and she couldn't say what they might
have been doing or saying on january
twentieth twenty first the president
again met with mrs curry and according
to her recapitulated what he said on
sunday day or two before right after the
deposition
in the context of everything it seems
abundantly clear that the president was
trying to make sure that betty curry
corroborated his lies and cover stories
from the deposition if she were ever
called to testify in the jones case or
before the grand jury or in any other
court proceeding that's what he was
doing
in doing so the president committed the
crimes of witness tampering
and obstruction of justice
later the president testified rather
disingenuously in my judgment that he
was simply trying to refresh his memory
when he was talking to ms curry mrs
curry's confirmation of false statements
that the president made in his
deposition could not in any way remind
him of the facts they were patently
untrue
that was
that the idea was that he was trying to
refresh his recollection is implausible
recognizing the the weakness of their
client's case
on this
the president's attorneys have suggested
that he was worried about what mrs curry
might say if the press really got after
this that's what we heard at least over
in the judiciary committee of course
it's possible that the president was
worried about the press
i i would suspect so but common sense
says he was much more worried about what
betty curry might say
to a court
after he just named her
several times
and and talked about her if she were
called as a witness in that
as those who follow me will tell you in
the arguments by the president's lawyers
that betty curry wasn't on the jones
witness list at the time and the window
of opportunity to call as a witness in
that case
closed shortly thereafter is irrelevant
they're going to argue probably they
argue to us that betty curry's name
wasn't on the witness list so that's a
big deal they say they said
but it's irrelevant it doesn't matter
witness tampering law doesn't even
require
that a pending judicial proceeding
be going on for it to be a crime
so whether her name is on the witness
list or not makes no difference remember
there are two types of obstruction of
justice
one of them does require pending
proceeding i'd submit that
that you'll hear more about this later
in the law that
this instance the president committed
both of them
he certainly should have anticipated
that she would be called in the pending
proceeding
that was going on in the jones case but
even if there was no pending proceeding
and you'll again hear more about this
later
under for a witness tampering part of
the obstruction of justice there doesn't
require to have even been an ongoing
judicial proceeding
within four or five days of this jones
deposition the president not only
explicitly denied
the true nature of his relationship with
monica lewinsky the key white house
aides he also embellished the story when
he talked to sidney blumenthal
to sidney blumenthal he portrayed monica
lewinsky as the aggressor
attacked her reputation by portraying
her as a stalker
and presented himself as the innocent
victim being attacked by the forces of
evil
certainly he wanted his denial and his
assertions to be spread to the public
by these aides but at the same time he
knew that the office of independent
counsel had recently been appointed to
investigate the monica lewinsky matter
he knew that at the time in the context
of everything else
that he was doing to hide his
relationship it seems readily apparent
that his faults and misleading
statements to these staff members
whom he knew were potential witnesses
before any grand jury proceeding were
designed in part to corruptly influence
their testimony as witnesses in fact the
president actually acknowledged this in
his grand jury testimony that he knew
his age might be called before the grand
jury
and one of the aides testified he
expected to be called sure enough they
were and they repeated the false and
misleading information he'd given them
in this the president committed the
crimes of witness tampering and
obstruction of justice is set forth in
count seven
of article
two
now that's the obstruction of justice
let's briefly review the the grand jury
perjury for a minute
if you believe monica lewinsky
the president lied to the grand jury and
committed perjury
if you believe her
and i think this one
is very important not that they all
aren't
there was the web of the obstruction
that i've just described
and then there's the grand jury perjury
on top of it and i told you earlier
perjury and just plain lying
can be all obstruction of justice as
well
but the grand jury part is much later
it's after the president
had time to really reflect on all of
this
a long time later
if you believe monica lewinsky the
president lied to the grand jury and
committed perjury in denying he had
sexual relations with monica lewinsky
even if you accept his interpretation of
the jones court definition of sexual
relations
that's really important
there isn't anything clear in the whole
darn matter than that
just look at the president's grand jury
testimony and i'm not going to go over
all of that
but it's on pages 93 and 96 is grand
jury testimony it's laid out in this
chart which you have in front of you and
i encourage you to read every page of it
carefully
specifically i call your attention to
the fact that again i'm not going to
read all this but they asked him about
touching certain parts of the body
that are defined in the definition that
you've had repeated many times publicly
and otherwise
and two of those body parts he
acknowledges
the breast and genitalia were in fact
part of the definition
and at the end of this and i think this
is very important and i'm going to read
it because it's part of his testimony he
answers the question
that is the compelling bottom line crime
this is where he purged himself above
and above all else
you are free to infer
that my testimony is that i did not have
sexual relations as i understood this
term to be defined question including
touching her breast kissing her breast
or touching her genitalia answer that's
correct
in her sworn testimony monica lewinsky
described
nine incidents
of which the president touched and
kissed her breast in four incidents
involving contact with her genitalia
on these matters lewinsky's testimony is
corroborated by the sworn testimony of
at least
six
friends and counselors to whom she
related these incidences
contemporaneously
again if you believe the testimony
monica lewinsky and it's certainly
credible here i think it's credible
throughout but it is certainly credible
with all the corroboration you've got in
the record
there is nothing clearer
in all of this
in all of this you have before you
then that the president committed the
crime of perjury in testifying before
the grand jury regarding the nature and
details of his relationship with monica
lewinsky
on the other hand there's
plenty here to indicate the president
cleverly created his own narrow
definition of sexual relations to
include only sexual intercourse absent
the explicit definition in the court
after he'd already lied in responding to
the interrogatories and other pleadings
and perhaps even in the deposition
itself in the jones case in other words
you're free to deduce
that he knew full well what most people
would include
as sexual relations oral sex and the
other intimate activities that
he was engaged in with ms lewinsky's
before he contrived his own definition
in that case you don't even have to rely
on monica lewinsky's
testimony to conclude that he committed
the crime of perjury and testifying
before the grand jury on the nature of
his relationship with her
there are other perjurious
lies the president's grand jury
testimony contains regarding the nature
and details of his relationship with her
i'm not going to outline all of those i
want to call your attention to one
the president's prepared statement given
under oath said i regret regret that
what began as a friendship came to
include this conduct you may remember
that
from mr rogan i think yesterday
i regret that what began as a friendship
came to include this conduct that's what
he said in the grand jury
the evidence indicates that he lied
as ms lewinsky testified her
relationship with the president began
with flirting
including ms lewinsky showing the
president her underwear
and just a couple of hours
later they were kissing and engaging in
intimacies
that's a little more a little bit more
than friendship
he lied
when he said that to the grand jury
before the grand jury the president
swore he said that he testified
truthfully at his deposition remember i
told you i was going to come back to
this it's important because the grand
jury i mean the
paula jones deposition testimony is
relevant to obstruction of justice but
it's also relevant
to the perjury here because one of the
portions of the perjury
article that you have before us includes
this issue of lying
in the deposition
the perjury in this case is not the
lying in the deposition it's the lying
to the grand jury about whether he lied
in the deposition
he didn't have to have committed perjury
we didn't send you the perjury count
over from the deposition but if he lied
lying could be less than perjury if he
lied
in the deposition
and then he told the grand jury that he
didn't lie
he committed perjury
in front of the grand jury
the evidence indicates that he
he did lie he testified before the grand
jury that quote my goal in this
deposition was to be truthful but not
particularly helpful
i was determined to walk through the
minefield of this deposition without
violating the law and i believe i did
contrary to this testimony the president
was alone with ms lewinsky when she was
not delivering papers which he even
conceded in his grand jury statement so
he lied in the deposition then when he
said he wasn't alone with her in the
deposition the president swore that he
could not recall ever being in the oval
office hallway with ms lewinsky except
perhaps when she was delivering pizza
the evidence indicates that he lied
the president swore in the jones
deposition that he could not recall
gifts exchanged between monica lewinsky
and himself
the evidence indicates that he lied
he swore in the deposition that he did
not know whether monica lewinsky had
been served a subpoena to testify in the
jones case at the last time that he saw
her in december 1997
the evidence indicates that he lied
in his deposition the president swore
that the last time he spoke to monica
lewinsky was when she stopped by before
christmas 1997 to see betty curry
at a christmas party
the evidence indicates that he lied
in his deposition in the jones case the
president swore that he didn't know that
his personal friend vernon jordan had
met with monica lewinsky and talked
about the case
the evidence indicates
that he lied
the president and his paula jones
deposition indicated that he was quote
not sure unquote whether he had ever
talked to monica lewinsky about the
possibility that
position indicated that he was quote not
sure unquote whether he had ever talked
to monica lewinsky about the possibility
that she might be asked to testify in
the jones case
can anybody doubt
the evidence indicates that he lied
the president his deposition swore that
the contents of the affidavit executed
by monica lewinsky in the jones case in
which she denied they had a sexual
relationship were absolutely true
the evidence indicates
that he lied
in other words when the president swore
in the grand jury testimony that his
goal in the jones deposition was to be
truthful but not particularly helpful
the evidence is clear that he lied and
committed the crime of perjury in as
much as he had quite intentionally
lied on numerous occasions in his
deposition testimony in the jones case
his intention in that deposition
was to be untruthful
that's what it was all about
to be untruthful
and so he committed the crime of perjury
in front of the grand jury
big time
the third part of article one concerning
grand jury perjury relates to his not
telling the truth
about
false and misleading statements his
attorney robert bennett
unintentionally mr bennett by the way
but nonetheless false and misleading
statements robert bennett made the judge
right during the president's uh jones
case deposition now we've been over that
a lot i don't want to bore you with
going over all those details again
but this is the third part
of the perjury count as well as an
obstruction of justice count
during the president's deposition in the
jones case mr bennett however
unintentionally on his part misled the
court when he said quote counsel
counsel for mrs jones is fully aware
that ms lewinsky has filed
has an affidavit which they are in
possession of saying that there is no
sex of any kind of any manner shape or
form with president clinton
judge wright as you recall again
interrupted mr bennett expressed her
concern that he might be coaching the
president to which mr bennett responded
quote in preparation of the witness for
this deposition the witness is fully
aware of mrs lewinsky's affidavit
so i have not told him a single thing he
doesn't know in his grand jury testimony
about these statements by mr bennett to
the judge in the jones case the
president testified
quote
i'm not even sure i paid attention to
what he was saying
i didn't pay much attention to this
conversation
which is why when you started asking me
about this i asked to see the deposition
i don't believe i ever even focused on
what mr bennett said in the exact words
he did until i started reading this
transcript carefully at this hearing
that moment the whole argument just
passed me by unquote
and so testifying before the grand jury
the president lied
and committed the crime of perjury
as you saw yesterday in the video
during this portion of that deposition
when mr bennett was discussing this
matter with judge wright the president
directly looked at mr bennett paying
close attention to his argument to judge
wright
he lied about that
to the grand jury he committed perjury
when he said that he wasn't paying
attention and he didn't know what mr
bennett was saying
several of the most blatant examples of
grand jury purge found in that portion
of his testimony cited in the fourth
part the last part of article one
which goes to his efforts the
president's efforts to influence the
testimony of witnesses and to impede the
discovery of evidence in the jones case
the president swore
during the grand jury testimony that he
told ms lewinsky that if the jones
lawyers requested the gifts exchanged
between them
she should provide them
if you believe monica lewinsky's
testimony the president lied and
committed perjury
in her grand jury testimony ms lewinsky
discussed in detail their december 28
meeting where the gifts were discussed
which proceeded by a couple of hours ms
curry's coming to her apartment and
taking the gifts and hiding them under a
bed
as you'll recall
she said she raised with the president
the idea of removing her gifts from her
house and giving them to somebody like
betty curry
and that his response was something to
the effect of let me think about that
she went on to say that from everything
he said to her they were not going to do
anything but keep these gifts private
in a separate sworn statement she
testified she was never under the
impression from anything the president
said that she should turn over the gifts
to the jones attorneys
and obviously
she didn't have the idea that she should
do that because she gave them all to
betty curry to hide under the bed
when the president
told the grand jurors
that he was simply trying to refresh his
recollection
when he made a series of statements to
betty curry the day after his deposition
he lied and committed perjury
as i've already pointed out to you today
the evidence is compelling that those
statements such as
i was never really alone with monica
wright were made to try to influence
betty curry's possible testimony so she
would corroborate him
his cover stories and his other fault
statements and lies that he'd given the
previous day in the jones deposition if
she recalls a witness if you conclude
that these series of statements
constituted witness tampering and
obstruction of justice
then you must also conclude that the
president committed perjury when he
asserted that the sole purpose of these
statements to betty curry were to
refresh his recollection
you have to
even if you were to buy the president's
council suggestion these statements
might have been made to influence her in
order to corrupt for him to corroborate
not an actual testimony in a court case
but for the press which they've said
again to us i know they'll say it to you
you would still conclude that he was
lying when he said that this was simply
to refresh his own recollection
in the context of all of this the idea
that he was refreshing his recollection
by firing off these declarative
statements doesn't make sense it just
doesn't make sense if you read the
statements and think about them on the
face they're inherently inconsistent
with refreshing his recollection
also the president told the grand jury
that the things he told his top aides
about his relationship with monica
lewinsky may have been misleading but
they were true
if you believe the aids testified
truthfully to the grand jury
about what the president told them about
his relationship
the president told them many falsehoods
absolute falsehoods
so when the president described them
under oath to the grand jury as
truths he lied and committed the crime
of perjury
one example of this comes from deputy
chief john podesta his testimony before
the grand jury on january the 23rd that
the president explicitly told him that
he and monica lewinsky had not had oral
sex
another is sidney blumenthal his
testimony on january 23rd
was that on january 23rd the president
told him that monica lewinsky quote came
at me and made a sexual demand on me
unquote
and that he rebuffed her
and also blumenthal's testimony that the
president told him that lewinsky
threatened him and said she would tell
people that they'd had an affair and
that she was known as a stalker
among her peers
in short the president lied numerous
times before the grand jury
my colleagues he lied numerous times
under oath
last august the 17th
he committed perjury numerous times
under oath
he certainly wasn't caught by surprise
by any of this by any of the questions
arrested him during the grand jury
appearance and he was given a lot of
latitude
he was given
latitude normally that grand jury
witnesses don't have to give a prepared
statement to have his counsel present to
refuse to answer questions
without taking the fifth amendment
it's hard to imagine a case where it's
clear that the lies meet the threshold
of the crime of perjury
but i'll leave the discussion the
elements of the law to the next group
that's going to come up here
the facts are clear that the president
lied about having sexual relations with
monica lewinsky even under his
understanding of the definition of the
jones case if you believe monica he lied
when he said he gave truthful testimony
in his jones deposition he lied when he
said he wasn't paying attention to his
attorney's discussion of monica
lewinsky's false affidavit during his
deposition in the jones case
he lied when he said he told monica
lewinsky she should turn over the gifts
to the jones lawyers
if they asked for them he lied when he
told the grand jury that he made the
declaratory statements to betty curry to
refresh
his recollection
and he lied when he told the grand jury
that he only told the truth to his white
house aides such as john podesta who
testified the president told him he had
not had oral sex with lewinsky and to
sidney blumenthal who testified he told
him very exaggerated and highly untrue
characterizations of monica lewinsky's
role in all of this
these impeachment proceedings aren't
before you because of one or two lies
about a sexual relationship
this is not
about sex this is about obstruction of
justice this is about a pattern this is
about a scheme this is about a lot of
lies this is about a lot of perjury
there before you because the president
lied again and again in a project
fashion to a grand jury and tried to get
a number of people other people to lie
under oath in the jones lawsuit and to
the grand jury and encourage the
concealment of evidence
now in a couple of days the president's
lawyers are going to have their chance
to talk to you and i suspect they'll try
to get you to focus on 10
or 15 or 20 or 30 or maybe even a
hundred specific little details
they're going to argue that don't square
with these details don't square with
some of the facts
about this presentation
but i would encourage you never to lose
sight of the totality
of this scheme to lie and obstruct
justice
never lose sight of the big picture
don't lose sight of the forest for the
trees it's easy to do because there are
a lot of facts in this case
i would suggest you avoid considering
any of this stuff in isolation
and treating them separately the
evidence and the testimony needs to be
viewed as a whole the weight we call it
in the law and you're going to hear that
in a few minutes the weight
of the evidence in this case is very
great it's huge
in its volume
that the president engaged in a scheme
starting in december 1997 to conceal
from the court in the jones case his
true relationship with monica lewinsky
and then cover up his acts of
concealment which he had to know
by that time were serious crimes
the case against the president
rests to a great extent
on whether or not you believe monica
lewinsky but it's also based
on the soren testimony of vernon jordan
betty curry sydney blumenthal john
podesta the corroborating witnesses
time and again
the president says one thing and they
say something entirely different
time and again
somebody is not telling the truth
and time and again
an analysis in the context
and the motivation and all of the
testimony taken together with common
sense says it's the president
who is not
telling the truth
but if you have serious doubts about the
truthfulness of any of these witnesses i
again as all of my colleagues do
encourage you
to bring them in here
let's examine monica lewinsky vernon
jordan betty curry and the other key
witnesses let you
examine the testimony invite the
president to come judge for yourself
their credibility
but on the record the weight of the
evidence taken from what we have given
you today what you can read in all of
these books back here everything taken
together is huge that the president lied
it's refutable but it's not refutable if
somebody doesn't come in here besides
just making an argument
i don't know what the witnesses will say
but i assume if they're consistent
they'll say the same that's in here but
you've got a chance to determine whether
they're telling the truth and only way
you'll ever know that
other than just accepting it if you
think the evidence and the weight is
that huge and it may be
is by looking them in the eye
and determining their credibility
i believe that when you finish hearing
and weighing all of the evidence
you conclude as i have
that william jefferson clinton
committed the crimes of obstruction of
justice
witness tampering and perjury
that these in this case are high crimes
and misdemeanors
that he has done grave damage to our
system of justice
and leaving him in office
would do more
and that he should be removed from
office
as president of the united states
thank you
mr chief justice
the chair recognizes the majority leader
mr chief justice i ask unanimous consent
that there now be a recess of the
proceedings for 15 minutes please return
to your positions within 15 minutes the
absence of objection is so ordered
as you just heard senate majority leader
trent lott asking for a 15-minute recess
the senate standing in
hi how are you hi
short time go ahead uh well i just
wanted to say that myself my family my
friends everybody i know they in the
last election they pretty much voted
democrat down the line because i
recognize them i see it happening down
the road
mr chief justice
as
all senators do return to the chamber i
believe now we're going to go through a
segment where we will hear from three of
the managers congressman gipas geekis
shupit and kennan and we will take
another break
shortly after 3 30.
the chair recognizes mr manager gigas
mr chief justice
counsel for the president
colleagues from the house
and members of the senate
up to now you have been
fully informed of the state of the
record in this case
in many different ways from very many
different tonalities uttered by the
managers who so magnificently in my
judgment
wove the story that began in
1997 and ended
not yet
but that
narrative that the
managers were able to produce for you
and put on the record has met even as we
speak with
commentary in the public
that
we've all known all of this before
but the big difference is
that now it is part of the history of
the country it is lodged in the records
of the senate of the united states
and together with the congressional
record of the proceedings that preceded
these those in the house
we now have the dawning of the final
chapters
of this
particular incident involving the
president
in which you will have the final word
but that's what the importance was of
what you have heard up to now the
complete record woven together step by
step
so that no one in his chamber at this
juncture does not know all the facts
that
are pertinent to this case
that is a magnificent accomplishment on
the part of the managers
but the record is not yet complete
and that is where i and
representative shabbat
representative cannon and representative
barr come in
so that now we can take the next step in
fulfillment of the record
and that is to try to apply the
statutory laws
the laws of our nation
as they obtain to
the facts that you now have well
ingrained into your consciousness
and to do that
we have to repeat some of the facts some
of these matters overlap
and so
the attention that you've given to the
matters at hand up to now your undivided
attention is
needed continuously
for instance
we cannot
discuss even the application of these
statutes to the facts
unless we repeat
the series of events that catapulted us
to this moment in history
and we must begin
as you have heard countless times now on
and off this floor
we must begin with
in my judgment
with the supreme court
of the united states with all due
deference
to the chief justice
because the supreme court
at one point in this saga
determined
in a suit brought by paula jones
that indeed an average day-to-day
ordinary citizen of our nation
would have the right
to have a day in court as it were
even against the president of the united
states it is there that all of this
began
because that fellow american paula jones
no matter how she may have been
described by
commentators and pundits and
talking heads etc did have a bundle of
rights
at her command
and those rights
went even to the core of
of our system of justice to bring the
president into the case as a defender
that is an awesome
a grand result
of the supreme court decision at that
juncture
and this is what is being overlooked in
my judgment as we pursue
why we believe that
if perjury indeed
was committed and the record is replete
that is in fact it was if indeed
obstruction of justice was
finally
committed by the president united states
as the evidence is abundant to
demonstrate
then
we must apply the rights of paula jones
to what has transpired
we are not saying that the president
even though the weight of the evidence
demonstrates it amply
should be
convicted of the impeachment which has
brought us to this floor
because he committed perjury just
because he committed perjury or
obstructed justice
but because as a result of
his actions
both in rendering falsehoods under oath
as the evidence demonstrates amply or in
obstructing justice
that because of his conduct
he attempted to
or succeeded in
or almost succeeded in
and doesn't matter which of these
results
finally emerges
attempted to destroy the rights
of a fellow american citizen that is
what the graverman of all that has
occurred up to now really is
in attempting to obstruct justice
we mean by that
obstructing the justice of whom
it was an attempt a bold attempt one
that succeeded in some respect
to obstruct the justice sought by a
fellow american citizen
that is heavy
that is soul-searching in its quality
that goes beyond those who would say he
committed perjury about sex so what
that goes beyond saying this is just
about sex
so what everybody lies about sex
but when you combine all the features of
the actions of the present united states
and you see that they are funneled and
tunneled and aimed and targeted towards
obliterating from the landscape the
rights of paula jones a fellow american
citizen
then you must take a second look at your
own
assertion that so what it's just a
question of fact
about sex
many of the
members of this chamber and the others
have already acknowledged that the
president
has lied under oath
but then they're quick to add that
so what which is so disturbing
in view of the results of
what has happened in this case
when
before the house of representatives as
part of your record we had a a group of
academicians professors testifying
professor higa bottom
who
since sadly i must relate has passed
away since his appearance then
was trying to show how
futile it was for us to even attempt to
to append perjury to an indictable
prosecutable offense that nowhere in the
country is it prosecuted regularly and
it's so trivial because it's based on
sex he went on to give a kind of a an
example of how trivial is would you
expect he was asking us and i'm
paraphrasing him i know would you expect
uh to indict the president of the united
states for perjure if he lied that in in
a 55 55 mile speed limit even though he
was going 56
that he would say i was only going 51
would you indict him on that
in the repartee that i had with him at
that juncture i asked him
would he
feel the same
if as a result of that
for jurious testimony about only going
51 miles an hour
that there was a victim in the case
that this might be a
tort case an involuntary manslaughter
case a negligence case in which someone
died as a result of an automobile
accident case and the issue at hand
would be the speeding speed limit
would he feel the same way if as a
result of the
perjury committed as to the rate of
speed
that someone's rights were erased from
the case by virtue of that perjury
the gentleman acknowledged that that
made a difference and that's what the
difference is here the perjury per se if
that be a phrase that we
lawyers can adopt the perjury for save
is almost a given
pursuant to the commentary that we've
heard from
people in and out of this chamber
but
when you add to it
the the the terrible consequence
of seeing a fellow citizen
pursuing justice
thwarted
stopped in her tracks as it were
by reason of the actions of the
president
that is what the core issue here is
and to take it then from
the
the the status of what consequence it
had to to that fellow american citizen
to the next step
is in my judgment an easier one to go to
the determination of whether or not
there was an impeachable offense
my colleagues will show you how the law
of perjury and the law of obstruction of
justice fits
fit into this this pattern of factual
circumstance that we bring to you but in
the meantime
we must recount even at the risk of
overlapping in some of the testimony
that following
the
initial
recognition by the president that there
was going to be
a witness list and that monica lewinsky
would eventually appear as she did on
that witness list this occurred
which is little
examined thus far
in the world of the scandal in which
we're all participants and that is this
the first item of business on the part
of the jones lawyers
in pursuing the rights of paula jones
was to issue a set of interrogatories
a discovery procedure
that is well recognized in our courts
all over the land
a set of interrogatories arrives at the
president's desk
at this juncture
this is way before
the president appeared at the
depositions about which you know
everything now
the facts have been related to you in a
hundred different ways and you know that
pretty well i know you do
but did you know did you can you fasten
your attention for a moment
knowing that this happened in
depositions on a month before on
december the 23rd 1997 when with the
president had in front of him were
interrogatories
that said
that asked did he ever have
sexual relations with anyone
other than his spouse
during the time that he was governor of
arkansas
or president of the united states
and there the president answered
or i think that the the the
enterographers stated name
any
persons with whom you've had sexual
assault in your life and the answer that
the president rendered in those
interrogatories under oath
was
none
i say to the ladies and gentlemen of the
senate
that this was the first falsehood stated
under oath
which became a chain reaction of
falsehoods
under oath
and even without the oath
all the way to the nuclear explosion of
falsehoods that were
uttered in the grand jury in august of
1998
this little innocuous piece of paper
called interrogator
was placed before the president
presumably with or without counsel but
let's even presume with counsel
and it was a straight question
not with any definitions no confusing
colloquy between a judge and a gaggle of
lawyers
no
interpreted interpretation being put on
any particular word in the
interrogatories but
whether or not sexual relations had been
urged or participated in by the
president of the united states and the
answer was none
in naming those persons what does that
mean to you
does that not mean to you
that when confronted right at the outset
with
the phrase sexual relations that the
president adopted
and
determined
the common usage
well understood definition of sexual
relations that everybody in america
recognizes as being the true meaning of
sexual relations meaning sex of any kind
did not the president answer that under
the common understanding that all of us
entertain when we discuss if
more so in the last year than ever
before in our lives
the
phrase sexual relations
to me that's a telling feature in this
case
because when you leap over that and get
to the depositions
and everything that the president might
have said in those depositions
as his counsel have repeatedly asserted
to us was true that he did not lie that
he did not commit perjury that he did
not evade the truth that
some of it was puzzling to them even but
that it did not amount to perjury can
they say that about the statement one
month before on december 23rd in the
interrogatories that's extremely
important
now that is my recollection yours is the
one we'll have to predominate of course
but the weight that i put on it
i urge you to at least evaluate as you
begin to level your weight on the
evidence that has been presented
and if that were not enough on january
the 15th again before the deposition
another interrogatory this one a request
for documents
was submitted to the president and again
the the questioning there was and you'll
see it in the record it's in the record
the
request for document says to submit
anything
that pertained to monica lewinsky the
intern or employee monica lewinsky of
whatever description notes gifts
whatever and the president in that
particular instance again
said
none
i'm willing to give the president a
reasonable doubt on that and even ask
you if if you don't place as much weight
on it as i do to forget all about that
but the point is that these assertions
under oath were made
before
the jones deposition was ever even
conceived let alone undertaken on
january the 17th
and so
he cannot the president cannot
use the
the lawyer talk and judge banter
and the descriptions and definitions of
sexual relations to cloud the answers
that he gave at that time and all of
this in the continuous effort to destroy
the rights of paula jones
a fellow american citizen
that brings up the question if if
someone
a member of your family
or or someone who is
a witness to these proceedings
had a serious case
in which oneself one's property one's
family has been severely damaged
would you suffer without a whimper
per jurious testimony given against you
would you know
down deep that at the end of the day has
caused you to lose your chance at
retribution at a chance to be
compensated for damages to restore your
family life
isn't that what our system is all about
isn't that what
the adverse consequence is
of the attempt
to obliterate
the paula jones civil suit
that's what it is not he committed
perjury so what
it is what the end result of that
perjury might be that you should weigh
skip over the fact that he committed
perjury we all acknowledge that it is
said
but now tell me what that does to paula
jones
or potentially could do to paula jones
or to one of you or you're one of your
spouses or to one of a member of your
community who wants to have
justice done in the courts
obstruction of justice is obstruction of
justice to an individual or to a family
you can take from paula jones and
telescope but upwards to every community
and every courthouse in every state and
every community in our land
and there is a paula jones eager to
assert certain rights
and then be confronted with someone who
would tear it down
by false testimony by
lies under oath
that is what the government of all of
this
really is
one more thing
the council for the president
have repeatedly
and very authoritatively and
professionally
have asserted as many of you have
that this is not an impeachable offense
for after all they say an impeachable
offense
an impeachable offense is one
in which there is a direct attack
on the system of government
not perjury
not obstruction of justice
so what on those
they imply
they say it does not perjury
especially about sex attack the system
of government
i must tell you
that as an eight or nine or ten year old
i would accompany my mother
to
naturalization school
three or four nights a week where my
mother was intent on learning the
english language
and learning about the history of the
united states as the teachers for
naturalization were preparing these
prospective citizens
and she was so proud
that she learned that the first
president of the united states was
george washington was prepared to answer
that question if it was posed to her at
naturalization court and she was so
proud
when i was testing her and preparing her
each time i said mom what are the three
branches of government and she would say
the exec
and the legislator
and the judiciary
in her wonderful
lovable accent
she knew the system of government and
she did have to answer that at
naturalization court and she knew that
one
wall of the three that protect our
rights is the judicial
she knew that the courthouse
and the the rights of citizens
which are advanced in that courthouse is
are the system of government
can anyone say that
purposely
attempting to destroy someone's case in
the courthouse
is not
an attack on the system
of government
of our country
mr shabbat
will elucidate on perjury
the chair recognized as mr manager
shabbat
mr chief justice
senators
distinguished counsel for the president
i'm steve shabbat and i represent the
first district of ohio
prior to my election of congress i
practiced law in cincinnati for about 15
years
as i stand before you today i must admit
that i feel a long way away from that
small neighborhood law practice that i
had
but while this arena may be somewhat
foreign to me
the law remains the same
as one of the managers who represents
the house
i am here to summarize the law of
perjury while today's discussion of the
law may not be as captivating as
yesterday's discussion of the facts it
is nevertheless essential that we
thoroughly review the law as we move
forward in this historic process
i will try to lay out the law of perjury
as succinctly as i can without using an
extraordinary amount of the summit's
time
but i beg you to indulge me
in the united states criminal code there
are two perjury offenses the offenses
are found in sections 1621 and 1623
of title 18 of the united states
criminal code
section 1621
is the broad jury status the broad
perjury statute which makes it a federal
offense to knowingly and willfully make
a false statement about a material
matter while under oath
section 1623 is the more specific
perjury statute which makes it a federal
offense to knowingly make a false
statement about a material matter while
under oath before a federal court or
before a federal grand jury
it is a well settled rule that when two
criminal statutes overlap the government
may charge a defendant under either one
as you know the president's false
statements covered in the first
impeachment article were made before a
federal grand jury therefore section
1623
is the most relevant statute however
section 1621
is applicable as well
the elements of perjury
there are four general elements of
perjury they are an oath
an intent
falsity
and materiality
i'd like to walk you through each of
those elements at this time
first the oath
the oath need not be administered in any
particular form
but it must be administered by person or
body legally authorized to do so in this
case there has been no serious challenge
made to the legitimacy of the oaths
administered to the president either in
a civil deposition in the jones versus
clinton case or before the federal grand
jury
let's once again witness president
clinton
swearing to tell the truth
before a federal grand jury
the oath element has clearly been
satisfied in this case the next element
is intent
to this day
the president has refused to acknowledge
what the vast majority of americans know
to be true
that he knowingly lied under oath the
president's continued inability to tell
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth has forced this body
this jury to determine the president's
true intent
the intent element requires that the
false testimony was knowingly stated and
described
this requirement is generally satisfied
by proof that the defendant knew his
testimony was false at the time it was
provided
as with almost all perjury cases you
will have to make a decision regarding
the president's knowledge of his own
false statements based on the
surrounding facts and yes by
circumstantial evidence
this does not in any way weaken the case
against the president
in the absence of an admission by the
defendant relying on circumstantial
evidence is virtually the only way to
prove the crime of perjury
the federal jury instructions which
federal courts use in perjury cases can
provide helpful guidance in
understanding what is meant by the
requirement that the false statement
must be made knowingly
let me quote from the federal jury
instructions
when the word knowingly is used it means
that the defendant realized what he was
doing
and was aware of the nature of his
conduct and did not act through
ignorance mistake or accident
so as you reflect
on the president's carefully calculated
statements remember the federal jury
instructions and ask a few simple
questions
did the president realize what he was
doing what he was saying
was he aware of the nature of his
conduct
or did the president simply act through
ignorance mistake or accident
the answers to these questions are
undeniably clear even to the president's
own attorneys
in fact mr roth and mr craig testified
before the judiciary committee that the
president willfully misled the court
let's listen to mr ruff
but did he lie i i'm going to respond
your question
i have no doubt
that he walked up to a line that he
thought he understood
reasonable people and you maybe
have reached this conclusion could
determine that he crossed over that line
and then what for him
was
truthful but misleading or
non-responsive and misleading or evasive
was in fact false
in an extraordinary admission the
president's own attorney has
acknowledged the care
the intention the will of the president
to say precisely what he said
the president's actions speak volumes
about his intent to make false
statements under oath for example the
president called his secretary betty
curry within hours of concluding his
civil deposition
and asked her to come to the white house
the following day
the president president clinton then
recited false characterizations to her
about his relationship with ms lewinsky
as you've already heard ms curry
testified that the president made the
following statements to her
you were always there when she was there
right
we were never really alone
you could see and hear everything
monica came on to me and i never touched
her right
she wanted to have sex with me i can't
do that
this is not the conduct of someone who
believed he had testified truthfully
it is not the conduct of someone who
acted through ignorance mistake or
accident
rather
it is the conduct of someone who lied
knew he had lied
and needed others to modify their
stories accordingly
finally
it is painstakingly clear during the
president's grand jury testimony that he
again knows exactly what he's doing
let's again watch the following excerpt
from that testimony
was an utterly false statement
is that correct
it depends upon what the meaning of the
word is
is
in this instance and in many others that
have been presented to you over the last
two days
the facts and the laws speak plainly
the president's actions and demeanor
make the case that president clinton
knowingly and willfully lied under oath
in a grand jury proceeding and in a
civil deposition the compelling evidence
in this case satisfies the intent
element required under both sections
1621 and 1623 of the federal criminal
code
the next element falsity
the next element of perjury is falsity
in order
for perjury to occur in this case the
president must have made one or more
false statements
yesterday my colleagues went through the
evidence on this matter in great detail
and clearly demonstrated that the
president did in fact make false
statements while under oath
because of the evidence that was
presented to date without question
the president's falsity and his false
statements have been shown so i'm going
to move forward to the final element of
perjury which is materiality
the test for whether a statement is
material as stated by the supreme court
in kungis versus united states is simply
whether it had a natural tendency to
influence
or was capable of influencing the
official proceeding
the law also makes clear that the false
statement does not have to actually
impede the grand jury's investigation
for the statement to be material
the law regarding the materiality of
false statements before a grand jury is
very straightforward
because a grand jury's authorities to
investigate is broad the realm of
declarations regarded as material is
broad
the president's false statements to the
grand jury were material because the
grand jury was investigating whether the
president had obstructed justice and
committed perjury in a civil deposition
now let's look at potential legal smoke
screens
the president's attorneys will try to
distract you
from the relevant law and facts in this
case to help you stay focused on the law
i would like to preview some of the
arguments that may be made by the
president's attorneys
legal smoke screen number one the
bronston case
you will probably hear opposing counsel
argue that the president did not
technically commit perjury and appeal to
the case of bronston versus united
states
this is a legal smoke screen
in the bronston case the supreme court
held that the state that statements that
are literally truthful
and non-responsive cannot by themselves
form the basis for perjury conviction
this is the cornerstone of the
president's defense
however the court also held that the
unresponsive statements must be
technically true
in order to prevent a perjury conviction
such statements must not be capable of
being conclusively proven false
as we've seen none of the president's
perjurious statements before the grand
jury covered in the first impeachment
article are technically true
so when the president's council cites
the bronston case remember the facts and
ask yourselves
are the president's answers literally
true
and remember to be literally true
they must actually be true
it is also important to note that
consistent with the bronston case the
response i don't recall
is not technically true
if the president actually could
recall
the factual record in the case
consisting of multiple sworn statements
contradicting the president's testimony
and highly specific corroborating
evidence demonstrates that the
president's statements were not
literally true or legally accurate
on the contrary
the record establishes that the
president repeatedly lied
he repeatedly deceived he repeatedly
feigned
forgetfulness
there are other clear and important
limitations on the bronston case's scope
in us versus disarm handed down just
three months ago by the sixth circuit
court of appeals the court made an
important ruling that is directly on
point in this case
the court of appeals stated and i quote
because we believe that the crime of
perjury depends not only upon the
clarity of the questioning itself
but also upon the knowledge and
reasonable understanding of the
testifier president clinton
as to what is meant by the questioning
we hold that a defendant may be found
guilty of perjury if a jury could find
beyond a reasonable doubt from the
evidence presented
that the defendant knew what the
question meant
and gave knowingly untruthful and
materially misleading answers in
response
the bronston case has further
limitations for example in united states
versus swindle
the court held that the jury can convict
for perjury
even if the questions or statements
involved are capable of multiple
interpretations where only one
interpretation is reasonable under the
circumstances surrounding their
utterance
in united states versus dougherty the
court held that the prosecution for
perjury is not barred under bronston and
i quote
whenever some ambiguity can be found
by an implausibly strained reading of
the question posed
i would submit to this body
that implausibly strained reading of the
questions posed is precisely what
confronts us time and again
in the case of the president before the
grand jury
legal smoke screen number two
the two witness rule
in the coming days you may hear opposing
counsel argue that the president did not
commit perjury by appealing to the
so-called two witness rule
again this is nothing but a legal smoke
screen
this common law rule requires that there
be either two witnesses to a progeria
statement or in the alternative that
there be one witness and corroborating
evidence of the perjury
opposing counsel may suggest that
because there were not two witnesses
present for some of the president's
false statements he did not technically
commit perjury
such an appeal to the two witness rule
is wrong for several reasons
first
the two witness rule is not applicable
under section 1623 only under 1621
the language of 1623 expressly provides
and i quote it shall not be necessary
that such proof be made by any
particular number of witnesses or by
documentary or other type of evidence
congress passed section 1623 back in
1970 to eliminate the two witness
requirement and to facilitate the
prosecution of perjury and enhance the
reliability of testimony before federal
courts and federal grand juries
the legislative history establishes this
as the fundamental purpose of the
statute
additionally substantial evidence has
been presented over the last two days to
satisfy the requirements of the two
witness rule under section 1621
remember
when the two witness rule applies it
does not actually require two witnesses
indeed it requires either two witnesses
or
one witness
and corroborating evidence as you know
there is a witness to each and every one
of the president's false statements and
there is voluminous evidence which
corroborates the falsehood of his
statements
finally case law tells us that the two
witness rule is not applicable under
certain circumstances when the defendant
falsely claims an inability to recall
a material matter
another possible legal smoke screen
the drafting of article one
article one being the first article of
impeachment
as you know
impeachment article 1 says that
and i quote
contrary to that oath william jefferson
clinton willfully provided for jurious
false
and misleading testimony to the grand
jury
you may hear opposing counsel argue that
section 1621 is the only applicable
statute because the article of
impeachment accuses the president of
willfully committing perjury this is
another legal smoke screen
following that reasoning one could just
as easily make the argument that 1623
was contemplated here because the term
false does not appear in 1621 but does
appear in 1623
however that's not the point the point
is that the language of the impeachment
article did not use these terms as terms
of art as they are defined and used in
various criminal statutes
while the article of impeachment does
not draw a distinction between the
standards
evidence has been presented over the
last two days that demonstrates that the
president did knowingly and willfully
lie under oath regarding material
matters before a grand jury and that
satisfies both 1623 and 1621
again in the context of perjury law this
the distinction
between a knowing falsehood and a
willful falsehood is almost a
distinction without a difference an
american surety company versus sullivan
the second circuit stated that the word
willful
even in a criminal statute means no more
than the the person charged with the
duty
knows what is he is doing
so that in essence
is the law of perjury
mr chief justice members of the senate
throughout this long and difficult
process
apologists for the president have
maintained that his actions might well
have been reprehensible
but are not necessarily worthy of
impeachment and removal from office
i would submit however
that telling the truth under oath is
critically important to our judicial
system and that perjury of which i
believe a compelling case is being made
strikes a terrible blow against
the machinery of justice in this country
the president of the united states the
chief law enforcement officer of this
land
lied under oath
he raised his right hand and he swore to
tell the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth
and then he lied pure and simple why is
perjury such a serious offense
under the american system of justice
our courts are charged with seeking the
truth
every day american citizens raise their
right hands in courtrooms across the
country and take an oath to tell the
truth
breaking that oath cripples our justice
system
by lying under oath the president did
not just commit perjury and offense
punishable under our criminal code but
he chipped away at the very cornerstone
of our judicial system
the first chief justice of the united
states supreme court
john jay
eloquently stated why perjury is so
dangerous over two hundred years ago
on june 25th
1792
in a charge to the grand jury of the
circuit court for the district of
vermont the chief justice said and i
quote independent
of the abominable insult which perjury
offers to the divine being
there is no crime more extensively
pernicious to society
it discolors and poisons the streams of
justice
and by substituting falsehood for truth
saps the foundations of personal and
public rights
controversies of various kinds exist at
all times in all communities to decide
them the courts of justice are
instituted their decisions must be
regulated by evidence and the greater
part of evidence will always consist of
the testimony of witnesses
this testimony is given under those
solemn obligations which an appeal to
the god of truth imposed
and if oaths which ceased to be held
sacred
our dearest and most valuable rights
would become insecure
why has the president been impeached by
the united states house of
representatives
why is he on trial here today in the
united states senate
because he lied under oath
because he committed perjury
because if oaths cease to be held sacred
our dearest and most valuable valuable
rights will become insecure
during the course of this trial
members of this distinguished body the
jurors in this case
will have to consider the law and the
facts very carefully it is a daunting
task and an awesome responsibility one
that cannot be taken lightly
i would humbly suggest to those sitting
in judgment of the president
that we must all weigh the impact of our
actions not only on our beloved nation
today but on american history
it is my belief that if the actions of
the president are ultimately disregarded
or minimized
we will be sending a sorry message to
the american people that the president
of the united states
is above the law
we will be sending a message to our
children to my children but telling the
truth doesn't really matter
if you've got a good lawyer
or you're an exceptionally skilled liar
that would be tragic
mr chief justice senators
let us instead
send a message to the american people
and to the boys and girls who will be
studying american history in the years
to come that no person
is above the law
and that this great nation
remains an entity governed by the rule
of law
let us do what is right
let us do what is just thank you
the chair recognizes mr manager cannon
mr chief justice senators
distinguished counsel for the president
my name is chris cannon i represent
utah's third congressional district
john locke once said wherever law ends
tyranny begins and speaking to our
american experience teddy roosevelt
added no man is above the law and no man
is below it
nor do we ask any man's permission when
we require him to obey the law obedience
to the law is demanded by right
not as a favor
this case is about the violation of law
my task is to clarify what the law
states pertaining to the obstruction of
justice and what legal precedent and uh
is applicable to the charges against
william jefferson clinton
well both the laws and the violations in
this case are clear and direct the
presentation i'm about to make it will
not be simple i ask your
indulgence and attention as i walk you
through case history and statutory
elements i promise to be brief probably
less than a half an hour and direct i
will present the legal underpinnings of
the law of obstruction of justice
you should have before you uh both the
text of this speech including the full
citations to the cases and cognitive
charts that i will use in this
presentation
i have uh
article two of the articles of
impeachment alleges that the president
prevented obstructed and uh and impeded
the administration of justice both
personally and through his subordinates
and agents and that he did so
as part of a pattern designed to delay
impede cover up and conceal the
existence
of evidence and testimony related to a
federal civil rights action brought
against him article two specifies seven
separate instances in which the
president acted to obstruct justice
the house believes the evidence in this
case proves that each of the seven
separate acts which comprise the
president's scheme constitute
obstruction of justice i'd like to draw
your attention this time to
the chart at my right and the first page
in your packet which depicts section
elements of section 1503
whoever corruptly influences obstructs
or impedes or endeavors to influence
obstruction or impede the due
administration of justice shall be
punished as provided in subsection b the
punishment for an offense under this
section is imprisonment for not more
than 10 years a fine under this title or
both
section 1503 is often referred to as the
uh as the general obstruction statute it
describes obstruction simply as an
impact on the due administration of
justice
section 1503 deems it criminal to use
force or threats or to otherwise act
corruptly in order to influence obstruct
or impede the new administration of
justice
federal court rulings i clarified that
it is not necessary for the defendant to
succeed in obstructing justice again i
direct your attention to the chart or
the accompanying chart in your packet
russell and aguilar each ruled that it
is not necessary that a defendant
endeavor a defendant's endeavor succeed
for him to have violated the law rather
simply attempting to influence obstruct
or impede the due administration of
justice violates the statute
maggot clearly stated it is the endeavor
to bring about the forbidden result and
not the success in actually achieving
the result that is forbidden
for the government to prove a section
1503 crime you must demonstrate that the
defendant acted with intent this can be
shown through the use of force
threats or by threats by the defendant
or by simply showing that the defendant
acted corruptly the following chart
gives three case histories regarding the
term acting corruptly
haldeman and specker held that a
defendant acts corruptly by having an
intent or by having an evil or improper
purpose and intent
barfield defined acting corruptly as
knowingly and intentionally acting in
order to encourage obstruction specker
also ruled that the government need not
prove the actual intent of the defendant
rather the intent to act corruptly can
be inferred from the proof
that the defendant knew his corrupt
actions would obstruct the justice of
being administered under section 1503
the government must uh also prove that
the defendant endeavored to influence
obstruct or impede the new
administration of justice the statute is
broadly applicable to all phases of
judicial proceedings
in
brenson
describe new administration of justice
as providing a protective cloak over all
judicial proceedings regardless of the
stage in which the improper activity
occurs
londol clarifies that section 1503 is
also intended to protect the discovery
phase of judicial proceedings stating
that the phase phrase do administration
of justice is intended to provide a free
and fair opportunity to every litigant
in a case pending in the federal court
to learn what he may learn concerning
the material facts and to exercise his
option
to introduce testimony or such facts
the house believes the facts of this
case make it very clear that the
president did corruptly impair the
ability of a litigant in federal court
to learn all the facts that she was
entitled to learn in doing so the
president committed obstruction of
justice under section 1503
the other federal crime which the
president committed was witness
tampering under section 1512 of title
18. again i refer you to the chart on my
right
and to the second page in your packet
which depicts the elements of the
section
whoever knowingly corrupts knowingly
corruptly persuades another person or
attempts to do so or engages in
misleading conduct toward another person
with the intent to one influence delay
or prevent the testimony of any person
in an official proceeding or to
cause or induce any person to withhold
testimony or to withhold a document or
an object from an official proceeding
shall be fined under this title or
imprisoned for not more than 10 years or
both
sections 1503 and 1512 differ in an
important way there does not need to be
a case pending at the time the defendant
acts to violate the law under section
1512. the statute specifically states
that for the purpose of this section an
official proceeding need not be pending
or about to be instituted
at the time of the offense for the crime
to be committed putting it another way a
person may attempt to tamper with a
witness and commit the crime of witness
tampering before such a person is called
as a witness and even before there is a
case underway in which that person might
be called to testify
the government to prove the crime of
witness tampering it must prove that the
defendant acted with the intent to cause
one of several results the defendant can
be convicted if he acted to influence
delay or prevent the testimony of any
person in any official proceeding or the
defendant can be convicted if he acted
to cause another person to withhold an
object from an official proceeding in
the case before us the evidence proves
that the president endeavored to cause
both of these results on several
occasions
and the government may show intent on
the part of the defendant in several
ways it may prove the use of
intimidation physical force or threats
or it may prove intent by showing the
use of corrupt persuasion or misleading
conduct in this case the evidence shows
that on several occasions the president
acted corruptly to persuade some
witnesses and engaged in misleading
conduct toward others in order to
influence their testimony and cause them
to withhold evidence or give wrongful
testimony in each instant
instance the president violated the
witness tampering statute
how does acting corruptly to persuade a
witness differ from misleading
engaging in visiting conduct section
1515 of title 18 states as used in
section 1512 that's the witness
tampering section of this title and this
section the term misleading conduct
means knowingly making a false statement
or intentionally omitting information
from a statement and thereby causing a
portion of such statement to be
misleading or intentionally concealing a
material fact and thereby cause creating
a false impression
by such statement or with intent to
mislead knowingly submitting or inviting
reliance on a writing
or recording that is false forged
altered or otherwise lacking
authenticity the difference then between
corruptly persuading a witness and
engaging in misleading conduct toward
the witness depends on the witnesses
level of knowledge about the truth of
the defendant's statement
rotlitz held that misleading conduct
involves a situation where a defendant
tells a potential witness a false story
as if the story were true intending that
the witness believed the story and
testified to it before a grand jury
let me clarify this detail if a
defendant simply asks a witness to lie
and the witness knows that he is being
asked to lie then the defendant is
corruptly persuading the witness in
contrast if a defendant lies to witness
hoping the witness will believe the
story and this this is misleading
conduct they are different but they are
both criminal
some may ask if it is necessary that the
witness who is influenced or tampered
with know that he or she might be called
to testify the answer is no and both
sections 1503 and 1512 answer this
question the witness tampering statute
can be violated even if the victim has
not been subpoenaed or listed as a
potential witness in an ongoing
proceeding
in shannon the u.s court of appeals for
the 8th circuit reviewed the conviction
of a defendant under section 1503 who
had attempted to influence the testimony
of a person who had not yet been
subpoenaed or placed on a witness list
on appeal the defendant argued that
because the target of the obstruction
had not yet become an official witness
in the case it was impossible for the
defendant to have engaged in obstruction
toward her the court of appeals rejected
that assertion in affirming the
conviction the court held neither must
the target be scheduled to testify at
the time of the offense nor must he or
she actually give testimony at a later
time it is only necessary that there is
a possibility that the target of the
defendant's activities be called on to
testify in an official proceeding
the witness statue or the witness
tampering statute can be violated even
when no case is pending therefore it
will not always be clear to whom the
defendant intended the individual to
testify and the statute does not require
proof of this
and morrison the united states court of
appeals for the district of columbia
explained that section 1512 is violated
if the defendant asks the person to lie
to anyone who asks the court held that
it is not necessary that the defendant
even used the words testify or trial
when he tries to influence the testimony
of the other person in such a case there
are no subpoenas there are no witness
lists the mere attempt to influence the
person to lie if asked is the crime
so under either section 1503 or 1512 the
fact that the target of a defendant's
actions is not named as a witness or
that the person is not ever called to be
a witness is immaterial the focus of
both statutes is on what the defendant
believed if the defendant believes that
it is possible that some person might
someday be called to testify at some
later proceeding and then acted to
influence delay or prevent his or her
testimony the defendant commits the
crime
now
some have asserted that an obstruction
of justice charge cannot or should not
be made against the president because
some of his acts occurred in the context
of a civil trial there's simply no merit
to this view there's no question that
the obstruction and witness tampering
statutes can be violated by acts that
occur in civil proceedings
and case law is consistent in upholding
that any attempt influence obstruct or
impede the due administration of justice
in a civil proceeding violates section
1503 lundwall which i referred to
earlier as a perfect example as it began
as a civil case the actual language of
the witness tampering statute makes it
clear that it also applies to civil
cases the statute provides for enhanced
penalties in criminal proceedings a
provision that would be unnecessary if
the law were only to apply to criminal
cases
in short
the fact that some instances of the
president's misconduct occurred in the
course of a civil proceeding does not
absolve him of criminal liability
as mr barr will demonstrate the
president of the united states
endeavored and did obstruct justice and
tamper with witnesses in violation of
the law of the united states on numerous
occasions he acted with an improper
purpose with an intent to interfere with
the new administration of justice in the
federal civil rights lawsuit filed by
paula jones
president clinton
corruptly endeavored to persuade a
witness to lie in some cases he
succeeded in every case he violated the
law
president clinton engaged in misleading
conduct in order to influence the
testimony of witnesses in judicial
proceedings
he succeeded
in each case he violated the law
president clinton acted with an improper
person
purpose to persuade a person to withhold
objects from a judicial proceeding in
which that person was required to
produce them he succeeded and in so
doing he violated the law president
clinton made misleading statements for
the purpose of deterring a litigant from
further discovery that would lead to
facts which the judge ordered relevant
in a federal civil rights case in so
doing he obstructed the due
administration administration of justice
and in that case
and violated the law
whether attempting a to persuade a
person to testify falsely or to ignore
court orders or to produce objects
whether suggesting to an innocent person
a false story in the hopes that he or
she will repeat it in a judicial
proceeding or testifying falsely in the
hopes of blocking other parties pursuit
of the truth all these acts obstruct
justice
all these acts are federal felony crimes
all these acts were committed by william
jefferson clinton thank you
the court recognizes that the chair
recognizes the majority leader mr chief
justice i asked you 100 that there now
be a recess again to the proceedings for
15 minutes please return profit to
change
without objection it's so ordered
in this section
senator will come to order
chair recognize the majority leader mr
chief justice i believe we're ready for
the final segment for today will be
presented by mr manager bar
the chair recognized mr manager barr
mr chief justice senators
learned counsel for the president
and fellow managers
on behalf of the house of
representatives
i thank the senate for the opportunity
to appear today
and to present
this argument
the house and i especially greatly
appreciate the time and effort the
senate has taken on this most important
and notable matter
you have heard the facts summarized
by my colleagues
they have described for you the law of
perjury and the law of obstruction
i will discuss several of the specific
instances
in which william jefferson clinton
violated these laws
as set forth in the articles of
impeachment presented to you
the process facing you as jurors
of fitting the federal law of
obstruction of justice
and of witness tampering
and of perjury
into the facts
of the case against president william
jefferson clinton
is not a case
in which there
is nor should be
a great deal of difficulty
it is not a problem
of fitting a round peg
into a square hole
quite the contrary
we have a case here
you have a case here for consideration
in which the fit between fact and law
is as precise as the finely tuned
mechanism
of a swiss watch
or
as seamless a process
as the convergence and confluence of two
great rivers
such as flow through many of the cities
which you represent
the evidence that president william
jefferson clinton committed perjury and
obstruction of justice
is overwhelming
these are pattern offenses
i beg your attention to the following
exposition of facts and law
but before commencing
i would like to address three
issues
which have come up during the course of
the proceedings
and which i believe might be helpful for
all of us to keep in mind
as we proceed not only through today's
the final presentations the tomorrows
and those made by which will be made by
learned council for the president
first by way of background on the
process that is the process that brings
us house managers to the well of this
great body
the trial
of the president of the united states of
america
as has been
indicated previously by one of my
colleague house managers
and as everyone here knows full well
the responsibilities the jurisdiction
and the process
between the house of representatives and
the senate
is very different in all three of those
respects
and therefore
while coming as no surprise to all of
you and all of us in this room but
perhaps to some in america
the steps that each body takes and
should take and must take are very
different
just as one example
one might ask
why were no witnesses called
in the house of representatives
valid question
deserves a valid answer
that valid answer can be found
not simply in impeachment proceedings
and the history thereof but also
in the day-in day-out proceedings in our
federal courts and in our state courts
it can be found in the difference
between
the body which has responsibility and
jurisdiction for charging a crime
and the jurisdiction and responsibility
of the body
that has responsibility
for trying
a crime
or an alleged crime
the house of representatives though not
in every respect
like a grand jury
operates much more like a grand jury
than a pedigree
as something akin to
a grand jury
we had in mind
and i know you have in mind
being very mindful and knowledgeable
about the difference in procedure
between the house and the senate on
matters of impeachment
that frequently
in court cases presented to federal
grand juries and i suspect similarly to
state grand juries
the evidence to the
grand jurors themselves
is not presented through a long array a
repetitive array of witnesses themselves
witnesses that is with first-hand
knowledge
of each and every fact
which would then later be proved at the
trial rather it is the more standard
procedure
certainly in federal courts with which i
am more familiar
for the government to present its case
to the grand jury
by way of summary witnesses normally
that would mean case agents that have
been working with the assistant u.s
attorneys or with the u.s attorney
in gathering evaluating
the evidence that will eventually be
brought to bear in the trial of the case
if one were to
be a fly on the wall of a federal grand
jury
one would see
normally
witnesses for the government that would
come in and discuss the general
parameters and the specific evidence of
the case that they would present
in court
frequently summarizing
the actual evidence that would be
presented in court by the witnesses
themselves that is the standard
operating procedure that is not to say
that there is also not presented
voluminous
written
evidence documentary evidence that is
frequently the case as well
nor is that to say
that there are not from time to time
cases presented to federal grand juries
in which there are actual witnesses with
first-hand knowledge
i simply make the point
which we are all aware but i think as we
begin or in anticipation of your process
of sifting through
all of this procedure all of this
evidence all of this law
to keep in mind that our job in the
house we approached necessarily
had to approach necessarily very
different from the way you approach your
job as jurors as triers of fact
we in fact
presented to the house of
representatives through the work on our
judiciary committee
a large volume of evidence
presented to us and through us to the
house of representatives as the charging
body not the try or fact body
that's essentially summarized and
discussed
through the words through the opinions
of
the independent council
akin to the chief investigative officer
in a grand jury in federal district
court
through the words
of many expert witnesses as it were
who placed all of that in context
we did not want to usurp your duty your
responsibility
given to you by the jurisdic by the
constitution as the trier of fact
we are not that presumptuous
it is your responsibility it is your
solemn duty to be the trier of fact
that is very different from our solemn
duty which i believe the house
performed admirably
in essentially reaching the conclusion
that there is probable cause
to convict the president
of perjury and obstruction of justice
and we did so in a way that is mindful
and respectful of your responsibilities
they carried out our responsibilities
and that is familiar to citizens all
across this land because it is
essentially the same process
that operates in federal courts
where you see also as here a very clear
distinction between the body that
charges the crime the grand which there
are many in this chamber with a legal
background
but which i think also is important to
keep in mind
as you reflect on and later deliberate
on the evidence itself in this case
and that is that there are indeed
two types of evidence
and in virtually every case whichever
finds its way to a court of law
and results in a trial
both types of evidence
are found used considered and form the
basis legitimately for
the eventual
rendering of a decision by a jury
those two types of evidence are direct
and circumstantial
frequently and i know this from
experience actual experience
defense lawyers
will attack the government's case
and one of the
standard
attacks that they level against the
government's case is
it is based on circumstantial evidence
you even hear that by the
folks out there today
not in this room
that are saying oh
all we're seeing is circumstantial
evidence
and that is not as good as direct
evidence now to the layperson
unfamiliar with the ways of our laws our
courts and the work of this great body
that may have some currency it may have
some surface appeal
they may say well
that commentator was right
that white house spokesman was right
if all they're doing is talking about
circumstantial evidence they can't have
a very strong case because if they had a
strong case they'd have direct evidence
well
the fact of the matter is
it is a principle of long and consistent
standing in every federal court in our
land and i suspect every state court in
our land
that
as directed by every federal judge to
every federal jury taking evidence
circumstantial evidence
is to be and shall not be afforded any
less weight
than direct evidence
and triers of fact are directed by
judges
in every case
not to accord less weight to one type of
evidence
as opposed to the other
that is
in the words of one of my
fellow managers
a smoke screen
a red herring
if somebody raises
as a defense in a case
this case or other cases
that the case is weakened somehow
because there is a reliance on
circumstantial evidence and it is not
founded solely on direct evidence
very important principle
i would appreciate
and appreciate you all's indulgence in
that small foray into some
basic precepts that i think all of us
certainly myself included need to keep
in mind
finally there is one other
sort of process argument that one here
is sort of floating around in the ether
out there
that i think also
is important for all of us to keep in
mind
and that is
facts
and the law
do bear repeating not endless not
pointless
but appropriate repetition
even today
even yesterday in the first round of
presentations to this body there was in
fact repetition of certain facts
certain aspects of the law
that is not presented to you
simply to emphasize a point
simply to make it appear stronger
because we say it five times instead of
two
there is a very important reason
for appropriate repetition
for example
in a case such as this where you have
two sets of laws
alleged to have been violated
perjury laws and obstruction of justice
laws
each one of those has several different
elements
and in addition to that
it is legitimate
as presenters of facts and the law for
managers or
prosecutors or plaintiffs attorneys
to take a particular fact a particular
note
and use it to illustrate several
different points for example
one particular fact
may provide evidence of motive
it may also provide one of the
substantive elements of perjury or
obstruction of justice
or it may go to the state of mind of a
declarant or a witness
it may provide important evidence with
regard to a course of conduct
prior knowledge
and the list goes on
that is why
senators
frequently
in the course of these particular
presentations and again
no different from the course of
presentation in federal and i suspect
state courts throughout the land in
trials
there necessarily is and should be in
order to responsibly present all of the
evidence in all of its elements certain
repetition
our job as managers
is to make sure we do not abuse that
necessity
and that we do not in fact
offer
repetitive
notions repetitive references
without having a very clear and specific
purpose such as i mentioned
for that process
[Applause]
finally
before turning to
that merger of the law and the facts
which i believe will illustrate
conclusively
that this president
has committed and ought to be convicted
on
perjury and obstruction of justice
i would respectfully ask
that you remember that under the law of
impeachment
based on our constitution
proof beyond a reasonable doubt that the
president committed each and every
element of one or more violations of
provisions of the federal criminal code
has never
been required to sustain a conviction
in any prior impeachment trial in the
senate
however
and i can say confidently that i speak
for all house managers
in relating to you
our belief
that the record and the law applicable
to these two articles of impeachment
clearly establishes
that president william jefferson clinton
did in fact
violate several provisions of title 18
of the united states code
that is the criminal code
including perjury
obstruction and tampering with witnesses
at this point a lawyer would say a force
your eye i won't
but i will say at this point that it
therefore goes without saying
that there indeed exists under every
historical standard
every historical benchmark which this
chamber has used
there is more than sufficient grounds on
which you might face a conviction
as to both articles
beginning then in looking at how the
facts
and the law both of which you have heard
through the
words
and exhibits of my colleagues and the
evidence that you already have
let us look first
at the submission of the false affidavit
in the jones case
we believe the evidence presented
clearly establishes that on december
17th of 1997
the president encouraged a witness and a
federal civil rights action brought
against him that witness being monica
lewinsky
to execute a sworn affidavit in that
proceeding which he knew to be
prejudious false and misleading
as other managers have outlined
monica lewinsky filed a sworn affidavit
in the jones case that denied the
relationship between her and the
president
that affidavit was false
ms lewinsky testified under oath before
the grand jury
that the scheme to file this false
affidavit was devised
or hatched
during a telephone conversation
with the president
on december 17 1997
a call the president initiated to miss
lewinsky
at 2 or 2 30 a.m
ostensibly
to give her the bad news that betty
curry's brother had been killed in a car
accident
but apparently since it consumed the
vast majority of the time of that
conversation more importantly
for the president to tell ms lewinsky
her name was on the witness list filed
in the jones case
and to thereafter discussed during that
conversation
the president's suggestion to her
she could file an affidavit in the jones
case
in order
for the purpose of
avoiding having to testify in that case
not to cover up
but in order to avoid having to testify
in an ongoing legal proceeding
in united states district court
she testified both she and the president
understood from their conversation they
would continue
their pattern of covering up
she testified she knew that if she filed
a truthful affidavit
the jones lawyers
would certainly have deposed her in that
case
the testimony of mr vernon jordan
confirms the president knew ms lewinsky
planned to file a false affidavit
he stated
that based on his conversations with the
president
the president knew in advance that miss
lewinsky planned to execute an affidavit
denying
their relationship
and that he later informed the president
miss lewinsky had signed in fact that
false affidavit
for his part the president denies asking
ms lewinsky to execute a false affidavit
instead
as he asserted in his response to the
house judiciary committee's requests for
admission
he seeks to have you now believe
he sought simply to have ms lewinsky
execute an affidavit that would quote
get her out of having to testify
close quote while being factually
correct
this statement reflects a legal
impossibility
the president has admitted miss lewinsky
was the woman with whom he indeed
had an improper intimate relationship
while president
and he has admitted he was very
concerned
over the great personal embarrassment
and humiliation he feared
would have occurred if that relationship
had been revealed
in the jones case
yet he would have you believe
he cannot remember a call he made to
that woman about that case
which occurred at two o'clock in the
morning
his statement
is not credible
and the reason it's not credible is
because it's not true
as mr jordan's grand jury testimony
cooperates the president knew what miss
lewinsky planned to allege in her
affidavit yet the president took no
action to stop her from filing it
as you have heard in earlier
presentations the president's lawyer mr
robert bennett
stated in court directly to judge wright
when he presented the false affidavit
quote there is absolutely no sex of any
kind in any manner shape or form close
quote and that the president was quote
fully aware of ms lewinsky's affidavit
close quote
the president took no action
to correct his lawyer's misstatement
as you have also heard the president in
his grand jury testimony tried to
disingenuously dissect the words
of his attorney
to remove his conduct
from further examination
even though obviously and by any
reasonable interpretation or
inference of the definition given the
president his conduct with ms lewinsky
was covered
and he disavowed knowledge of his
lawyers misrepresentations by claiming
he was not paying attention
that canard has been most stably
disposed of
in prior presentations
both through the words of the managers
and the videotape presentations
later in the deposition
when mr bennett read to the president
the portion of the affidavit
which in which
ms lewinsky denies their relationship
and asked him is this a true and
accurate statement as far as you know it
the president answered
that is absolutely true
this statement
is neither credible
nor true
it is perjury
the inescapable conclusion from this
evidence is that the president has lied
and continues to lie about the affidavit
his continued false statements and
denials about the affidavit bolster the
conclusion of our managers
that in fact he was part of a scheme to
file the false affidavit
the evidence supports ms lewinsky's
account that such a scheme did in fact
exist between them
the evidence and all reasonable
inferences drawn there from
do not support the president's denial
inferences
i respectfully add that in your
deliberations
as in the deliberations of any jury
are to be and should be
based on common sense
and deliberated uh in terms of
the light of your experiences
in judging
human behavior
moreover
in engaging in this course of conduct
referring here to the words of the
obstruction statute
found at
section 1503 of the criminal code
the president's actions constituted
an endeavor to influence or impede the
due administration of justice
in that he was attempting
to prevent the plaintiff in the jones
case from having a free and fair
opportunity
to learn what she may learn
concerning the material facts
surrounding her claim
these acts by the president also
constituted an endeavor
to corruptly persuade
another person
with the intent
to influence the testimony they might
give in an official proceeding
such are the elements
of tampering with witnesses found at
section 1512
of the federal criminal code
miss lewinsky knew full well her only
hope of not having to testify
was to file an affidavit that did not
truthfully reflect
her relationship with the president
the president also knew that if she had
filed a true affidavit
without any doubt
it would have caused the jones lawyers
to seek her further
testimony something both co-conspirators
desperately sought to avoid
in encouraging her to file an affidavit
that would prevent her from having to
testify
president clinton was of necessity
asking her to testify falsely in an
official proceeding
he was attempting to prevent and in fact
did prevent
the plaintiff in that case
from discovering facts which may have
had a bearing on her claim against the
president
his motive was improper
in the language of the law that is
corrupt
and his actions did influence the
testimony of miss lewinsky
as a witness
in the pending official proceeding in
u.s district court
under both
sections
of the federal criminal code that is
1503
obstruction in 1512 obstruction in the
form of witness tampering
the president's conduct
constituted
a federal crime and satisfies the
elements of those statutes
with regard to the issue of perjury
before the grand jury
concerning the affidavit
we as managers would show that when
asked
before the grand jury
whether he had instructed ms lewinsky to
file a truthful affidavit president
clinton testified
did i hope she'd be able to get out of
testifying on an affidavit absolutely
did i want her to execute a false
affidavit no i did not
the evidence however
clearly establishes that the president's
statement constitutes perjury
in violation of section
1623 of the u.s federal criminal code
for the simple reason
the only realistic way
ms lewinsky could get out of having to
testify
based on her affidavit
would be to execute a false affidavit
there was no other way
it could have happened
the president knew this
miss lewinsky knew this
and the president's testimony on this
point is perjury
within the clear meaning
of the federal perjury statute
it was willful
it was knowing
it was material
and it was false
let us reflect
and see also
members of the jury
how the use of cover stories and the
development thereof
ties in
the facts and the law to constitute a
basis on which you might properly find
a conviction
on perjury and obstruction of justice
we as managers believe that the evidence
presented to you also establishes that
on december 17th
the president encouraged a witness in a
federal civil rights action brought
against him to give progeria's false and
misleading testimony
if and when
called to testify personally in that
proceeding
this was in essence the conspiracy
18 usc 371 to commit both obstruction
and perjury
throughout their relationship
the president and ms lewinsky
understandably wish to keep it secret
and they took steps to do that
steps that ultimately turned out to be
and constitute criminal
acts for some time in fact until miss
lewinsky testified under oath and under
a grant of immunity their efforts were
remarkably successful
all things considered all circumstances
considered associates and employees
testified in support of the president's
stories
and even several secret service officers
testified to the grand jury that they
understood ms lewinsky to be in the oval
office to
pick up papers yet
as ms lewinsky testified her white house
job never required her to deliver papers
or obtain the president's signature on
any documents
it was all a sham it was all a cover
story it was all a conspiracy to
obstruct
miss lewinsky testified later after she
left her white house job and went to the
work of the pentagon
that phase two of the cover-up went into
effect
the two co-conspirators began to use
miss curry as a source of clearance into
the white house
this was so even though the purpose
of miss lewinsky's visits were almost
always to simply see the president
as my colleagues have told you on
december 17th
during that 2 a.m
or perhaps it was 2 30
telephone conversation placed by the
president ms lewinsky
he told her her name appeared on the
witness list in the jones case
she testified that at some point in the
conversation the president told her you
know
you can always say you were coming to
see betty or that you were bringing me
letters
miss lewinsky testified
that she understood this to be
quote
really a reminder of things that they
had discussed before close quote
she said it was instantly familiar to
her
he knew or i knew she says
that is miss lewinsky knew
exactly what he meant
and so i respectfully submit to all of
us here know exactly what the president
meant
when the president then was questioned
before the federal grand jury if he ever
had said something like that to ms
lewinsky he admitted that well i might
have
said that
because i certainly didn't want this to
come out if i could help it and i was
concerned about that
a cover story which this was
between two teenagers
trying to steal a date without their
parents knowledge is one thing
such would not constitute a crime
it would be something we might even wink
at
as long as it didn't happen too often
however
we are not here dealing with two love
struck teenagers
trying to circumvent their parents
watchful eyes
we are dealing here with the president
of the united states of america
and a subservient employee
concocting and implementing a scheme
that
while perhaps not illegal in its
inception
simply trying to keep a relationship
private
did in fact deteriorate
into illegality
once it left the realm of private life
and entered that of public obstruction
however and this is critical in terms of
establishing the illegality or
convictibility
of the president's actions
the situation at the time of that early
morning phone call from the president to
ms lewinsky
was very different
from that facing the president during
any earlier discussions
of a cover story
now in early december 1997
ms lewinsky had been officially named as
a witness in a pending judicial
proceeding
she was now under an obligation
to give complete and truthful testimony
and he
the president
was under a legal obligation at that
time
not to tamper with
her
or her possible testimony
this is precisely where private lies
become public obstruction
this is in fact
the bright line between child-like
pranks and deadly serious obstruction of
our legal system
the president and ms lewinsky at that
point entered the big leagues and the
president a highly skilled lawyer knew
it
which is why he went to such lengths to
continue the cover-up for so many
months the president knew that if miss
lewinsky were to testify
that she only brought papers to the
president or to see the president's
secretary
her testimony would have been neither
complete nor truthful
yet the president encouraged her to give
that untruthful testimony
and in so doing
he broke the law of obstruction of
justice and in lying about it
he compounded the problem by breaking
the law of perjury
as mr cannon made clear
with regard to section 1503
the general federal obstruction statute
of the criminal code
a person commits the crime of
obstruction of justice when he attempts
to influence the due administration of
justice which includes all
aspects of any civil or criminal case
including pre-trial discovery
mr clinton's encouragement to ms
lewinsky
to tell something other than the truth
certainly would have influenced the
discovery process in the jones case
courts have consistently held that civil
discovery
is every bit a part of the due
administration of justice protected by
the obstruction statutes
as any other aspect of any other civil
or criminal case
and as mr cannon also made clear
with regard
to section 1512 of the federal criminal
code
a person commits witness tampering when
he attempts to influence another person
to give false testimony in an official
proceeding
mr clinton did encourage ms lewinsky to
give false testimony about her reasons
for being in the white house with the
president
by encouraging her to lie
the president committed the crimes of
obstruction of justice under section
1503
and the crime of witness tampering under
section 1512 of the federal criminal
code
you have also members of the senate
heard
about the president's statements to mrs
curry
on january 18th and then again on the
20th or 21st
the president spoke with her
in what was clearly
demonstrably
unavoidably
another potential witness to be
influenced in the civil rights case
the president did this in this case by
relating to mrs curry
false and misleading accounts of events
about that case
as to which he was going to testify
had testified
and again
with the intent that his recitation of
the so-called facts
would in fact corruptly influence her
testimony
as the managers have previously
described to you the evidence in this
case shows that on that
saturday
january 17th only two and a half hours
after the president had been deposed in
the jones case
he called his secretary
at home
and asked her to come to the white house
the next day a sunday
she testified miss curry that is
testified this was very unusual
it was rare for the president to call
and ask her to come in on a weekend
but of course she did
the next day sunday january 18 1998
at about 5 p.m
she testified to the grand jury that
during her meeting with the president he
said there are several things you may
want to know
he then proceeded to ask her a number of
questions in succession
you were presented evidence of these
five statements by other managers
i will only emphasize that it was at
that time and in that way
in that manner
that the president led mrs curry through
a series of statements and determinate
questions
to establish a set of facts describing
his relationship with ms lewinsky at the
white house that supported
his false testimony
as you have heard ms curry stated under
oath she indicated her agreement with
each of the president's statements even
though she knew
that the president and ms lewinsky had
in fact been alone in the oval office
and in the president's study
prosecutors frequently see this
it's not unknown to prosecutors federal
or state you frequently see this pattern
of agreeing
to things that the person knows are not
true
where you have a dominant person
suggesting
testimony to another person who is in a
subordinate relationship
this i submit is yet another bright line
between a private lie
and public obstruction
during the president's grand jury
testimony he was asked about his
statements to mrs curry he testified he
was trying to determine whether his
recollection
was accurate
as he put it i was trying to get the
facts down i was trying to understand
what the facts were
this fits the same pattern of a classic
obstruction prosecution
in which a defendant
suggests a story to someone
in the hopes that they will later
testify consistent with that earlier
suggestion
indeed when defendants in federal courts
defend against obstruction prosecutions
in those type cases
they frequently rely on the very same
defense
the president raises here
that he was merely and oh so innocently
encouraging the other person to
tell the truth
you may want to see as an example
of an unsuccessful effort at such a
defense
in the case of united states v o'keefe
a fifth circuit case from 1983.
in that case
mr o'keefe did not
ask someone to lie
he did not even say i suggest you lie
rather
as is almost always the case
in white-collar obstruction prosecutions
his words
along with their setting and their
context
suggested a certain story
in that case as well as this a false
story
just as mr o'keefe did not expressly ask
someone to lie
mr clinton never asked someone to lie
he didn't have to
he was too smart for that
and he had witnesses who at that time at
least were willing ready and able to do
his bidding
the president lied to the grand jury
when he made these statements
mischaracterizing his earlier statements
to mrs curry
just as he tampered with her as a likely
witness
nine months earlier in january
the president's assertion
that he simply was trying to understand
what the facts were
lacks even colorable credibility
when one considers that he had already
testified
it was obviously too late to try and
recollect what the facts were
if in fact one accepts that then he's
admitting he didn't testify to what the
facts were under oath at the deposition
because he didn't say i don't know i
have to ask mrs curry he testified under
oath
as to what the facts purportedly were
then he would have us believe that he
had to after the fact
of the deposition go back and find out
what the facts were from somebody else
that is an argument
that cannot be made
with a straight face
in any event mrs curry could not have
told him what the true facts were
because he alone
knew what they were
the defenses and explanations the
president's defenders raised to justify
why the president would make factual
assertions to mrs curry about the
circumstances of his relationship with
miss lewinsky right after his testimony
are many
for example
one administration witness who appeared
before the house judiciary committee
actually suggested
that such coaching
is proper
as a method whereby an attorney prepares
a client or witness for testimony
of course such a suggestion
in this case would be ludicrous
president clinton obviously did not and
could not represent mrs curry as her
attorney
yet it is this sort of explanation
straining credulity
that illustrates the lengths to which
the president's defenders have gone to
try and explain away the obvious
that there was no legitimate reason
why the president made the statements to
mrs curry
after his grand jury testimony other
than to suggest to her what her
testimony should be
in federal criminal trials defendants go
to jail for such obstruction
in the case before you
we submit this clearly forms a proper
basis on which to convict this president
of obstruction of justice
for witness tampering
and subsequent perjury
please keep in mind also it is not
required
that the target of a defendant's actions
actually
testify falsely in fact
the witness tampering statute can be
violated even when there is no
proceeding pending
at the time the defendant acts in
suggesting testimony
as the case is discussed by manager
cannon demonstrate
for a conviction under either section
1503
obstruction or 1512 obstruction by
witness tampering
it is necessary only to show it was
possible the target of the defendant's
actions might be called as a witness
that element has been more than met
under the facts of this case
it was not only likely mrs curry would
be called the president's own testimony
deliberate testimony to the grand jury
pretty much guaranteed that she would be
called he wanted her called so that she
could then buttress his false testimony
his actions clearly we believe violated
both the general obstruction statute and
the witness tampering statute in these
particulars and in this regard
with regard to the obstruction regarding
the subpoena for the president's gifts
to ms lewinsky
let us look at the merger
of the facts and the law as has been
discussed
while the witness tampering statute
makes it a crime to attempt to influence
the testimony of a person
it also makes it a crime to influence a
person to withhold an object from an
official proceeding
in other words to tamper with evidence
the facts of this case
we as house managers believe clearly
show the president corruptly engaged in
encouraged or supported
a scheme
with monica lewinsky and possibly others
to conceal evidence that had been
subpoenaed
lawfully in the jones case
on december 19th of 1997 miss lewinsky
was served with a subpoena in the jones
case
requiring her to produce each and every
gift given to her by the president
then on december 28th
ms lewinsky again met with the president
in the oval office at which time they
exchanged
gifts
they also discussed the fact that the
lawyers in the jones case had subpoenaed
all the president's gifts to ms lewinsky
and especially a hat pin
the hat pin apparently had sentimental
significance to both of them
in that it was the very first gift the
president gave to ms lewinsky
during that conversation
miss lewinsky asked the president
whether she should put the gifts away
outside her house
or give them to someone
maybe
betty
at that time according to miss
lewinsky's sworn testimony the president
responded let me think about that
no apparently he did
because later that day that very same
day only a few hours after ms lewinsky
and the president had met to discuss
what to do with the gifts
miss curry called ms lewinsky setting in
motion the great gift exchange
according to ms lewinsky
mrs curry said i understand that you
have something to give me or the
president said you have something to
give me
in her earlier proffer or or offer of
evidence to the independent counsel
prior to her testimony before the grand
jury
ms lewinsky said
mrs curry had said the president had
told her
that is mrs curry that ms lewinsky
wanted her to hold on to something for
her
after their conversation at the oval
office
mrs curry
drove to ms lewinsky's apartment for
only the second time in her life
there she picked up a box sealed with
tape and on which was written
please
do not throw away
mrs curry then took the box drove to her
home
placed the box under her bed
now at her grand jury testimony mrs
curry testified that she and miss
lewinsky
did not discuss the content of the box
nor did she open it once she got it to
her home
but she knew she understood
what was in the box that it contained
the gifts from the president to ms
lewinsky
in fact ms gwinski testified mrs curry
was not at all confused
surprised or even interested
when she handed the box over to her
the legal impact the illegal import of
this is that there is no question
that if the gifts had actually been
produced to the jones lawyers
they would have established a
significant relationship between the
president and ms lewinsky
knowledge of the gifts at a minimum
would have caused the jones lawyers to
inquire further as to the nature of the
relationship between the president
and ms lewinsky
her failure to turn over the gifts as
required by the lawful subpoena served
on her
was in the words of the witness
tampering statute
the withholding of an object from an
official proceeding
we believe the evidence shows
clearly establishes that the president
corruptly persuaded miss lewinsky to
withhold these objects
from the lawful proceedings in the jones
case
in his grand jury testimony the
president asserted he encouraged miss
lewinsky to turn over the gifts
ms lewinsky's testimony directly
contradicts that
importantly all other evidence of
subsequent acts cooperates her
testimony not the president's
for one thing the gifts were never
turned over
in fact ms lewinsky testified she was
never under any impression from anything
the president said
that she should turn over the gifts
to the attorneys for miss jones
quite the opposite
while the president asserts he never
spoke about this matter with betty curry
he would have us believe
that his personal and confidential
secretary
would on a sunday
drive to the home of the woman with whom
he was having an inappropriate intimate
relationship
take possession of a sealed box which
she believed to contain gifts given by
the president
hide the box under the bed in her home
never questioned the person giving her
the box
and never even mentioned to the
president she had received the box of
gifts
the president's position as he would
have you believe
is not credible
it defies the evidence
it defies any reasonable interpretation
or inference from the evidence
it defies common sense
and it stands in defiance of federal law
the only reasonable interpretation of
the facts is that following the
discussion
between the president of miss lewinsky
earlier in the day on december 28th
the president decided miss lewinsky had
actually come up with a pretty good
suggestion
the gift should be put away outside of
her home
as
jurors you may reasonably presume
that based on the evidence and all
reasonable inferences they're from
along with common sense
that it was the president who directed
mrs curry to call ms lewinsky
to tell her she understood
she had something for her and that
happened to be evidence under lawful
subpoena
in a civil
proceeding in u.s district court
mrs curry would have no independent
reason to even consider such a course of
action on her own
she had never other than one time in her
life ever driven
to ms lewinsky's home
she did so on this sunday
not because
she developed a sudden hankering to do
so
or because she routinely visited interns
at their homes she didn't
or because she had a vision
she did it because
the president would have asked her to do
it
now the president further points out
that mrs curry has testified that ms
lewinsky called her
to arrange to pick up the gifts rather
than the other way around
in fact though mrs curry has testified
inconsistently
as to whether miss lewinsky called her
or she called miss lewinsky
she actually deferred to ms lewinsky's
superior knowledge of the facts
however
even if one one were to accept for
purposes of argument
that it was ms lewinsky who initiated
the call
the president's a vowel that he had no
knowledge of or involvement with the
hiding or transfer of the gifts is still
not plausible
it is totally unreasonable to presume
that the private secretary to the
president of the united states
would drop what she was
doing travel to the home of a former
intern pick up a box and hide it in here
in her home
simply because the former interim
demanded that she do so
all of this
had to have been done reasonably
plausibly credibly was done
because of communication directive and
understanding between the president and
his personal secretary
there's one more point on this
ms lewinsky testified she met with the
president for 45 minutes on december
28th
at which time they discussed the fact
that she had been subpoenaed along with
the need to to conceal the gifts
the president's testimony directly
conflicts with hers on this point
first
the evidence however establishes that
his professed inability to remember
whether she and the gifts had been
subpoenaed
is unbelievable and false
please keep in mind
when evaluating the circumstantial
evidence to determine whether a false
statement was made intentionally
the most important evidence to consider
is the existence of a motive to lie
it is the calculated falsehood combined
with a clear motive to lie
that leads
day in and day out in federal court
proceedings to the conclusion
that
the false statement false statements
were intentional
also
we urge you to bear in mind that the law
will not allow
a person to testify i don't recall or
i'm not sure
when such answers are unreasonable under
the circumstances
former united states representative
patrick swindle
attempted this course of action
when he appeared before a federal grand
jury
in the northern district of georgia in
1988
his evasive and false answers to the
grand jury provided the basis for his
subsequent conviction
feigned
forgetfulness or feigned assertions that
grand jury questions are ambiguous
and therefore cannot be answered
cannot and in fact in federal
proceedings do not shield defendants
from criminal liability for perjury or
impeding the conduct of a federal grand
jury
nor should such efforts be allowed to
shield president clinton
from conviction on these two articles of
impeachment
as to these facts
the president a man of considerable
intelligence and gifted with an
exceptional memory
as somebody described a prodigious
memory
can and should be inferred to have
clearly understood
what he was doing
as well as the logical and reasonable
consequences of his actions
as well as the questions put to him by
the independent counsel
and the grand jury questioning
and he had a clear motive to falsely
state the grand jury that he could not
recall
that he knew on december 28th that miss
lewinsky had been subpoenaed and that
the subpoena called for her to presu
produce the gifts
for to have to acknowledge such
would have helped establish a motive on
his part for orchestrating the
concealment of the gifts
and as we have also seen and understand
there is no doubt the president's
statement of feigned forgetfulness was
material
not only to the matters before the jones
case
but to matters subsequently before the
grand jury
now the president's council may very
well argue the fact that the president
gave miss lewinsky additional gifts on
that same day that is december 28th
as proof of the president's assertions
that he didn't know there was anything
wrong going on here
their argument if they make it cannot be
sustained in the face of so much
evidence to the contrary
the evidence and facts points to a much
more plausible explanation
the additional gifts given that day
demonstrate
the president's continued confidence
that ms lewinsky would keep to their
earlier agreement
to conceal their relationship
it is also plausible that the additional
gifts were intended
as a further gesture of affection
by the president to miss lewinsky to
help ensure she would not testify
against him
such a fact pattern also finds its way
to those of us who have prosecutorial
background into federal courts
on a regular basis
we have heard
about the job search
and its relationship to
perjury and obstruction
let me tie the facts relating to the job
search and the law
applicable there too together
we believe as managers that the evidence
shows that beginning on or about
december 7th of 1997 and continuing
through and including january 14th of
last year the president intensified and
succeeded in an effort to secure job
assistance
for a witness in a federal civil rights
case
brought against him
in order to corruptly prevent the
truthful testimony of that witness in
that proceeding
at a time when the truthful testimony of
that witness would have been harmful to
him
monica lewinsky
is if nothing else
a persistent witness
after she was transferred out of the
white house and after being rebuffed
repeatedly
by others
to
secure
assistance from the president and
gaining a job that met her expectations
and wishes
she decided to
change tax she wrote directly to the
president
asked for and received a meeting
in which she asked him to find her a job
in new york
the day before the president filed his
answers to the interrogatories
in the jones case
as manager geekus discussed
the president asked mrs curry to set up
a meeting for miss lewinsky with mr
vernon jordan
two days after he filed his answers
in which he refused to answer whether he
had ever had any extramarital
relationships in the context of his
public jobs
that meeting in fact occurred
but mr jordan made no particular effort
to assist miss lewinsky at that time
in fact
as he later testified he had no
recollection of the meeting
there was of course at that early stage
no urgency
the situation however changed
dramatically in early december 1997.
on december 6 the president
became aware that miss lewinsky had been
named as a witness in the jones case
earlier that day she had thrown a
tantrum at the white house northwest
gate
when she was unable to meet with the
president when she wanted
despite the president's initial anger
over ms lewinsky's behavior and over the
acts of some of the secret service
officers
a mere five days later
miss lewinsky in fact secured her second
meeting with mr vernon jordan
but this time unlike previously
this powerful washington lawyer jumped
for the former intern
he immediately
placed calls to three major corporations
on her behalf
on december 11th judge wright ordered
the president to answer paula jones's
interrogatories
on december 17 the president suggested
to mrs winsky she file
the affidavit
and continued to use their cover stories
in the event she was asked about her
relationship with the president the next
day
she had two
interviews in new york city
arranged by mr jordan
on december 22nd
ms lewinsky met with an attorney at a
meeting arranged by
mr jordan
the following day she had another job
interview arranged by mr jordan
on january 7th
ms lewinsky signed the false affidavit
and proudly showed the executed copy to
mr jordan
the next day
ms lewinsky had an interview arranged by
mr jordan with mcandrews and forbes in
new york city
an interview that apparently
went poorly
to remedy this she called mr jordan
and so informed him
mr jordan then called the ceo
of mc andrews and forbes mr ron perlman
two
in mr jordan's words for two in mr
pearlman's words make things happen if
they could happen
after mr jordan's call to mr pearlman
ms lewinsky was called and told she
would be interviewed again the very next
morning
that following day she was
re-interviewed and immediately offered a
job
she then called mr jordan to tell him
and he passed the information on to mrs
curry
tell the president
mission accomplished
now what are you as jurors
entitled to conclude from all of this as
a matter of law and a fact
until it became clear that ms lewinsky
would be a witness in the jones case
little was done to help her with her job
search
but once she was listed as a witness
things changed dramatically and rapidly
just days after she is listed on the
jones witness list
she gets a second meeting with one of
the most influential men in washington
but unlike their first meeting
mr jordan now makes three calls on her
behalf to get her a job interview
a week later the president proposed the
affidavit
the next day ms lewinsky has two job
interviews in new york
a few days later mr jordan arranges for
an attorney to represent her the next
day she has another job interview two
weeks later she signs the affidavit the
next day she has another interview
mission
accomplished
obstruction
accomplished
another potentially embarrassing witness
in the bag
were monica lewinsky to get a job and
move to new york
this would help the president
substantially in two very important ways
first
it would presumably
create a happy and probably compliant
witness
one willing if not eager to support the
president's false testimony
second
it would make miss lewinsky much more
difficult if not impossible
to reach
as a witness in the jones case
in fact this is precisely what the
president himself suggested to miss
lewinsky
during their december 28th meeting
according to her sworn testimony
to put it plainly
but respectfully
if that is not obstruction by witness
tampering
one would be hard pressed to find a fact
pattern that was
this aspect of the case against the
president is extremely important
she gets the job
and what did the president get
the key affidavit to throw the jones
lawyers off the trail
and possibly a witness outside the
practical reach of the attorneys
much like the absent witnesses we've
seen in large numbers
in the campaign financing investigations
the president's efforts were designed to
and did obstruct justice and tamper with
a witness
and his actions we submit
were criminal
under both sections 1503 and 1512 of the
federal criminal code
the president's false statements
to his senior aides
here too
the facts and the law
come together and would form the basis
we respectfully submit
for a conviction
on articles of impeachment
all that needs to be shown to prove a
violation of the statute is that the
defendant engaged in misleading conduct
with another person to influence that
testimony
misleading conduct
is not a term of art for which there is
no definition it is specifically defined
in the federal criminal code
as section 1515
when you as jurors properly apply these
definitions to the terms of section 1512
the tampering statute
the federal with the and then turn your
attention to the facts in this case
wherein the president repeatedly and
deliberately gave
false explanation to aides he knew or
should reasonably have known
would be witnesses in federal judicial
proceedings
the conclusion he violated this statute
is we respectfully submit
unavoidable
would point to one case previously
mentioned the o'keefe case
as particularly perhaps applicable to
deliberations on this particular point
finally statements by the president and
his lawyer concerning the affidavit
during the jones deposition
the obstruction statute may also be
violated as you know by a person who
gives false testimony
in the jones case the president allowed
his attorney
to make false and misleading statements
to a federal judge
this part of the obstruction scheme was
accomplished by characterizing as true
the false affidavit filed by ms lewinsky
in order to prevent questioning by the
jones lawyers
testimony which had already been deemed
relevant by the judge in that case
the president's lawyer as you have heard
objected to the innuendo of certain
questions asked to the president
and at that point
during the deposition pointed out that
miss lewinsky had signed an affidavit
denying the relationship with the
president
he then made the famous statement about
there being no relationship of any way
shape or form or kind
following this statement
the judge right judge wright warned mr
bennett about making an assertion of
fact in front of the witness that is the
president to which he replied i am not
coaching the witness
in preparation of the witness for this
deposition
the witness is fully aware of the
affidavit so i have not told him a
single thing he doesn't know
the president's lawyers did not know
what an understatement that was
later
on september 30th of 1998
long after the deposition and after the
full evidence of ms lewinsky's
relationship with the president became
public
mr bennett wrote to judge wright
to inform her that she should not rely
on the statements he made during the
president's deposition
because
parts of the affidavit were misleading
and not true
misleading and not true
sounds like perjury
sounds like obstruction
which brings us full circle
full circle from a false affidavit
concerning confirming earlier concocted
cover stories
through a web of obstruction
to a letter from a distinguished lawyer
forced to do what no lawyer wants to do
but every honorable lawyer must do when
confronted with clear evidence
their client has misled a court and that
is to correct the record of falsity
even to the detriment of their client
what we have before our senators and mr
chief justice is really not complex
critically important yes
but not essentially complex
virtually every federal or state
prosecutor and there are many
distinguished such persons
on this jury
have prosecuted such cases of
obstruction before in their careers
perhaps repeatedly
cases involving patterns of obstruction
compounded by subsequent cover-up
perjury
the president's lawyers may very well
try to weave a spell of complexity over
the facts of this case
they may nitpick over the time of a call
or parse a specific word or phrase of
testimony
much as the president has done
we urge you to distinguish jurors in
this case
not to be fooled
use
from ohio mr chief justice i
object
to the use and the continued use of the
word jurors
when referring to the senate
sitting as triers
in a trial on the impeachment of the
president of the united states
mr chief justice i base my objection
on the following
first
article 1 section 3 of the constitution
says the senate shall have the sole
power to try all impeachments
not the courts
but the senate
article three of the constitution
says
the trial of all crimes except in the
cases of impeachment
shall be by jury
a tremendous exculpatory clause
when it comes to impeachments
next mr chief justice i base my
objection
on the writings in the federalist papers
especially federalist paper number 65 by
alexander hamilton
in which he is outlining the reasons why
the framers of the constitution gave to
the senate the sole power to try
impeachments
i won't read it all but i will read this
pertinent sentence
where mr hamilton says and i quote
there will be no jury
to stand between the judges
who are to pronounce the sentence of the
law
and the party who is to receive
or to suffer it
next mr chief just as i base my
objection
on the 26 rules of the senate adopted by
the senate
governing
impeachments
nowhere in any of those 26 rules is the
word juror or jury
ever use
next mr chief justice i i base my
objection
on the tremendous differences between
regular jurors
and senators sitting
as triers
of an impeachment
regular jurors of course
are chosen to the maximum extent
possible with no knowledge of the case
not so when we try impeachments
regular jurors are not supposed to know
each other
not so here
regular jurors cannot overrule the judge
not so here
regular jurors do not decide what
evidence should be heard or the
standards of evidence nor they do they
decide on witnesses or what witnesses
shall be called
not so here
regular jurors do not decide when a
trial is to be ended not so here
now
mr chief justice
it may seem a small point
but i think a very important point
i think the framers of the constitution
meant us
the senate to be something other than a
jury
not jurors
what we do here today
is not just to decide the fate of one
man
since the senate sits on impeachment so
rarely
and even more rarely on the impeachment
of a president of the united states
what we do here sets precedence
future generations will look back on
this trial
not just to find out what happened
but to try to decide what principles
governed our actions
to leave the impression for future
generations
that we somehow are jurors and acting as
a jury chief justice could i call for
regular order at this point
the chair recognizes the senator from
new hampshire
i would ask as a parliamentary point
whether it's appropriate to argue
what i understand as a statement
as to the proper reference
relative to members of the senate this
is not a motion
as i understand it if his emotion is not
debatable as i understand
mr chief justice
yes i i i think you may state your
objection certainly but not argue out
the chair if you views that you may
state the objection and some reason for
it but not argue with uh odd uh infinite
yes i was just stating the reason for my
objection because of the precedence that
we set
and that i do not believe it would be a
valid precedent to leave for future
generations that we would be looked upon
merely as jurors
but something other than being a juror
and that's why i raised that objection
mr chief justice
the the chair is of the view that the
senator from iowa's objection is well
taken that the court the senate is not
simply a jury it is a court
in this case and therefore council
should refrain from referring to
senators as jurors
i thank the court for its ruling
we urge you
the distinguished senators sitting as
triers
of fact and law in this case
not to be fooled
we urge you to use your common sense
your reason
your varied and successful career
experiences
just as any
trier of fact and law
anywhere in america might do
just as does
that other
trier of fact and law
do so too have each of you sworn to
decide these momentous matters
impartially
your oath to look to the law and to our
constitution demand this of you
as this great body has done on so many
occasions in the course of our nation's
history
i and all managers are confident you
will neither shrink from nor cast aside
that duty
rather i urge
and fully anticipate you will look to
the volume of facts
and to the clear and fully applicable
statutes
and conclude that william jefferson
clinton in fact and under the law
violated his oath and violated the laws
of this land and convict him on both
articles of impeachment
even though such a high burden that is
proof of criminal violations
is not strictly required of you
under the law of impeachment
in fact such evidence
is here
that higher burden
is met
perjury
is here
obstruction
is here in the facts and the law
which formed the basis
for the articles of impeachment in the
house in which we believe
properly would form the basis for
conviction in the senate
perjury and obstruction
we respectfully
ask you to strike down these insidious
cancers that eat at the heart of our
system of government and laws
strike them down with the constitution
so they might not fester as a gaping
wound poisoning future generations of
children
poisoning our court system and perhaps
even future generations of political
leaders
just as members
of both houses of congress have
unfortunately over the years
been convicted and removed from office
for perjury and obstruction
and just as federal judges
have been removed from life tenure
for perjury and obstruction
so must a president
so sadly
should this president
thank you mr chief justice and thank you
members of the united states senate
sitting here
as priors of fact and law in the trial
of president william jefferson clinton
the chair recognizes the majority leader
mr chief justice uh as a reminder to all
participants in these proceedings we
will begin at 10 a.m on saturday uh
january the 16th and we're expected to
conclude sometime between 3 and 3 30 p.m
i'd earlier indicated it might go as
late as 5. i understand it'll be between
3 or 3 30. and therefore mischief
justice pursuant to the previous consent
agreement on i ask unanimous consent to
send standing german under the previous
order
without objection it is so ordered
you